Auf der Baustelle aus dem Apple Store Berlin. Wir berichten live von den Fortschritten beim Apple Store Berlin. Und zwar ist da jetzt hektisches Schrauben angesagt und ab jetzt arbeiten sie auch Tag und Nacht an der Baustelle. Also es wird sozusagen Nachtschicht eingeführt worden. Und an den Innen ist alles noch so ein bisschen halikadiert. Ein Laden, der zwei Jahre hergerichtet wird, das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Zwei Jahre bauen die an diesem Scheiß. Naja, da geht ja nichts voran.
Toll!
Zwei Jahre.
Toll, Apple!
Toll!
Zwei Jahre.
Oh, eine Eilmeldung!
Mobile Max aktuell!
Ich bin mir da noch nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, aber ich deute das mal so als 99 Prozent. Dieser Apple Store wird keine Glas-Drehung.
Dann ist es einfach funktional kaputt.
Herzlich Willkommen bei BUMZACK RETURN.
Ja, das war's.
Wenn wir hier keine Glastreppe haben, dann sollen die auch keine Glastreppe haben.
Irgendwie ist hier noch Musik.
Ja, man nennt das Intro. Jetzt ist es weg.
Das hatten wir doch noch nie.
Was? Doch immer.
Dass diese Musik dann noch so ewig im Hintergrund mitschwirrt. Das ist mir heute das erste Mal aufgefallen.
Ja, irgendwann ist ja immer das erste Mal.
Aber irgendwie...
Du fühlst dich unruhig, unwohl.
Der Kopfhörer ist irgendwie... Nee, der ist in seiner Soundwiedergabefähigkeit eingeschränkt.
Und das ist übersteuert.
Ist das jetzt zu leise oder?
Nee, also der ist irgendwie so...
Ist auch leise. Kannst du auch ein bisschen lauter machen?
Ja, ich weiß. Okay, wir probieren das einfach mal.
Ich hab noch mehr. Also ich kann ja auch einen anderen geben, wenn es für dich schlimm ist.
Momentan geht's. Hab ich den richtigen Stuhl oder ist das der elektrostatische, der gleich wieder...
Also du musst auch keine Elektroschläge oder so weiter befürchten. Alle Bestrafungen sind dann einfach gerechtfertigt und nicht auf mangelndes Equipment zurückzuführen. Na Huckel, dann sag ich mal hallo Huckel, weil das ist ja hier Mobile Max 109. Und am revolutionären 1. Mai gibt's natürlich auch eine revolutionäre Sendung.
So sieht's aus.
Nicht wahr? Und Huckel ist mit dabei, ihr habt's schon gehört.
Direkt frisch aus dem Kreuzberg.
Genau, eingeflogen, weil Straßen sind alle dicht.
Genau, Dennis ist auch da.
Aus Mitte.
Aus Mitte, direkt eingeflogen, weil Straßen sind ja alle dicht.
Nee, von Mitte ist alles schick.
Ach so, von Mitte ist alles super.
Wie bei Apple ist ja der Wald gerade, da ist ja Freifahrt.
Ja, das stimmt. Ja, Clemens wiederum ist noch unterwegs, der muss sich noch, glaub ich, durch Kreuzberg durchschlagen.
Durchschlagen, ha ha.
Ja, er muss wahrscheinlich jetzt noch irgendwelche Barrikaden beseitigen. Um dann hier auch noch zu weilen. Nicht da ist Roddi, weil der kann nicht.
Weil der mitten an Kreuzberg wohnt. Der wohnt bei mir um die Ecke, aber der war so involviert, den konnte ich da nicht mehr rausschleusen, der war einfach...
Komm, Roddi, lass die Bullen in Frieden. Mai ist 1.
Mai.
Also ich muss den zurücklassen.
Muss man verstehen. Aber ist egal, wir sind ja pfiffig.
Er meinte, geh ohne mich weiter. Komm wenigstens du zum Mobile-Max-Podcast.
Und wir haben einen würdigen Ersatz gefunden, nämlich Dirk. Hallo Dirk.
Hallo.
Guten Tag. Wir müssen unsere Telefone noch davon abhalten.
Ich bin aus dem Friedrichshain gut hergekommen.
Ah ja, so, so. Da brennt es also noch nicht so richtig.
Nee, da war nix.
Auf der ganzen Strasse.
Die Revolution hat es noch nicht bis Friedrichshain geschafft. Ja, genau. Dirk wollte schon häufiger mal vorbeikommen.
Aber wir haben ihn nicht gelassen?
Wir haben ihn nicht gelassen, wir haben ihn zappeln lassen.
Fünf Monate haben wir ihn zappeln lassen.
Wirklich, so lange? Wir mussten ja als eine personelle Umstellung exerziert haben.
Wie viele iPhones hast du?
Also das ist nicht meins, aber ich habe ein iPhone. Da haben wir die Erklärung. Das ist ein iPhone 4. Das habe ich seit das 4GS, ne wie hieß das? 4S hieß das. Seit das 4S rausgekommen ist. Ja. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass es schon alt war, als ich es gekriegt habe.
Naja, das kann man aber auch schnell erklären, weil Dirk gehört jetzt zu den anderen.
Eigentlich ja nicht, eigentlich ist der Dirk ja, den kennen wir ja schon lange, aber seitdem ich ihn kenne, ist er ja auch eigentlich ein Apple Fanboy.
Absolut, seit 1995. Aber mit dem iPhone haben sie es echt übertrieben, also bei mir zumindest.
Und dann bist du gleich zum Erzfeind gegangen und dachtest, du gehst mal auf die andere Seite der Mauer.
Ich geh mal hier, wie wäre das? It's open.
Du bist aus der einen Zellentür raus und bist gleich in die nächste rein. Anstatt mal zu flüchten.
Wo hätte ich denn hingehen sollen, ich mag nur Mobiltelefone.
Dirk ist jetzt bei der offenen Seite der Macht.
Bei der offenen Seite der Zelle.
Wer hier viel Mitter-Ebene hört, der könnte Dirk aber auch schon mal gehört haben. Und zwar im CAE, da warst du nämlich schon dreimal. Einmal haben wir lang gesprochen, zusammen mit Bocke, über Java, CAE 90, dann über Android, welch Wunder. CAE 152 mit Rodja Trappe und gemeinsam mit Daniel Mack haben wir auch mal lange und breit über E-Mail geschwatzt. Weil du bist ja eigentlich auch so ein Hardcore-Backender, kann man sagen.
Du warst vor zwei Jahren, ja.
Du hast die Seiten gewechselt.
Genau, da wollte ich nicht mehr Backend machen, weil ich das nicht so interessant fand. Android mache ich seit November 2008, da habe ich mein Telefon bekommen, dieses HTC Dream. Ich habe es immer noch, es funktioniert auch immer noch. Wirklich? Ja, aber man will es nicht mehr benutzen. Es war damals schon eine harte Prüfung für mich, das zu benutzen, aber ich bin dabei geblieben.
Und du castest auch Pod? Du hast nämlich einen eigenen Podcast zum Thema Android und der heißt?
Der heißt Pandroid, der ganzheitliche Android-Podcast. Den mache ich mit Volkers Freunde, der gerade im Chat gesagt hat, ich soll mal den Podcast pluggen.
Hatten wir hier schon auf der Liste. Wer hier zu Gast ist, darf auch pluggen.
Ja, genau, den machen wir jetzt auch regelmäßig, wenn ich schon mal dabei bin. Einmal im Monat, nämlich am ersten Dienstag im Monat, also nächste Woche Dienstag die nächste Folge. Ja, auch live auf Xenim. Also seit wir das live auf Xenim machen, machen wir es auch regelmäßig.
Ja, absolut.
Die Ankündigung und dann ist klar, auf den Punkt hin, da geht es wieder los.
Wie ist denn das mit diesem Xenim, muss man sich da anmelden für einen Slot und muss dann hoffen, dass der noch frei ist?
Nee, das ist egal. Du könnt den liebigen vielen gleichzeitig senden.
Also die haben da keine Limits.
Aber du musst da sozusagen Mitglied... Nein. Also man muss da fragen und dann gucken sie, ob es irgendwie in ihr Repertoire passt.
Ob ihnen deine Fresse gefällt.
Aber jetzt mal ganz ehrlich.
Wie jetzt ganz ehrlich?
Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich hier, ja? Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich sein. Ist denn diese Xenim Mehrwert gegenüber einem eigenen Icecast oder was auch immer für ein Cast-Server so viel?
Wir haben vorher auch schon live gestreamt, aber da hatte der Betreiber des Servers immer Schiss, dass wenn wir den Link twittern, dass dann sein Server zusammenbricht. Und die Angst muss man bei Xenim einfach nicht haben.
Also Xenim ist ein Community-Projekt und der Unterschied zu einem normalen Server ist der, dass das halt ganz ordentlich skaliert. Also es gibt da eigentlich keinerlei Erfolgsprobleme, weil das ja da round-robin-mäßig auf mehrere Server verteilt wird. Das heißt, wenn jetzt hier viele Leute... Also in diesem Fall jetzt nehme ich mal an, werden wir gleichzeitig über sechs verschiedene Server gestreamt. Aber es läuft halt alles über dasselbe Frontend, alles über dieselbe URL, die dann halt entsprechend weitergeleitet wird.
Und senden wir mit 128k bit oder mit...?
Wir senden, glaube ich, nur mit 64k bit. Warum?
Ich überlege gerade, wie viel Bandbreite das jetzt sozusagen... Wenig. Ja, für den anderen Podcast, den ich ja da jetzt gerade tue, da machen wir noch kein Live-Streaming. Und irgendwie hätte ich jetzt halt auch mal überlegt, das einfach selber zu machen. Und dachte mir, okay, so viel kann das doch alles nicht kosten. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie so 500 Live-Hörer üblicherweise oder so in dem Dreh. Oder? Im Mobile Max, ja.
Ja, es schwankt, ich weiß nicht.
Aber sagen wir mal, wir haben 500, 64 Kbps.
Also wir eigentlich haben ja natürlich nur 499, weil mehr sind ja nicht möglich. Also da weißt du ja, das Internet hat so eine automatische Begrenzung und die endet halt derzeit bei 499. Was ganz praktisch ist, weil ab 500 bräuchten wir ja auch eine Lizenz.
Eine Rundfunkstaatsvertrags-Lizenz?
Ja, da fallen wir halt nicht rein, weil wir benutzen Internet und das Internet, weiß jeder, ist einfach auf 499 begrenzt.
Dafür wählen Sie jetzt die Telekom. Okay, naja gut, sagen wir, wir haben 499, dann sind das ja laut Wolfram Alpha hier. Irgendwie 32 MB die Sekunde, nee Kilobit die Sekunde doch, das heißt 32 MB die Sekunde.
Ja, und dann musst du auch noch ein bisschen was tun, um die rauszuschicken, also nicht nur Bandbreite, sondern auch.
Ja, stimmt.
Die CPU muss ich auch noch ein bisschen bewegen.
Aber wir haben ja noch nicht so viele Hörer. Ich bin halt gerade so auch so ein bisschen am Gucken, wie diese ganze Podcasting, Infrastruktur, Geschichten, Landschaft also aussieht und was man so selber machen kann und was man halt nicht selber machen kann. Und weil ich habe ja schon mal einen Xenon, einen Eiskaster aufgesetzt auf meiner Maschine und ja.
Also Xenon ist sehr bequem und sehr zuverlässig und ich kann da nur Gutes drüber sagen. Aber wir hatten ja schon mal Probleme, die Leute wissen, wann deine Sendung kommt.
Wir hatten ja schon auch Probleme mit Xenon.
Ja, aber die Probleme, die wir jetzt hier hatten, haben sich nicht wirklich bestätigt, dass das mit Xenon zu tun hat, sondern ich habe ja hier allerlei Debugging betrieben, weil wir ja dummerweise immer, während Mobamex gab es diese Ausfälle. Bei NSFW hatte ich die komischerweise nie. Und hier ist es glaube ich jetzt drei oder vier oder fünf Mal sogar vorgekommen. Ich habe jetzt allerdings das Device, was ich gerade in Verdacht habe, getauscht. Und das war ja der Ethernet-Switch. Ich habe hier so einen normalen Stino 16-Port Gigabit-Switch benutzt. SMC, irgendwas, Rujimin. Und auf Clemens Empfehlung bin ich jetzt auf Cisco umgestiegen. Ist jetzt noch nicht besonders konfiguriert, aber ich hoffe mal, dass jetzt die Brand-Hardware hier besser performt. Es handelt sich hierbei um einen Cisco SG300-20. Also ich glaube faktisch zählt das tatsächlich als Cisco, weil das halt quasi eben so ein Gerät aus ihrer Profi-Modellpalette ist und wo iOS draufläuft, soweit ich weiß. Aber das können wir uns vielleicht nachher von Clemens nochmal erläutern lassen. Da wollte ich das Thema eh nochmal aufrufen. Auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt die Hoffnung, ob sie sich erfüllt, werden wir sehen, dass diese Ausfälle nicht mehr stattfinden. Weil es machte einfach den Eindruck, dass es an dem Switch lag. Ich kann es nicht mit allerletzter Sicherheit sagen, aber so wie sich das hier manifestiert hat, diese Problematik, nämlich, dass hier nicht nur der Stream nach draußen abgerissen ist, sondern auch intern die Verbindung, wo der einzige Knotenpunkt einfach dieser Switch war, ich wüsste nicht, was es sonst noch hätte sein können. Und jetzt haben wir die Komponente getauscht und wir hoffen alle, dass das jetzt hier ein bisschen zuverlässiger strömt aus der Metaebene. Was noch zu Xenim zu sagen ist, und was ich auch auf jeden Fall einen wichtigen Faktor finde, ist, auch Xenim ist ja sozusagen nochmal so eine eigene Community und du machst natürlich auch deinen Podcast darüber dann auch bekannter, dass du da quasi sendest. Das ist so ein bisschen wie so ein Sender.
Ja, genau. Die Leute haben die iPhone-App installiert und kriegen dann eine Push-Notifizierung oder überhaupt die Liste der Podcasts.
Wir sind da auf jeden Fall sehr dankbar.
Da können wir an dieser Stelle auch nochmal zum Ausdruck bringen. Vielen Dank hier an Kato und wer auch sonst noch rund um die Xenim-Gemeinde hier das zum Laufen bringt immer wieder. Und natürlich auch die Leute, die die Bandbreite spenden, auch wenn das so häufig natürlich so noch verfügbare Kontingente sind, die dann halt leergesogen wird, bis die Drossel kommt.
Na gut, ich flatter sie ja auch schon.
Xenim kann dir auch echt den Arsch retten, weil eine Sendung, da habe ich irgendwie die Fails nicht richtig runterkopiert gehabt von dem Server, auf dem wir mal aufzeichnen, und war dann zu Hause und wollte die Sendung hochladen und war nicht. Und dann im Stream war sie halt noch drin, da muss ich nur vorne was wegschneiden, hinten was wegschneiden.
Und Xenim macht halt noch einen Backup.
Genau, und die bleiben da auch. Lustigerweise, weiß gar nicht, ob ich das laut sagen darf, aber man kann da alle Sendungen sehen, wenn man da irgendwie...
Wenn man da so ein Element aus dem Pass rausnimmt.
Das ist nicht erlaubt im Internet alle Sendungen zu sehen.
Aber ich wollte noch mal kurz was zu den 500 Hörern sagen. Also müsste sich da nicht mal so ein Verfassungsrechtler-Anwalt irgendwie angesprochen fühlen, weil ich meine, in der Verfassung steht doch, dass jeder senden darf. Und wieso darf ich nicht an mehr als 500 Leute senden?
Du darfst, du musst nur bloß eine Lizenz holen.
Ja, eben ich darf nicht, weil die Lizenz kriege ich doch nicht, oder?
Doch, also wieso nicht?
Na, YouTube hat keine gekriegt.
Was?
Na, das ist doch der Grund, warum YouTube die Live-Hangouts nicht in Deutschland live sind.
Oh, really?
Ja, das ist der Grund.
Weil die Live-Hangouts sind nicht live?
Ja, du kannst es live aufnehmen mit zehn Leuten und dann kannst du es hinterher nicht live abspielen lassen. Aber du kannst es nicht live einer Million Leute zeigen in Deutschland. Und das lag zumindest am Rundfunkstaatsvertrag und tut es, glaube ich, immer noch. Und da finde ich, sollte mal, ich rufe dazu auf, ein Verfassungsrechtler irgendwie sich mal darum kümmern, weil das ist ja wohl gegen die Verfassung, sage ich jetzt mal so.
Das sind ja ganz neue Informationen.
Ja, so geht es ja nicht. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen, also diese Lizenz für 500 Leute und Staatsvertrag und bla bla bla und dieser ganze Scheiß, das erinnert mich einfach manisch an diese Modem-Gesetzgebung in den 80er Jahren. Und da kann ich nur wieder Warholland irgendwie unter dem Sofa hervorkommen. Vorausschauender Umgang mit Gesetzgebung ist manchmal einfach angebracht. Man kann nicht immer so lange warten, wie die anderen zum Denken brauchen.
Ja, oder bis die Gesetze endlich mal geändert sind.
So, ich werde jetzt hier gerade nochmal angepflaumt. Ich soll doch mal den Metaebene-Chat auf Abdeutnet noch nennen. Das tue ich jetzt hier mit.
Wer Lust hat, da auch noch mal zu chat. Wie komme ich da rein?
Wie du da reinkommst, da kommst du rein über Pater. Achso, was auf deinem Browser?
Ich habe so einen Abdeutnet-Client, der geht damit nicht. Nein, der heißt Tweetlane.
Den Tweetlane?
Genau, das ist ein Twitter-Client, der auch Abdeutnet kann.
Ach guck an.
Aber der muss das dann nicht können, sozusagen.
Ich höre von diesem Client ehrlich gesagt das erste Mal, aber wir können ja hier im Buch der Waffen nachschlagen. Vielleicht, weil es ein Android-Client ist. Nein, nein, nicht weil es ein Android-Client ist. Der ist dieser Liste nicht verzeichnet. Es kann sein, dass es eigentlich ein Twitter-Client ist, der gerade ADN nachgerüstet hat.
Aber dann installiere ich mir heute Robin, kein Problem.
Wir können mal kurz mal schauen, welches Feature war hier gefragt. Petter war hier gefragt, da muss man hier mal ein bisschen durchscrollen. Das ist Gen, schon wieder alle. Oh Gott, sie haben schon wieder bei ADN geredet.
Entschuldigung.
So ist das halt.
An unserem revolutionären Podcast-Tag.
Genau, revolutionärer Podcast-Tag erfordert auch die Erwähnung revolutionärer Dienste.
Welchen Klein kann ich denn benutzen, um die Petter-Chat auf dem Weg zu machen?
Wieso steht da überall Not available?
Na, weil das die Android-Seite ist. Wo ist denn hier Petter?
Okay, also das ist schon nicht einfach nur sowas wie Twitter, sondern das ist ein Gruppen-Chat.
Ich könnte jetzt auch ein anderes User-Interface, weil es gibt da jetzt auch ein Web-Interface dafür. Ich muss mir das mal hier kurz in Ruhe anschauen. Ich hatte nur so das Open-Petter-Rom bei URL geht um Robin. Also mit Robin hast du das. Robin ist der Android-Klein. Ich habe den auch selber ein bisschen benutzt. Ich habe ja auch so ein Android-Gerät übrigens hier.
Hab ich schon gehört. Hast du das mit 3G oder ohne? Na, hat es einen SIM-Karten-Slot?
Ja, aber es ist bloß immer aus, wenn ich einschalten will.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch leer jetzt.
Wieso wird das immer leer dann?
Achso, nee, wenn du es ausschaltest, dann wird es nicht von alleine leer. Nee, ich lasse meine immer manchmal an, aus Versehen, und dann sind sie halt leer. Plötzlich, nach drei Tagen.
Na, ich bringe ihnen so einen Sleep-Modus. Ja, ja, das ist dann immer ganz furchtbar leer. Und dann tut es auch gar nichts. Und dann muss man irgendwie diese blöden USB-Kabel finden, die ich jetzt gerade nicht finde. Also wie auch immer.
Kurze Zwischenfrage. Welcher Mac-Client würdest du mir denn gestatten, an diesen wahnsinnig tollen Petter Chats teilzunehmen?
Mac-Client. Da gibt es derzeit leider nur Web-Interfaces dafür. Und da geht man dann auf paterrab.net.
Das habe ich schon.
Und dann ist es der Raum 11299. Der heißt einfach META eben. Das haben jetzt auch schon ein paar Leute gefunden. Von daher könnt ihr euch da ja mal rumschlagen. Wir sagen mal nicht zu, dass wir da jetzt viel mitlesen. Denn der Primär-Chat ist natürlich nach wie vor Irk. irk.irc.freenote.net. Jetzt können wir es ja auch mal komplett nennen. Slash-Mobile-Max und dann seid ihr bei uns hier auf dem Beamer. Ihr könnt ja mal winken. Chat-Leute.
Na, die haben auch eine Verzögerung.
Das scheint mir heute eine wirklich sehr revolutionäre Podcast-Folge zu werden.
Das kommt ja schnell. Jaja, total revolutionär. Ja, Dirk, dann bleiben wir doch nochmal ganz kurz bei Android. Du hörst ja auch diese Sendung. Uns wird ja häufig vorgeworfen, wir hätten keine Ahnung. Kannst du es mal erklären, in welchem Maße?
Ich habe tatsächlich auch schon oft ins Kabel beißen wollen, von meinem Kopf höre, wenn ich euch über Android reden höre.
So oft war das ja gar nicht. Vor Lachen.
Und rein schreien, aber ich habe ja kein Mikro, und außerdem höre ich die Erinnerung ja dann auch nicht live auf dem Fahrrad. Nein, die höre ich dann versetzt. Wir sind jetzt keine konkreten Sachen mehr im Kopf, leider. Ich habe kurz vor der Sendung nochmal gegrübelt, ob mir was konkretes einfällt.
Aber gibt es nicht so ein generelles Gefühl, wo wir so immer daneben liegen?
Man hat das Gefühl, dass Blinde über Farben reden, wenn sie über Android reden. Das ist so meine voreingenommene…
Ich dachte mal, das ist alles schwarz, weil die dann Strom sparen wegen ihrem OLED-Display.
Das habe ich auch schon mal gehört, ja tatsächlich. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich so ist. Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, das Schwarz kostet genauso viel. Also vielleicht bei OLED. Aber ja, Hardware ist eh nicht mehr so mein Ding. Ich will jetzt hier nicht über Android reden. Ihr seid halt iPhone-User und ich werde euch nicht konvertieren.
Da bin ich jetzt aber schwer von ausgegangen.
Genau, ich dachte du zeigst uns jetzt mal das Licht mit den Farben.
Genau, zeig uns die Farben, Dirk.
Ich meine, ihr seht doch die Einschüsse auch rechts und links irgendwie fletter rausgeflogen. Das war das letzte. Und das ist halt, also bei mir ist das eine prinzipielle Sache. Ich hab ja auch mal iOS programmiert, schon mal. Und das ist auch in Ordnung. Das kann man machen, das sind schöne Arpies. Man hat sehr viele Sachen, die man bei Android nicht hat. Dafür hat man andere Sachen nicht. Und dann hab ich mal mit so iOS-Programmierern in meiner Firma geredet und die meinten halt, sie würden halt iOS machen, weil das halt einfach defaultmäßig gut aussieht und das sei ihnen halt wichtig. Und dann hab ich gesagt, ich mach halt Android gerne, weil ich gerne nicht für die Katze arbeite, sondern für irgendwie auch Sachen vertreiben will hinterher. Und wenn ich was mache, was Apple nicht gefällt, dann erlauben die das halt einfach nicht. Da sagen die einfach, ne, das kannst du hier nicht machen. Und dafür ist mir meine Zeit zu schade.
Meinst du nicht, dass wenn Google erst mal riesengroß ist oder in der Store besser funktionieren würde, dass die auch irgendwann mehr restriktiv wären?
Gerne, die sollen den Play Store so restriktiv machen, wie sie wollen. Ich muss den ja nicht benutzen.
Da gibt es ja noch 23 Millionen andere Stores.
Genau, 160 andere Stores.
Ja, aber benutzen die Leute wirklich die Stores so nach...
Die Masse erreicht man natürlich nur mit dem Play Store. Klar. Aber wenn Google etwas nicht gefällt, dann ist man halt nicht gleich ganz weg vom Fenster. Sondern man kann auch selber vertreiben. Du kannst es ja auch auf deiner eigenen Webseite vertreiben, dein Zeug.
Aber gibt es denn überhaupt Klauseln, mit denen man nicht in den Play Store aufgenommen wird?
Ja, Copyright-Verletzungen darfst du nicht machen.
Findet aber trotzdem massiv statt.
Kann sein. Kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Vor allem von Apps. Das gibt es natürlich auch im iOS-App Store. Noch ein Nöcher, aber es ist teilweise schon ein bisschen krass.
Die Kopien.
Wie auch immer. Das ist so eine prinzipielle Sache bei mir. Ich finde das prinzipiell schlecht. Im moralischen Sinne. Ich glaube, es wäre auch nicht nötig gewesen. Apple hätte das nicht so machen müssen. Aber sie haben sich nun mal so entschieden und jetzt ziehen sie es durch.
Na gut, dafür ist natürlich gefühlt 99% der Malware, die da draußen tobt, auf Android unterwegs.
Ja, aber die wird auch nicht durch den Play Store vertrieben.
Die wird auf jeden Fall durch den Play Store nicht groß verhindert.
Das ist ja ein großes Problem.
Selbst wenn. Also ich meine, auf deinem Mac kannst du dir auch Malware installieren. Und da würdest du auch nicht darauf verzichten wollen, auf dieses Feature, oder?
Ja, aber nicht aus einer beliebigen Quelle, sondern wenn, dann kommt es aus dem iOS.
Und das würdest du auch wollen, dass du das kannst, dass du die Freiheit hast, dir Scheiße zu installieren. Ich will die Freiheit haben. Ich will mir auch mal Melware installieren können, wenn es heißt, dass ich eben dann auch die Sachen installieren kann, die Apple nicht zulassen würde.
Gut, ich meine, auf dem Mac liegt der Fall anders. Noch, ja. Ja, dieses noch und the future und so weiter, das kann man natürlich jetzt immer sagen, aber damit unterstellt man ihnen einen Mord, den sie halt noch nicht gemacht haben.
Nein, ich unterstelle ihnen da nichts. Ich bin nur traurig darüber, wenn sie es tun würden, denn dann müsste ich weg vom Apple, wenn es käme. Also ich müsste dann einfach zu Linux leider. Und das tut mir wirklich weh. Seit 1995 ist mein Primärrechner immer ein Mac gewesen. Tatsächlich sogar immer ein mobiler Mac.
Ja, das wäre für mich auch nicht zu vertragen. Aber ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass sich das Nennenswert weiter verschärft, als so wie es jetzt ist.
Okay, dann hoffen wir das beide.
Wobei natürlich, ich meine es gibt den faktischen, oder sagen wir mal, es gibt den zwingenden Druck, jetzt eine iOS-Welt ist es klar, aber auf dem Mac gibt es natürlich nicht den Zwang, dass du deine Software nicht über den Mac App Store vertreiben musst, sondern du kannst, und trotzdem ist natürlich die Buying Experience, wie das so schön heißt, natürlich besser über den App Store.
Und so sollte es auch auf dem iPhone sein. Also so sollte es auch auf dem iPhone sein.
Wie ist denn das eigentlich bei diesem Signieren von, also du kannst ja von Apple die Binaries auch signieren, wenn du nicht in den App Store deine App stellst?
Musst du das jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht sogar schon, oder solltest du es auf jeden Fall jetzt auch tun?
Kommt drauf an, was der Endanwender für eine Einstellung hat.
Und das ist dann, damit sie sozusagen im Nachhinein theoretisch noch sagen könnten, ok, das was du da voll mit unserem Zert gesigned hast, dass es jetzt irgendwie mal wäre und jetzt revoken wir...
Genau, wir wissen, dass du da böse bist und dann stehst du in den Revocation Lists und dann kommst du nicht durch. Was ich, also ich finde den Ansatz, den sie da derzeit auf dem Mac haben, finde ich völlig in Ordnung und auch hilfreich. Nur, ihre App Store Politik ist natürlich auch auf dem Mac App Store genauso fragwürdig.
Ja, da gibt es Probleme mit Apis, da können wir bestimmte Apis nicht benutzen, wenn man da rein will.
Also da kommen wir, ich hatte das tatsächlich auch als Punkt notiert, weil anlässlich einer neuen Beta-Version, über die wir vielleicht gleich nochmal ausführlicher sprechen können, nämlich Instacast, gibt es ja jetzt auch für den Mac. Also es gibt jetzt nicht nur Instacast für iOS, sondern es gibt jetzt auch Instacast für den Mac. Aber jetzt brauchst du gar nicht im App Store zu suchen, sondern erstens ist es heute jetzt gerade vor ein paar Stunden als Beta erstmal rausgehauen worden und der derzeitige Plan ist halt auch nicht in den App Store zu gehen. Und da gibt es auch viele gute Gründe dafür. Da kommen wir vielleicht auch gleich noch drauf. Trotzdem, der Mac App Store erlaubt dir halt bestimmte Sachen nicht. Und eine dieser Sachen, die abwesend sind vom App Store, ist Bithorrent. Ich hab keine Anwendung gefunden im Mac App Store, die Bithorrent macht. Und sagen wir mal, auf iOS zumindest für Telefone und Geräte mit 3G und so, nicht so sehr für iPads, die nur WLAN haben, aber so für 3G. Da kann ich das irgendwie noch so ein bisschen nachvollziehen. Da kann ich sagen, ja okay, Bithorrent auf 3G ist auch nicht so eine gute Idee. Auf der anderen Seite könnte man das...
Das geht super.
Ja, natürlich geht das super. Wegen Bandbreite und Blah und Kontingente, Verbrauchern und so weiter. Nach dem Motto, Apple hält seine schützende Hand über die User. Also man kann das ja auch...
Um die Bandbreite geht es ja bei Bithorrent wohl kaum, oder?
Das ist jetzt...
Der Punkt.
Der Punkt, die Frage. Nur jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, warum gibt es auf dem Mac App Store keine einzige? Und der Witz ist, es gab mal eine, nämlich Opera. Opera ist ja der einzige Webbrowser, der Bithorrent eingebaut hat. Als er rauskam, war das Bithorrent Feature auch drin. Das ist dann später aber laut dem Blog von Opera, ich habe das nochmal nachgeschlagen, zurückgezogen worden, das Feature, weil das so selten benutzt wurde. Ich finde das interessant, weil, woher wissen die das? Also haben die da irgendwie Code drin, der irgendwie den sagt?
Das machen alle irgendwie, ihre Apps tracken, was die Leute da machen. Also wenn du das nicht machst, dann...
Ein Web-Browser?
Die Heimat funkt, wie viel ich irgendwie ein Protokoll benutze.
Ein Feature.
Wie?
Klar.
Du machst Witze.
Natürlich tracken alle möglichen iOS-Apps, alle möglichen Apps haben da irgendwelche Tracking-Libraries, die alles Mögliche da raus tracken.
Ich rede nicht von allen möglichen Apps, ich rede von Web-Browsern.
Ja, warum denn nicht?
Sag mir mal, ein Web-Browser, der liefert Firefox Statistiken des Users an Firefox?
Er fragt dich, ob er das machen soll.
Die brauchen auch Statistiken, weil sie wollen ihr Produkt verbessern. Du musst es einfach anklicken.
Da fragen sie vielleicht nicht. Aber ob sie das machen, weiß ich auch nicht.
Also bei Safari gab es da nicht auch mal diese Option mit der Usage Data?
Bei Betas, glaube ich, gibt es das nur.
Also ich würde behaupten, jeder einigermaßen.
Das war auf jeden Fall Ihre Aussage, dass Sie das deshalb getan hätten. Und ich sag dir nur, Nachtigall, ich höre dir trapsen.
Ja, also das hört sich ja wirklich so an, als wenn Apple Ihnen gesagt hätte, nehmt das raus, sonst fliegt ihr aus dem App Store und sagt aber niemandem, dass ihr das rausnehmen müsstet, um im App Store zu bleiben. Und dann haben sie sich halt so eine Ausrede ausgedacht. So klingt das für mich.
Kann man so lesen, ja. Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand im Chat irgendwie vielleicht weiß, ob es mal irgendeinen anderen Versuch gab, Bithorn Software im Mac App Store unterzukriegen, die dann abgelehnt wurden und wenn ja, aus welchen Gründen?
Hier, Dennis.
Mir fällt da nichts zu ein irgendwie. Ich kann mich da auch nicht erinnern.
Was ist mit Transmission? Warum ist Transmission nicht im... Du kennst die doch.
Ich kenn die nicht zu, nicht wirklich. Aber ich glaube, die lassen einfach kein Bithorn zu. Ist halt Filesharing zack fertig. Steht in ihrer...
Files haben nicht geshared zu werden.
Aber Dropbox ist doch...
Deswegen funktioniert das auch bei Apple generell so schlecht. An allen Stellen so. Auch mit Clout.
Dieses AirDrop hervormt auch nicht. Ich hab da noch nie mehr als 2MB rüber bekommen.
AirDrop funktioniert super.
Aber wie schnell ist es?
Ich weiß nicht, der dreht sich der Kreis.
Also ich hab jetzt mit AirDrop nicht so Probleme, aber das ist nicht unbedingt ganz so das, was ich unter File Sharing verstehe. Also das mag da auch eine Rolle spielen, aber Sharing heißt halt schon...
Noch über eine längere Strecke.
Genau, ja auch mehrere vielleicht als nur eine andere Person. Ja, das ist schon... Das ist wirklich bedenklich und ich frag mich halt auch, wo bitte soll das hinführen?
Na, in Total Control.
Ja, aber Total Control, das ist ja auch gerade gemerkt, würde ihnen wirklich eine Kernzielgruppe entziehen.
Programmierer.
Programmierer und...
Also ich meine...
Ja, aber wenn wir eine Minderheit sind, dann ist es den Apple-Jungs egal.
Na, irgendwo müssen die Leute herkommen, die die tollen Apps programmieren.
Das sind aber auch so die Power-User und Systemadministratoren und so weiter. Das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen überdreht. Ich vereinfache mal. Aber erinnert ihr euch noch, als es so mit OS X anfing und kein Mensch das wirklich benutzen konnte? Wer hat sich mit Begeisterung und mit Hingabe dieser Plattform an den Hals geschmissen? Das waren die Hacker, das waren die Programmierer, das waren die Systemadministratoren, die sich gedacht haben, geil, endlich mal Unix mit ordentlichem UI.
Nee, endlich mal Unix auf meiner Kiste, das war's.
Ja gut, oder so rum halt. Aber vorher, es hat auch viele Leute von anderen Plattformen dahingezogen. Und ich will das nicht überbewerten, aber ich hatte schon den Eindruck, dass damals diese Szene ein extremer Multiplikator war und die Max an Stellen wieder ins Spiel gebracht hat, wo sie schon fast nicht mehr eine Rolle gespielt haben.
Wo sie vielleicht noch nie eine Rolle gespielt haben, auch vorher.
Genau, also mittlerweile auch, wo sie nie, aber wo sie, sagen wir mal, auch so ein bisschen auf der Bettkante saßen und Angst haben mussten, gleich runtergeschubst zu werden.
Aber wird es nicht einfach zweiglässig sein? Also ich meine, es wird halt eine iOS-Version geben für Max und dann wird es noch das Mac OS für Max geben. Und irgendwann wirst du dann wahrscheinlich eine Developer-Lizenz bei Apple beantragen müssen, damit du dann auf deinem iOS was freischalten kannst und dann kannst du da drauf entwickeln. Nein, was ist heute schon so? Es gibt kein iOS für den Mac, oder?
Ach so, iOS, ja es gibt diesen Simulator.
Also das, was jetzt iOS ist, wird auf den Mac migriert, auf die Mac-Plattform und zwar erstmal als Option, kannst du im Laden. Das behaupte ich, das ist meine Theorie.
iOS auf dem Mac? So einen Quatsch überlassen die App Microsoft. Du siehst ja, wie gut sie damit fahren.
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht.
Für eure Geräte irgendwie, für eure Touchscreens, für Rechner, die auch trotzdem noch irgendwie eine Tastatur haben und verkauft sich halt gar nicht.
So wird er demnächst gefixt. Das ist der Windows 8.1 oder SP1 und dann machen sie es wieder weg.
Was machen sie wieder weg?
Na den Touch Default da.
Echt? Die bauen jetzt so einen Startbutton ein.
Nee, der Touch Default ist da wieder aus. Das sieht ja so wie früher.
Meinst du, eine Vermutung von dir?
Ich habe gehört, dass sie den Startbutton wieder einbauen. Aber werden wir sehen.
Sehen wir, genau. Kann ja nicht mehr so lange dauern, oder?
Microsoft ist auf jeden Fall orientierungslos. Die wissen nicht, wo...
Genau, nicht ablenken, wir sind hier bei Apple.
Nee, wir sind hier nicht bei Apple. Wir sind hier bei allem, was interessant ist. Und meistens finden wir ja Microsoft nicht so interessant. Aber manchmal halt schon, oder?
Ja, wann haben wir sie denn das letzte Mal so richtig interessant gefunden? Ich kann mich beim besten Willen nicht erinnern.
Was war denn das letzte Coole, was Microsoft gemacht hat?
Also selbst wenn ich so richtig weit zurückdenke, fällt mir beim besten Willen nicht ein.
Surface heißt jetzt dieses Tablet oder so oder?
Vorher war es dieser Tisch.
Genau, und dieser Tisch, den fand ich cool.
Hast du den mal in echt gesehen? Nee, ich hab in der Filme gesehen. Bei Artcom hat er auch mal hier so Multitasche-Systeme gebaut. Und dann hatten wir zwar Ansicht mal, weil es da auch nicht viel gab von anderen Herstellern, haben wir uns dann einmal so eine Surface kommen lassen. Und diese Geschichte, die war wirklich episch, weil die kamen an und es ging nichts. Es gab ein Manual, es gab eine Install-CD, das hat man befolgt und dann Blue Screen. So, beim Boot. Dann irgendwie kam, glaube ich, mal irgendwann so ein Microsoft hier nochmal an und hat die sozusagen in Betriebszustand versetzt. Und dann hattest du halt diesen Tisch und er bootete auch so ein Windows, und dann war diese Surface oben drauf und dann gab es da einfach nichts zu benutzen. Es war wirklich, du hast dieses Piano-Ding gehabt, ja, und dann kannst du mal ein bisschen klimpern. Ah, Multitouch. Dann gab es noch so ein paar Spiele. Ah, Multitouch. Und dann war nach fünf Minuten auch schon wieder langweilig und dann hast du das Ding wieder ausgemacht und es hat Staub gefangen. Das war die Surface. So super unexciting. Die Oberfläche war halt auch so total so touch unfreundlich. Es war halt nicht so ein schönes, ein glatter Tisch, sondern eher so ein stoppender Tisch. Ja, das hatte irgendwie so eine komische Rauberoberfläche. Das war nichts. Na gut. Es war ein Showcase-Gerät, was wahnsinnig teuer war und wofür wahrscheinlich nie irgendeine Third-Party-App jemals entwickelt wurde, außer vielleicht in-house. Also das war nicht cool, das war wirklich alles andere. Kinect ist vielleicht doch so ein bisschen cool.
Hab ich noch nicht benutzt, aber...
Kinect ist auf jeden Fall technologisch saugeil. Ich hab's selber noch nie benutzt, muss ich zugeben. Aber es ist natürlich auf jeden Fall so ein Gerät, was sich schwer durchgesetzt hat, auch im robotischen Bereich.
Ich hab die tatsächlich mal benutzt, ich glaube im Computerspielemuseum in Berlin. Da kann man tatsächlich ein Spiel spielen, wo man dann vorm Bildschirm rumhampelt.
Machen das Leute eigentlich? Hoppen jetzt Kinder vom Gerät rum? Ich meine wirklich?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab keine Kinect.
Ich hör ja auch immer wieder, dass Leute bereit sind, mit ihrem Computer zu sprechen.
Google ist ja auch so eine Firma, die daran passt. Das ist eins der Features, die immer wieder gehypt werden, die ich nie benutze. Also Voice Search und whatnot. Aber ich fahre auch nicht viel Auto.
Willst du denn deine Google Glass haben?
Ich würde es haben wollen wegen des Bildschirms, ja. Also Kamera, ja, ist mir egal. Ich hoffe, es wird eine Möglichkeit geben, die Kamera so abzukleben, dass man eben nicht auf die Fresse kriegt, wenn man irgendwo damit auftaucht. Das muss halt offensichtlich abgeklebt sein. Oder vielleicht ein Google Glass ohne Kamera. Aber diesen Bildschirm so zu haben, wenn das funktioniert, dass ich irgendwie im Augenwinkel oder halbwegs sehen kann, immer eingeblendet habe.
Das hättest du schon gerne. Wirst du mal vor beim Motorradfahren, Dirk?
Ich fahre nicht mehr Motorrad, aber beim Fahrradfahren. Wieso? Wieso kann ich jetzt wieder Motorrad fahren?
Also, das ist kein Insider-Talk. Denkst du nicht auch, dass das ein Fehler war, da eine Kamera einzubauen?
Weil es kriegen ja alle auf dich besser, auch die, die sie ausgeschaltet haben. Wahrscheinlich war es kein Fehler, eine Kamera einzubauen, weil man damit seine Kinder filmen kann, keine Ahnung. Ja, aber dann muss man das so halten. Gerade heute habe ich irgendwie im Girls Sir Park gesessen und eine tolle Band spielen hören. Orchestra Miniatur In the Park. Und ich hätte das gerne aufgezeichnet um das später. Also die spielen so mit Spielzeuginstrumenten. Also sie hatten so einen Mini-Piano und war echt lustig. Ich hätte das gerne aufgezeichnet, aber ich will nicht wie ein Depp da stehen und mein Telefon hochhalten und wie eine Kamera und das filmen. Ich würde das natürlich auch mit dem Google-Glas nicht machen.
Ja eben, weil das Ding mit Helmkamera ist, das funktioniert halt für sehr selektiv. Also zum Beispiel Motorrad fahren ist super, weil du guckst halt nach vorne. Oder es funktioniert beim, was weiß ich, aus dem Flugzeug springen, weil irgendwie alles ist spektakulär, egal wohin du guckst. Aber wenn du beim Konzert stehst und eigentlich so ein Ziel hast und dann willst du dich unterhalten. Ich kann jetzt meinen Kopf nicht drehen. Kannst du mir mal die Cola? Wo ist das hier so? Das macht halt auch keiner, ne? Und auch deine Kinder filmst du ja nicht so die ganze Zeit, dass du dann hier so mit deinem Kopf irgendwie hältst das Kind vor dir und gehst halt mit dem Kopf da um das Kind rum, um da so einen möglichst tollen Winkel zu kriegen. Das macht doch keiner.
Papa, alles in Ordnung hier?
Wahrscheinlich fällt die Kamera Google Glass gar nicht auf, weil demnächst so viele Kameras überall sind. Also ich meine, wir werden noch von hinten und vorne aufgeweicht total durch tausende Kameras. In jedem Scheiß, die weiß, ist eine Kamera.
Warte, weiß ich.
So blöd es ist, aber das Spiel ist verloren.
Ja, also ich hätte gern das Head-Up-Display. Die Kamera kann ich gut und gerne darauf verzichten und kann ich auch verstehen, dass andere Leute das nicht cool finden, wenn ich die ganze Zeit mit einer Ready-to-use-Kamera rumlaufe an meinem Kopf.
Was ist das eigentlich so für Specs, das Teil?
Keine Ahnung. Ich guck mir das erst an, wenn ich eins in der Hand habe.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn man so auf so einen Bildschirm guckt, kann man schon wissen, wie viel Püxel der so hat.
Ja, der hatte nicht allzu viel. Also 640 oder so was, also relativ wenig. Aber ich meine, das ist halt die erste. War smart, wenn das nächste Modell kommt, dann ist gleich wieder komplett so viel.
Ist der dann so rechts oben an der Ecke, wo man hingucken muss, oder ist der dann komplett overlaid, oder nur so rechts oben in dem normalen View, oder wie ist das?
Ich glaube, das ist in so einem Viertel von deinem rechten Augen-View. Aber ich weiß es nicht. Genau deshalb würde ich gerne so ein Ding mal ausprobieren.
Was ich ja gerne hätte, wäre tatsächlich, wie sagt man, diese Kontaktlinse. Und da soll das dann bitte schön gleich reinprojiziert werden.
Ja, und zwar so, dass man es gut lesen kann. Und nicht opark, sondern halt so durch, mit Alpha-Dingster, Alpha-Kanal, durchgucken. Ja, Dennis, das ist ein Punkt.
Jetzt hast du schön in meinem Mikro gequatscht.
Super, ne?
Orchester, Miniatur in the Park.
Ja, aber das ist Piano gar nicht dabei. Die hatten heute so ein kleines Spielzeug-Piano.
Na gut, wir können ja vielleicht nochmal auf das andere Thema kommen, was ich jetzt schon angesprochen hatte. Also Instacast für den Mac ist draußen. Das freut mich auf mehreren Ebenen. Erstens können wir nicht genug Podcast-Lines haben. Zweitens gab es ja auf dem Mac eigentlich nichts. Oder? Außer iTunes natürlich.
Und Miro.
Was irgendwie keiner so richtig benutzen wollte. Und natürlich ist es auch immer so eine Sache, dass ja diese ganzen Clients deshalb sich nicht haben durchsetzen können gegen iTunes, weil iTunes den Vorteil hatte, dass sie eben den Sync mit dem Telefon hatten. Aber jetzt, wo halt der Sync ohnehin übers Netz kommt, spielt das in zunehmendem Maße keine Rolle. Wer also auf seinem Mac einen Client haben will, der will dann halt auch auf dem Mac hören. Oder archivieren, oder sonst wie interagieren, spricht sicherlich einiges dafür. Habt ihr euch das schonmal angeschaut?
Noch nicht, aber...
Ladet euch doch mal die Bilder.
Das, was mir schon interessiert bei Bad Guys Türen, ist, dass ich ja das auf meinen iPod Shuffle rauftue und beim Sport höre, wenn dann eigentlich hauptsächlich. Das heißt, iTunes ist mein einziges Tool, um Podcasts jetzt auf diesen Shuffle zu kriegen. Glaub ich zumindest. Und jetzt mit Instacast wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht so direkt gehen.
Hast du den Shuffle mit Bedienung noch? Aber die Bedienung ist auf dem Gerät und nicht im Kopfhörer? Genau. Der Neueste, der kann das wieder. Gut, ich hatte mir nämlich auch überlegt, den zu kaufen.
Ja, aber weiß man das, ob die auch so mit iPods, also ob das Instacast, oder muss ich dann mit Instacast es trotzdem runterladen, dann das iTunes reinstecken und um es auf den Shuffle zu kopieren?
Also ich weiß gar nichts von Syncing.
Okay, weil ich würde ja sehr gerne dieses iTunes loswerden, aber es geht halt irgendwie.
Syncing hat es natürlich, aber es synkt über das Netz, mit deinem Instacast-Account und so weiter. Das heißt, wenn du den Instacast auf dem iPhone benutzt, dann hast du, du startest die ab, du lädst dich locker mit demselben Account ein, dann hast du alle deine Subscriptions und denselben RedStatus und denselben Play-Account und so weiter. Also das ist alles gesyncht, aber Synken in Synking mit Gerät und rüberkopieren von einem bestimmten Set von Podcasts ist so nicht drin. Aber ich denke, das ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt die Zielgruppe an der Stelle.
Es wäre nur schön, dieses Altions irgendwie früher oder später mal ganz abschaffen zu können.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Ja, das wird doch nichts. Das ist auch echt das Merkwürdige. Also ich hatte ja auch mal vor Ewigkeiten einen neuen Music Player vorgestellt, und da gibt es einfach keine Updates für. Und der hat Bugs. Der sah sehr vielversprechend aus und der wird einfach nicht geupdatet. Und das ist auch so, als wäre da so der Deckmantel des Schweigens von Apple ausgebreitet. Und na, du machst einen Music Player. Überleg dir doch nochmal gut, ob du dafür ein Update rausbringen willst. Sonst wäre doch schade, wenn was deinem Computer passiert.
Es wäre doch schade, wenn deine Kinder eines Tages nicht von der Schule zurückkommen.
Ja, irgendwie. Also es ist mir ein totales Rätsel, warum es nicht ein ordentlichen alternativen Music Player auf Mac gibt. Das ist wirklich traurig.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so easy, weil es auch ganz stark geschmacksabhängig ist und du kannst nicht alle Geschmäcker gleichzeitig erfüllen. Das geht einfach irgendwie nicht.
Ich bin nur ein Player, der nicht auch noch ein E-Book Store ist und ein App Store und ein Music Store und ein iPhone Backup und ein App Mansion. Ich will einen Scheißpack. Ja, aber nicht in meinem Music Player.
Aber willst du nicht auch die Musik singen?
Das geht doch auch ohne. Du kriegst doch iLive, du kriegst auch deine Libraries auch irgendwie sonst wo geshared. Also du musst ja nicht irgendwie das im gleichen Programm haben, um das zu tun. Du kannst auch Fotos mit der einen ab...
Ja, man kann es getrennt haben, aber man kann es auch integrieren.
Aber ich finde...
Mein iTunes funktioniert super, ich weiß überhaupt nicht...
Ja, funktioniert es schon, aber es ist einfach voll überladen.
Und die haben die Suche kaputt gemacht.
Also bis zur letzten Version, jetzt die neueste Version, mit der habe ich mich auch noch nicht angefreundet, aber... Aber mit der Version davor war ich zumindest total zufrieden.
Ja, man ist immer mit der Version zuvor zufrieden, weil die danach ist immer schlechter. Das heißt, die davor war immer besser.
Nee, ich habe ja euer Gerante auch mir jede Sendung angehört, aber ich konnte das echt nicht nachvollziehen. Aber bei mir funktioniert das.
In der neuen Version.
In der vorletzten Version.
Die letzte hat halt das Interface geändert, da habe ich mich noch nicht dran gewöhnt. Ich bin halt konservativ.
Dieses Ding schon alleine, dass man jetzt hier nicht mehr filtern kann, sondern dass dann das kommt und dann geht man da drauf und dann kommt man in diese Scheißansicht.
Das ist nicht die vorletzte Version, die du da hast?
Das ist nicht die neueste.
Wie hast du das so hin? Müssen wir nach der Sendung mal drüber reden.
Früher hat das da oben gefiltert und nicht einfach den kompletten View einmal umgedreht. Furchtbar.
Bei mir funktioniert das mit dem Wetter.
Bei mir ist iTunes vorher und nachher gleich Scheiße gewesen.
Ja, eigentlich nur anders Scheiße, finde ich. Also das Level an Beklopptheit ist gleich.
Hat sich nur leicht verlagert. Kommen wir nochmal zu Instacast. Da ist es mit der Beklopptheit nicht ganz so schlimm. Ganz im Gegenteil, ich finde das ganz ordentlich designt. Ich würde das jetzt auch gerne auf den Beamer kriegen, geht aber nicht, weil der Beamer hängt noch an einem 10.7 Mac und es läuft leider nur mit 10.8. Wer also noch nicht auf 10.8 ist, ist hier leider kein potenzieller Kunde. Was natürlich sehr schön ist, ist das mit Instacast für den Mac und vor allem der Tatsache, dass dieses Programm nicht über den App Store vertrieben wird und wohl auch nicht werden wird. Ein paar interessante Dienste hier Einzug gehalten haben bzw. noch hoffentlich Einzug halten werden. Nämlich Flatter. Das heißt, dieses tolle Feature von Instacast auf iOS, dass wenn man eine Episode gehört hat, dass sie dann automatisch geflattert wird. Nach dem Motto, alles was ich höre, flatter ich auch. Das hat hier wieder den Weg hineingefunden. Ich bin mir gerade nicht ganz so sicher, ob das quasi jetzt indirekt über das Syncing auch funktioniert. Also wenn man den Laufner hat und der synkt und man hört eine Episode an oder zu Ende auf iOS und synkt dann diese Informationen mit, habe ich gehört, zurück in den MEC-Line, ob das dann auch so eine Flatter-Aktivität auslöst, das weiß ich gerade nicht. Wäre nochmal ganz interessant, das herauszufinden. Aber auf jeden Fall, wenn ich das User Interface hier richtig interpretiere, kann man das halt hier einstellen, dass er automatisch flattert, wenn man anfängt oder wenn er aufgehört hat. Oder wenn man etwas, also dann ist das quasi der automatische Modus, wenn man etwas als Favorit markiert hat. Das finde ich eigentlich eine sehr schöne Sache. Ganz klar. Ansonsten haben sie auch eine ganze Menge Sharing-Funktionalität mit drin und wie sollte es auch anders sein? Auch mit Update-Met-Support. Ganz toll.
Also eine der wenigen Applikationen, die uns quasi, die auf uns hört. Die all unsere Wünsche erfüllt.
Brav.
Ja, mein Problem ist ja eigentlich immer, also ich bin ja, ich finde der Podcast schon toll, ich mache jetzt ja nur auch mal selber einen oder sozusagen auch zwei. Aber ich habe nie richtig Zeit, das zu hören, außer wirklich beim Sport auf dem Shuffle. Und deswegen sind so diese ganzen tollen Tools und Interfaces für mich irgendwie so ein bisschen, ja, unnütz, weil ich halt immer diese iTunes-Krücke brauche, um das auf mein primäres Abspielgerät zu bringen. Vielleicht sollte ich mir mal wirklich so ein Nano oder, die gibt es noch, ne? Aber das Schöne ist eben, dass du überhaupt nicht abgelenkt bist von diesem Interface. Du machst ja halt vorher deine Playlist, drückst auf Play und dann bist du halt da die ganze Zeit am Rum rotieren und Salto schlagen und Klimmzüge mit einem Arm und sowas machen und dann musst du dich...
So viele Sachen in deiner Freizeit.
Sport halt, ne?
Klimmzüge an einem Arm.
Natürlich.
Könnte ich auch mal ausprobieren.
Es ist das Schöne beim Radio, dass die, die mich jetzt noch nicht gesehen haben, die...
Können sich dich jetzt richtig gut vorstellen.
Ja, ich denke auch. Und es ist halt auch sehr gut, dass du dich die ganze Zeit nicht da drum kümmerst. Ja, es gibt ja auch die Leute beim Sport, die ohne Scheiß hier diese fette Manschette mit so einem iPhone drin haben. Und die sich auch nicht dabei schämen. Ja, weil das mega bescheuert aussieht.
Du, wenn man den richtigen Podcast hört, ist es egal. Ja, ich sehe vielleicht scheiße aus, aber ich höre Mobamex.
Das weiß ja dann keiner.
Weiß er genau.
Also diese iPhone-Manschetten am Arm wirklich, das ist also... Wie machst du das denn? Der Shuffle, der ist so klein, der hängt einfach...
An der Hose.
Den klippst du dir irgendwo ran, du merkst ihn gar nicht.
An die Unterhose?
Das ist halt das Schöne, also der ist so mega leicht und klein.
Ich hab ja jetzt ein Headset, mit dem ich das machen kann. Also ich klemme dann das Headset irgendwo hin und dann...
Wir brauchen doch die iWatch.
Klingt jetzt komisch, ist aber so.
Wir brauchen die iWatch.
Also ein Bluetooth-Headset, meinte ich natürlich, ohne Kabel.
Na ja gut, wir können dir nicht groß helfen. Auf jeden Fall zum Thema Instacast kann ich nur sagen, schaut's euch mal an. Wenn ihr Podcasts auf eurem Mac hört, ist das auf jeden Fall die Empfehlung des Tages.
Also das kann man jetzt schon herunterladen, ja?
Das kann man jetzt gerade live in Farbe aus dem Internet direkt auf die Platte laden. Jetzt direkt hier auf der Line. Und ja, hat Kapitelmarken drin und all diese ganzen schönen Sachen, die man eben von iOS Versionen auch kennt. Und ich bin da sehr zuversichtlich, dass da demnächst auch noch bitteren Support nachgeschoben wird.
Achso, und deshalb kommt es nicht in den Nextdoor?
Naja, das wäre auf jeden Fall etwas, dass wenn es davon eine App Store Version gibt, dann wäre dieses Feature wahrscheinlich draußen, genauso wie das Filter-Feature.
Aber du kennst die ja, die können das doch einfach mal ausprobieren und dir dann hinterher sagen, was passiert ist.
Naja, das ist ja schon mal. Du meinst das mit dem Bitteren? Ja, das kann man natürlich machen.
Achso, sie wollen auch aus anderen Gründen nicht in den App Store?
Na, es gibt viele Gründe auch nicht im App Store zu sein.
Update?
Also ich kann jetzt nicht für Martin sprechen, was jetzt konkret seine Gründe sind, ist zu tun oder nicht zu tun. Aber generell hast du natürlich mit dem App Store auch erst mal ein Problem an der Backe, so wie das ja bei iOS und generell bei allen App Stores ist. Also zumindest bei Apple, nein, generell, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es ist, aber beim Play Store, wenn man da eine neue Version pusht, ist sie dann sofort da. Also hat man das selber in der Hand oder muss es auch immer noch reviewed werden?
Da wird nichts reviewed und sie ist aber trotzdem nicht sofort da. Das war früher mal so, tatsächlich die ersten Apps, die ich reingestellt habe oder die erste. Die war dann innerhalb von ein paar Minuten. Aber Updates sind manchmal ein Problem. Anscheinend, wenn sie das schon mal distributiert haben, bis das dann überschrieben ist, das Update, das kann tatsächlich so 10 Stunden dauern.
Aber es gibt andere Stores, wo es auch gereviewed wird, oder?
Ja, bei Amazon.
Amazon macht das genau. Wie erfolgreich ist eigentlich dieser Amazon Store?
Ich muss noch meinen Amazon Store-Developer-Account cancelen. Die wollen jetzt Geld, glaube ich. Beziehungsweise sie haben es angekündigt, dass sie jetzt Geld wollen von mir. Und da ich da nichts drin habe, warum soll ich dafür Geld bezahlen?
Das ist open.
Der ist auch offen, aber nicht so offen wie der Play Store.
Ich trage dich immer.
Glaub ich zumindest.
Ja, nochmal zu den Gründen. Also der Mac App Store hat natürlich das Problem. Bis vor kurzem war es sogar so, dass die Review-Zeiten auch noch enorm lang waren. Aber ich habe gehört, das hat sich wiederum enorm verbessert.
Also es ist wohl besser geworden.
Wochenlang klagen da teilweise Updates rum.
Aber es ist schon relativ lang, also bei VUGA, das ist immer so die Regel, dass es so zwei Wochen dauert.
Also dass wir das annehmen, dass es zwei Wochen dauert.
Ich rede jetzt wirklich von dem Mac App Store.
Okay, ja da sind die Review-Zeiten wahrscheinlich so.
Also da waren sie extrem schlecht und mittlerweile sind sie, glaube ich, ganz okay wieder, aber so oder so, wir wissen, das Problem ist, du hast halt eine Version draußen und du musst unbedingt was fixen, weil es einfach eine Menge Leute gerade schwer in den Arsch beißen und jede Stunde, die dieses Update nicht da ist, erzeugt immer noch mehr Probleme. Und das ist nicht so schön. So jetzt sehe ich gerade, wir kriegen Verstärkung. Wir haben einen Zaungast. Willst du nicht reinkommen?
Nein, nicht durchs Fenster.
Durchs Oberlicht?
Ich lasse mal hier die Verstärkung rein.
Ach, Instacast.
In der Zwischenzeit sagen das auch eine neue Folge von meinem neuen Podcast. 300 Herz.
Und da geht es um Musik.
Gitarrenverstärker.
Das machst du mit Roddi?
Nee, aber Roddi würde ich auch gerne mal dazu holen. Ich hatte mal einen Zuhörer von Mobile Max gefragt, ob wir das nicht mal machen wollen. Dann habe ich mich mit dem Schontan getroffen und habe das gemacht.
Und wie macht ihr das? Was für ein Studio-Equipment habt ihr?
Das erste Mal haben wir es improvisiert.
Mit so einem Recorder in der Hand?
Nee, mit großem Mikrofon und fettem Audio-Interface. Und die zweite Folge war bei Tim im Studio.
Tim verleiht sein Studio.
Nur an ausgewählten Gründen.
Wir haben ja auch unser Studio in der Raumfahrt-Agentur. Ich habe mir jetzt eine Sprechgarnitur von Tim Pritzach empfohlen.
Hörsprechgarnitur heißt das.
Ich habe jetzt eine Sendung damit gemacht, aber die ist gut. Man muss nicht immer am Mikro bleiben.
Genau, die zwei.
Aber es klingt schöner.
Wenn man an der richtigen Stelle ist, klingt es schöner, genau. Nur eine Strom-Klarenz. Wir haben hier glaube ich noch eine Menge mehr Strom.
Ich kann meins auch verleihen, hier meinen Strom.
Komm doch erstmal rein.
Komm doch erstmal rein. Fühl dich willkommen.
Wo ist die Schokolade?
Drei, ich glaube ich hatte sogar...
Ich habe euch die ganze Zeit zugehört, du hattest recht mit dem weiträumig umfahrenden...
Du musst erstmal dein Headset aufsetzen, dann darfst du auch an der Sendung teilhaben. Bis dahin...
Es wird doch alles hochgerechnet nachher. Einmal habt ihr eine ganze Sendung mit Dennis ohne Mikro gemacht, und der war trotzdem zu hören hinterher. Aber ich hatte auch schon so eine Sendung, da war irgendwie die halbe Sendung. Auf Honig rettet einem dann die andere.
Wenn ich zumindest noch die Original-Dateien archiviert hätte, was mir auch nicht gelungen ist, dann könnte ich heute wahrscheinlich da noch richtig was rausholen aus der Sendung. Jahre später? Ich meine, erstens war das eine gute Sendung, und zweitens ist ja nun betorrent nicht...
Anniversary Edition auf Mobile Max.
So, Herde an Mobile Max. Ja, weiträumig umfahren, du hattest recht. Hinternauen, kurz rechts abbiegen. Wir haben ein bisschen was abgesperrt in Berlin wieder mal.
Ach, die Janowitzbrücke stand voll mit Wasserwerfern.
Genau, also man musste heute...
Auch weiter, auch Potsdamer Platz, alles, wie gesagt, auch nach Westen.
Spreewasser?
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie da Wasser rausgeholt haben, das hab ich nicht gesehen. Aber die hatten da drei Wasserwerfer und zwei Räumfahrzeuge.
Also ich bin aus, ja, naja, das interessiert morgen ja keinen mehr, wie die Verkehrslage heute in Berlin ist, aber für die Live-Hörer, also ich kann empfehlen, nein, Quatsch.
Also mit Fahrrad kommt man überall durch. Also ich bin zumindest überall durchgekommen mit meinem Fahrrad.
Ja, hättest du mal vorhin am Cotty probieren dürfen. Da ging nicht. Ja, schön, dass du da bist.
Danke.
Ja, Clemens, wo kommst du denn voran? Wir sollten vielleicht mal reden darüber, was du machst.
Nee.
Nee?
Später aber. Nächstes Mal. Auch nicht. Scheiße.
Macht so viel Spaß, ja.
Du hast ja mit so vielen Leuten geredet, du warst ja sozusagen all over Germany irgendwie, sogar in den iTunes-Charts.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen krass, das find ich auch schon ein bisschen, hat mich denn auch etwas entsetzt.
Ja, wurde immer gefragt, wer heißt denn der Sänger?
Und vor allen Dingen findet eigentlich echt schade, weil die Leute das jetzt irgendwie auf mich projizieren, aber da wird die ganze Arbeit gemacht. Ich hab ja nur ein bisschen rumgeschimpft.
Der Frontman kriegt all die Girls.
Wir sehen uns.
Ja, das war doch sehr nett, wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat, hier unser Funktional-Kaputzung vom letzten Mal wurde dann auch bei iTunes eingestellt. Kann sich da auch noch, den kann man da auch noch kaufen. Das Geld geht wiederum als Spende an die digitale Gesellschaft. Also Lust hat sich da allein deshalb mal daran beteiligt.
Das ist nicht in anderen Stores, also nicht in Amazon und Google Play oder so was sagt. Toll fand ich die Rezensionen im iTunes-Store, die sind echt toll. Da hat zum Beispiel einer geschrieben, dieser Song heilt Pflanzen, er hat den irgendwie seinen kaputten Geranien vorgespielt und seitdem sind die voll fit. Oder, das fand ich irgendwie dann auch schon.
Positiv, der kommt auch in Music-Stores.
Ja, da war ein paar Gänsehörer dabei.
Leider zeigen sie einem nicht an, wo es gerade auf der Liste ist. Man muss noch mal diese ganze Scheiß Top 100 durchscrollen. Wo sind die in der Rezension? Ach hier, da.
Da muss man immer rechts sein. Da gibt es so diese Ratings and Reviews.
Ach da, ah ok.
Das ist ja mega.
125 Leute haben ihm 5 Sterne gegeben und 2 Leute haben auch 1 Stern.
Ob die schreiben?
Ich würde mal sagen, wir holen mal Most Critical hoch.
René Obermann oder was? Und sein Marketingleiter.
Top eBay gerne wieder steht hier.
Den fand ich auch nicht schön.
Und das ist ja wichtig, dass wir Spaß haben.
Und bei Soundcloud ja immerhin fast stolze 30.000 Plays mittlerweile. Also das ist ja auch schon mal sehr heftig und dann hat das ja auf Flatter diesmal dem David auch mal ordentlich was gebracht. Was der für 1 Minute 30 da verdient hat an fetter Klicks, da stricken wir hier 4 Stunden manchmal dran.
Er hat ja auch 108 Intros, die er damit quasi mitgeflattert wäre.
Ja die Reviews sind wirklich gut. I don't understand a word, but the rhythm is magic. Best track ever when being stoned. Oder auch ging schnell über ihr erste Enzaladen. Pure Emotion. Kaufen für die Gerechtigkeit, so sieht's aus. Toller Podcast, tolles Lied. Ja, ja, wir haben es auch in die Fanboys geschafft im Oehring.
Ja, überall eigentlich, oder? Also ich meine Netzpolitik, im Twitter wurde das ja auch tausend Millionenfach.
Fritz hat's gespielt. Linus hat's mir geschickt, so, du läufst jetzt im Radio und ich so, hm, okay. Lustig, aber.
Wir machen weiter. Ja, weiß nicht, lohnt es das Thema Drossel jetzt nochmal, um einen Tisch zu heben, so richtig was getan hat sich da nicht, aber es gab dann doch deutlich mehr Presseecho, als ich es für möglich gehalten habe, insgesamt. Also ich fand das mehr, als ich dachte. Ich hätte gedacht, das geht relativ schnell unter, so zwei Tage später.
Ist schnell hochgegangen, ist aber auch genauso schnell wieder runtergegangen. Alle ergießen sich so ein bisschen auch seit Tagen in den Tweets in diesem na ja, man kann ja eh nichts machen Modus. So, das heißt, die haben jetzt mal alle ordentlich mit den Schultern gezuckt und dann warten wir jetzt so. Ich denke mal, dass das, ich habe ja neulich schon mal vorgeschlagen, dass das ja daran liegen könnte, dass die Telekom das vielleicht wirklich absichtlich geleakt hat. Die haben sich gesagt, lieber kurz und kräftig, kleiner Shitstorm, okay, vielleicht haben sie jetzt nicht damit gerechnet, aber jetzt haben sie das Ding durch und wenn sie das jetzt wirklich mal anbringen, dann ist das News von gestern. Deswegen warten sie auch noch mit dem echten Drosseln. Wir haben ja Zeit, wir wissen ja alle, dass sie das nicht machen müssen. Das, weil ihnen ja nicht das Netz kaputt geht oder sonst irgendwas, sondern die können das ja irgendwann mal machen und dann ist es so old news, dass wirklich nicht mal der hintertupfinger Tageblatt da noch irgendwie in alle Teile von verliert.
Aber das wird den Leuten schon auf die Nerven gehen, plötzlich nur noch 384 Kilo Bits zu haben.
Ja, aber dann ist die Aufregung vorbei. Der Ärger bleibt, das ist unbestritten. Der jetzt da ist, der kommt nochmal wieder. Aber da können die Leute schreien, was sie wollen. Also die Presse wäre immer mit zu sagen, ja, pff, haben wir doch schon vor zwei Jahren abgehändelt.
Was ich erstaunlich fand, ist, dass die Tatsache, dass es ja schon Verträge gibt mit Drosseln, mit Drosseln geflissentlich umgangen wurde. Mir ist allerdings auch im Nachgang erst klar geworden, dass die Drosselung, die es schon gibt in den Verträgen, ausschließlich in VDSL 25 und VDSL 50 drin ist. Ohne Entertain, wiederum, genau. Was insofern ja ganz bemerkenswert ist, dass ja Entertain billiger ist als der normale VDSL. Mit Entertain zahlst du 5 Euro weniger. Frag die Telekom.
Das glaube ich jetzt mal nicht.
Das heißt also, wenn man VDSL haben will, dann sollte man es jetzt noch beantragen?
Ja, dann ist es vielleicht wieder so ein Deal mit in den ersten 12 Monaten irgendwie billiger, weil Aktions-Tralala und so.
45 Euro statt 50.
Wie so 50 Euro? Alle anderen Leute, die VDSL haben, die kennen zahlen eh bloß 40. Jetzt guckt der Tim. Nee, nee, 50er. Kenne keinen, der einen VDSL 25 hat.
Ja, und ich 40 Euro?
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe jetzt auch keinen Nerv, auf den Telekom-Seiten rumzuklicken. Mir war heute schon schlecht.
Lass mich gerne eines Besseren belegen. Ich hatte ja noch mal explizit, als ich gerade diese ganzen Telekom-Votes hatte, mir hier Unterstützung angeboten wurde, kam unter anderem dann auch noch der, warum machst du denn nicht entertain? Da ist es dann auch noch 5 Euro billiger. Das war sozusagen die Aussage. Und was ich damals nicht wusste, was ich erst jetzt im Rahmen dieser ganzen Drossel-Kampagne verstanden habe, ist, dass es halt in den Entertain-Verträgen nicht drin ist. Das heißt, mit Drossel ist es teurer als ohne Drossel. Trotzdem sagen sie ja, ihr Entertain-Fernsehprogramm spielt ja keine Rolle. Dann frage ich mich, was jetzt der Unterschied ist. Also wenn ich sozusagen ihr Scheiß nehme, dann habe ich gar keine Drossel.
Wir haben es damals einfach nicht verstanden. Aber ihre Logik, die sind ja schön. Welche Logik? War da jemals irgendeine Logik irgendwo drin?
Na ja, ihre vorgegebene Logik in der Argumentation.
Ja, aber nochmal, das ist einfach Dämlichkeit. Du glaubst immer auch, so Riesenkonzerne, die sind so unglaublich schlau und die haben Anwälte, bis der Arzt kommt. Und da läuft das Brain, das fließt da nur so durch die Gänge und so. Die sind genauso doof wie alle anderen, manchmal sogar noch döver. Ich kann dir mal eine super kleine Anekdote fallen lassen. Ihr habt da sicherlich mal mitgekriegt, irgendwann in den 90ern, oder war es schon 2000 irgendwann, hat doch mal der Vodafone den Mannesmann Mobilfunk gekauft. Da waren auch nur richtig große Konzerne, wo du nun meinst, da rannten hundertschaften von Rechtsanwälten durch die Gegend. Und dann sind sie hingegangen und hatten eine Vodafone AG und dann wollten sie hingehen, noch eine Vodafone GmbH anmelden. Und so ein kleiner Popel, irgendwo in Düsseldorf, da beim Amtsgericht, hat ihnen klarmachen müssen, dass du keine zwei Kapitalgesellschaften gleichen Namens haben darfst. Eine als AG und keine GmbH. Das weiß jeder Rechtswissenschafts-Student im zweiten oder dritten Semester. Nur die mit ihren 100 anmelden wussten das nicht. Und da denkst du jetzt so, wie kann denn das sein? Zwei riesen Konzerne, die sich mergendet. Wie kann denen so was passieren? Und das ist der selbe Grund, warum denen so was passiert, dass sie ihre AGBs nicht richtig gebastelt kriegen. Deswegen bauen sie die auch dauernd immer wieder um.
Gerade bei der Tete kommen.
So, Fall in Suff kommt vor, VDSL 3995.
Ja, ab. Mit irgendwie, wenn du... Aber auch nur für das erste Jahr und dann nicht mehr oder so. Du musst das Kleingedruckte lesen, das ist alles total verwirrend.
Aber wo ist denn hier hinter dem...
Aber lassen wir das.
Wie gesagt, es war halt schon schlecht.
Können wir nicht mal einen eigenen Provider machen?
Es wurde ja auch mehrfach vorgeschlagen. Technisch, wie gesagt, es hat kein Rocket Science. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass da irgendwie Geheimwissenschaften stattfinden, um so was zu tun. Es gibt so ein paar Probleme, die man sich mal überlegen müsste. Wenn du dein Produkt nicht nur irgendwie auf dem Sportplatz anbieten willst, sondern vielleicht in einer größeren Umgebung, wo auch mal so ein öffentlicher Weg oder irgendwas dazwischen ist, dann musst du ja immer überlegen, wie du die Kabel zu den Leuten nach Hause kriegst.
Na gut, also sagen wir mal, die letzte Meile, die nehmen wir halt von der Telekom, ist halt so ein...
Ja, aber auch das ist schon ein Problem. Ich weiß, das hören auch Leute von der Telekom zu. Sie twittern mir auch, aber ich habe echt das Gefühl, dass die Telekom extra dafür die Leute ausgesiebt hat mit einem IQ unter 70, die sie so haben, die haben wir da ein paar Hunderttausend von, und dann haben sie die ausgesiebt mit IQ unter 70 und die haben gesagt, pass auf, du machst jetzt bitte die Teilnehmeranschlussleitung für unsere Mitbewerber. Also wenn zum Beispiel ein 1&1 oder irgendjemand anders hingeht oder ein Alice oder ein O2 und sagt, hallo liebe Telekom, ich bräuchte hier mal ein Stück letzte Meile, dann schicken sie den los, der am kränkesten ist und der auch sonst irgendwie nicht alle Tassen im Schrank hat.
Ja, das ist ja alles, aber...
Aber das hilft dir... Guck mal, du willst doch einen eigenen Provider machen, damit du diesen Ärger los bist.
Ja gut, aber den Ärger wirst du ja nicht los.
Eben.
Und was ist jetzt das Problem an der letzten Meile?
Nö, du musst einen Bürgersteig aufreißen oder dir das Zeug von der Telekom anbieten.
Genau, aber das, was du eigentlich als Provider, als tolles Feature anbietest, nämlich keine Drosselung...
Das kannst du jetzt auch schon machen. Das kannst du ja machen. Du kannst dich bei der Telekom sagen, wir nehmen sogar eure DSLAMs und alles mit. Nur euer T-Online mit der Drossel drin, das könnt ihr euch knicken und wir hängen uns da hinten dran und haben da Spaß. Ich habe ja so einen Zugang, weil ich mit dem teste, das habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, deswegen habe ich auch schon seit etlicher Zeit auch IPv6 da drauf, also auch lange bevor die Telekom das angenipst hat. Also sowas gibt es, sowas kann man machen. Aber da müsste man sich jetzt mal die Preise angucken, müsste man mal gucken, was die Telekom dafür haben will. Weil auch da gibt es natürlich Rechenwerte, wo du sagst, ab diesem Wert lohnt sich das nicht mehr. Das heißt, du musst jetzt auch wieder dieselbe Rechnung aufmachen, wie sie die anderen Provider machen, also sagen, hoffen, dass du nicht nur die Power-User kriegst. Das ist auch das Problem, das andere jetzt haben. Wenn wir so ein Ding aufmachen würden, würden wir die ganzen User abkriegen, die von der Drossel betroffen sind. Das sind auch die Leute, die nicht aufhören bei 76G oder so. Die wollen es dann auch wirklich wissen. Die wollen schon aus Prinzip wissen, ob da auch irgendwie vier Terabyte durchpassen in der Woche. Und in diesem Rechenbeispiel kannst du das machen, aber dann musst du halt eben Anschluss anbieten, der sich 150-200 Euro im Monat kostet. Das spielt natürlich auch wieder keiner mit. Na ja, man könnte es ja gestaffelt haben. Aber man müsste es mal nachrechnen.
Was ich ja ganz interessant fand, ist die Drossel, die LadiCable Deutschland macht. Die finde ich in gewisser Hinsicht noch zu vertreten, weil die haben ja ein tägliches Kontingent. Und das liegt, glaube ich, bei 100GB. Also wenn du 100GB pro Tag verbrauchst, dann greift eine Drossel und dann ist es aber auch nach dem Tag wieder vorbei. Das heißt, du hast eine tägliche Deckelung und nicht eine monatliche.
Ja, und sie machen den Ding nicht komplett kaputt. Sie fahren nicht nur irgendwie auf 6 MB.
Ja, genau.
Bei 100GB pro Tag ist nun mal eine ganz andere Aussage als 75 GB im Monat.
Ja, und sie machen das auch. Machen sie das halt, wenn du BitTorrent sehr viel saugst, dann drosseln sie halt nur die BitTorrent-Protokolle sozusagen und lassen den Rest noch weiter flutschen.
Ja, wobei das finde ich schon wieder fragwürdig.
Geht das auch mit Verschlüsselung mit BitTorrent?
Ja, aber beim Shared Medium ist es halt vielleicht ja dann auch okay.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die auch Verschlüsselung in irgendeiner Form drosseln? Trotzdem detektieren zu können?
Verschlüsselung detektieren ist kein Problem, aber dann zu detektieren, dass es BitTorrent ist in der Verschlüsselung.
Tja, wie weit ist die Deep Packet Inspection heutzutage?
Du hast auch Traffic Pattern, wo du einfach siehst, was läuft wie viel wo hin und her. Du kannst zum Beispiel auch IP-Streams dadurch erkennen, dass es schön, egal ob sie verschlüsselt sind oder nicht, dass sie schön gradlinig dieselbe Bitrate in beide Richtungen fahren. Das ist Comfort-Neuss oder? Nö, nicht Comfort-Neuss. Niemand macht Comfort-Neuss an oder diese Unterdrückung. Niemand. Also heute nicht mehr, das ist einfach Quack. Nehmen wir an, du hast jetzt ein ganz normales A-Law-Gespräch, dann hast du halt deine 64 Kilobit plus ein bisschen Overhead und die rauschen da so richtig gradlinig durch. Da ist nicht ein Bit pro Sekunde mehr oder weniger drin. Und dann kannst du das jetzt nochmal verschlüsseln, aber das ändert dann diesen Traffic-Pattern nicht. Damit kannst du die zum Beispiel erkennen. Also es gibt schon da Möglichkeiten. Und BitTorrent hat halt eben auch so seine Signaturen, wie das halt da vor sich hin bürstet und macht und tut und wieviel Connections plötzlich von einer Kiste irgendwo hinkommen oder wieviel Connections sie plötzlich empfängt von draußen oder so. Also da gibt es schon Möglichkeiten. Ja, das war jetzt ganz tief aus den Untiefen der Bösen. Das war von der anderen Seite der Macht.
So, muss ich ja nochmal...
Geht der Font noch ein bisschen kleiner?
Ich hab hier gerade mal die M-Seite erwischt und... Vollversion, Lightversion... Ach, das ist schon die Vollversion. Wenn ich jetzt auf klassische Webseite gehe... Das ist so geil, da haben sie ja auch echte Experten bei welt.de. Du bist auf mwelt.de. Dann bieten sie dir unten irgendwie die Ansicht, Mobil und klassische Webseite. Aber wenn du auf klassische Webseite gehst, dann kommst du natürlich auf die Homepage. Es wäre definitiv zu viel verlangt, auch noch die passende URL für denselben Artikel rauszusuchen.
Mit dem Nächsten gibt es drei Sparten.
Zu Hause, Mobil oder Telekom.
Oder gedrosselt.
Also ganz grob.
Auf jeden Fall fand ich diesen Artikel hier sehr schön. Die neueste deutsche Protestbewegung ist noch keine fünf Tage alt und hat schon ihre Hymne. Es ist einfach funktional kaputt. Rap das Berliner Podcast-Team von pobabax.de in seiner musikalischen Wiene drosselt.
Die haben Rat und Drap verwechselt.
Quelle-Doppelpunkt-Internet.
Hast du das schon gehört?
Ja, ich hab das schon gehört. Vor der Sendung hab ich das gehört.
Hat sich schon rumgesprochen, Dennis.
Ja, ich noch nicht.
Du hast es noch nicht gehört.
Du hast es doch im Vorsprung gehört, oder nicht?
Du hast es doch in der Sendung gehört.
Letztes Mal hab ich nur so halb gehört.
Du hast es nicht gehört. Wir müssen es jetzt noch mal einspielen.
Super.
Wenn die anderen das machen.
Das haben jetzt 30.000 Leute und noch mehr gehört. Jetzt einer mehr.
Dann kommt es jetzt auch nicht drauf an.
Die 1,30 Minuten, die haben wir doch.
Tim, hast du das gekauft oder spielst du das jetzt einfach nur mal ab? Alter rechte Brecher.
Du meinst, ich sollte es noch offiziell runterladen von iTunes oder was?
Ja, fände ich jetzt mal okay.
Na, ich hab's schon gekauft. Das müsste hier in Purchased auftragen. Ich weiß immer nicht wie genau. Auftauchen müsste es, ich weiß bloß nicht. Wie ist denn das hier mit runterladen von einem anderen Rechner mit diesem scheiß iTunes-Store? Ich benutze das ja kaum.
Das hatten wir ja vorhin schon.
Check for available downloads. Aber hier ist nichts zu finden von irgendwie kaputt.
Und dieses iTunes.
Ja, Clemens hat gesagt, er will das jetzt hier nochmal.
Der wusste schon, dass das so ein Schmerz wird. Der wollte jetzt einfach nicht, dass du in der Lage bist, abzuspielen.
Ich habe es ja schon gekauft.
Auf YouTube ist es aber 5 Minuten lang.
Merke das jetzt auch, dass ich das schon gekauft habe? Oder zeige ich dir jetzt nochmal? Stunden später, tags darauf. Ja, du hast es schon gekauft.
Die iTunes Store-Regeln haben sich geändert. Bitte klicken Sie sich durch unser AGB.
Ach, die Welt ist so schlecht. Das fühlt sich wirklich... Also, SSD war wirklich das erste und einzige, was mich so am 21. Jahrhundert wie 21. Jahrhundert angefühlt hat. Alles andere ist Käse irgendwie.
Wir hätten die Musikkasse niemals verlassen sollen.
16 GB RAM fühlen sich auch gut an, finde ich, am 21. Jahrhundert.
Ja, aber von diesem Quantensprung, also Quantensprung ist ja wieder das falsche Wort, aber von diesem Fortschrittgefühl war doch SSD, muss ich sagen, das signifikanteste Update.
So, Dennis, für dich, bitte schön.
Das ist einfach kaputt. Dann ist das einfach funktional kaputt.
Genau.
So ein bisschen mehr Hip-Hop-Astiel müssen kommen, oder? So ein bisschen mehr Aggro ist zu nett.
Na ja, das kann ja noch kommen, was ist ja geil. Also die Remix-Saison ist eröffnet.
Also ich hab ja keine Ahnung, das ist ja auch toll gemacht.
Ich kann auch gerne... Wenn ich das gemacht hätte, hätte ich was Akro-mäßiges genommen. Wenn jetzt ernsthaft irgendjemand da ein Remix ist oder so was Interesse hat, wovon ich jetzt nicht unbedingt ausgehe, aber nur falls... Naja, ich würde vor allem die Stelle noch mal spursepariert rausgeben, damit diese ganzen Huste rein und so weiter da nicht mehr drin sind. Ich nehme ja e-Multi-Track auf und so, das heißt, ich könnte den Teil noch mal raussuchen.
Du meinst, du machst ja so wie Radiohead, dass du die einzelnen Spuren rausgibst auch zum Mixen?
Genau, ich suche einfach mal das raus und dann kann sich da jeder bedienen, wie er möchte. Das gilt übrigens auch für dich, David, falls du mal etwas separierter brauchst dann, ne?
Ja, aber dann ist ja der Überraschungseffekt weg. Du solltest ihm einen grundsätzlichen Exzess auf die einzelnen Spuren geben. Ja, aber nicht, dass du sie bei dir abfragst, dann weißt du ja vorher, was kommt für den nächsten Film.
Ich weiß vorher nicht, was kommt. Ich würde ja dann einfach alles, weißt du? Na mal gucken, vielleicht, ich warte ja noch auf das Multi-Trick-Feature von Opphonic, dann gibt es das vielleicht mal serienmäßig irgendwann mal. Ich weiß nicht, hier wollen wir noch darüber reden, hier blablabla, Telekom, YouTube, ja und so weiter. Und YouTube kann ja zahlen und so. Ich bin übrigens, ich habe über das eine oder andere Argument ja auch noch mal nachgedacht. Du bist ja vehementer Vertreter der These, dieses Entertainen müsste da ja rausgenommen werden wegen dieser Trennung und so weiter.
Wie rausgenommen werden?
Naja, weil das Entertainen ja quasi so auf der Last Mile irgendwie eingespielt wird und nicht auf der Internet.
Wir haben doch schon diskutiert, dass die ja aber das, die machen da massiv mit ihrem Spotify und verletzten die Netzneutralität, aber Entertainen nur gerade eben nicht, das ist versehentlich auf demselben Kabel mit drauf, genauso wie auf Kabel Deutschlands, Kabel, die ja auch drosseln versehentlich noch Fernsehprogramm mit drauf ist. Die schalten dir auch nicht dein RTL ab, nur weil jetzt irgendwie deine 100 Gig voll sind an dem Tag. Das geht übrigens schon deswegen nicht, weil dann würde in Deutschland die Revolution ausbrechen.
Ja, aber wäre nun T-Online und TDSL nicht dann doch derselbe Konzern, bezweifle ich, dass T-Online mit dieser Initiative der Drosselung wirklich so voran marschieren würde. Und außerdem ändert das letztlich nichts daran, dass mit diesem ganzen Fernsehangebot konkurrieren sie sehr wohl mit den Sachen da draußen. Nur weil das jetzt technisch...
Tut aber der Kabel Deutschland mit seinem Fernsehangebot auch? Also nur weil das über die selbe Kabel kommt, über die selbe Strippe kommt, kann man das nicht in einen Topf schmeißen mit einem anderen. Das kann man machen, aber dann muss man wirklich alle gleich behandeln. Dann muss man auch sagen, ey Vodafone, wenn bei dir dein, wie auch immer, wenn der User sein G-Paket da runter ist und du ihn drosselst, musst du ihm auch die Sprache drosseln. Was natürlich komplett albern ist, aber dann musst du wie gesagt das auch tun. Weil das hast du auf allen Kanälen, die wir so haben, die uns die Medien nach Hause bringen, findet heutzutage Triple Play statt. Okay, das mit dem Fernsehen ist ihnen so ein bisschen schiefgegangen, diese DVB-H oder was die da machen wollten, über Handy-Netze oder sonst so. Ganz krasse Geschichten. Das ist ihnen so ein bisschen verunglückt, aber vom Prinzip träumen sie immer noch davon, träumen auch die Mobilfunk-Provider noch davon, dass die auch wieder dein Skype-Paket oder was weiß ich, über das Mobilfunknetz nach Hause bringen. Das heißt, sie träumen alle davon, die Internet, Telefonie und Fernsehen zu verkaufen. Das machen sie natürlich über ihre selbe Luft oder über das selbe Kabel oder das selbe Glasfaser, wie auch immer. Und die sind aber von ihrer Natur unterschiedlich. Wenn man sehr über einen Kamm stehlen will, was man tun könnte, muss man so aber auch alle über einen Kamm stehlen. Da kann man nicht hingehen und die arme Telekom beißen und sagen, dein System basiert ja auf IP, was das übrigens bei anderen Medien auch tut. Nur nicht im Kabel. Aber nur weil es jetzt auf eine IP-Technologie basiert, aber nichts mit dem Internet zu tun hat, regulieren wird es jetzt anders als die anderen. Das finde ich dann auch wieder nicht fair. Obwohl, warum soll man eigentlich fair sein zur Telekom? Sekunde. Ist das eigentlich ein blöder Gedanke?
Ja, ich verstehe das auch nicht so ganz genau.
Wo du es anbringst, wenn man ein bisschen tiefer drüber nachdenkt.
Ich meine, jetzt war die letzte Aussage, das war zu dem Zeitpunkt, als hier unsere RANS-Primär entstanden, noch nicht ganz klar, dass sie das 2016 machen wollen. Und ich würde sagen, die Karten sind dann eh schon wieder neu gemischt.
Eben.
Von daher müssen wir uns da jetzt gar nicht weiter drüber aufregen. Regen wir uns lieber über andere Sachen auf. Apple hat sich jetzt eingesehen, dass wir einfach Fakten geschaffen haben hier in diesem Podcast und haben sich unserer Empfehlungen gebeugt. Und am 3. Mai wird der Apple Store eröffnet, wie wir schon gehört haben, ohne Glastreppe. Und ja, findet statt. Und jetzt sind wir natürlich wieder in dieser unangenehmen Situation, dass wir uns darüber Gedanken machen müssen. Was machen wir jetzt? Machen wir was? Oder nicht? Also ich, wir können Empfehlungen ausgeben.
Den die Jubelperser mal ein bisschen aufmischen? Untermischen, uns unter die Jubelperser mischen.
Wir können ja mal verschiedene Ansätze fahren. Also sehen wir das doch ganz erst mal hier positiv. Also Apple, unsere Lieblingsfirma mit den geilen Produkten, der Lifestyle der letzten Dekade und auch der nächsten Dekade.
Der Modenausstatter.
Das, was unseren Status reflektiert, was einfach in ist, die Spude und wir sind im Hörich. Und jetzt kommt dieser geile Laden, kommt zu spät. Und ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie es so wäre, wenn man so bei Apple so ein Crew-Manager ist oder wie das auch mal heißen mag. Und man muss jetzt so einen Laden und so eine Truppe irgendwie echt auf Vordermann bringen. Stellt euch einfach mal vor, ihr seid jetzt die ausgewählten Apple Store-Mitarbeiter. Also die Movamax-Crew geht jetzt an Start.
Wollen wir uns bei einem Praktikum bewerben?
Support und so. Bitte?
Wir können uns ja zu einem Praktikum bewerben. Du kannst doch mal ein bisschen hinter der Genius Bar stehen. Und ich sollte tägliche Leiter Apple User anhören.
Na jetzt ist das halt einfach so, nimmst jetzt einfach als Fakt hin, ja? Und jetzt wird eröffnet. Und dann musst du stolz sein auf deinen Laden.
Scheiße.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das reicht nicht.
Hey, Stimmung! Wir sind die Besten! Das wäre ja cooler, wenn ihr jetzt sehr vieles...
Guck mal, das war schon eine sehr schöne Mobile-Max-T-Shirt.
Apropos Mobile-Max-T-Shirts, warum gibt es eigentlich keine Mobile-Max-T-Shirts?
Wir bleiben jetzt erstmal beim Apple Store. Ich hatte noch was Schönes im Internet gefunden.
Aber für einen Freitag wäre es praktisch Mobile-Max-T-Shirts.
Sollten uns Leute zuhören, die in so einem Theater, wie heißt der denn jetzt? Fundus arbeiten? Ja, Requisite. Requisite, genau. Wir müssen uns ja schon darüber Gedanken machen. Also entweder wir gehen da gar nicht hin. Das ist ja schon so ein bisschen Arschkarte und so ein bisschen so... Da weiß man ja nicht, was da war. Ja, da wissen wir wieder nicht, was da war.
Das wird dann berichtet in allen Landesmedien.
Aber wenn wir da sind, dann ist es so, ah ihr seid auch hier und so wie langweilig. Also du kannst es nur falsch machen. Dann kann man auch gleich hingehen. Die Frage ist, wie. Man kann natürlich jetzt einfach gelangweilt da rumstehen. Ich hab mir auch bei Amazon mal so eine Schreimaske irgendwie so schonmal geklickt, ist leider noch nicht da. Aber ich dachte mir, wenn wir so Mönchs kutten, dann könnte man das ja hier irgendwie... Ich spiel das mal kurz ein hier.
Musst du mal in V-Chat den Link schmeißen. Ich hab das nicht gesagt.
Wird geschnitten.
Ja, guck mal, diese Herren hier, haben alle so iPads in der Hand.
Hauen sich die mit Schmackes vor die Glocke.
Genau, und das fände ich mal eine geile Performance, wenn man einfach so in Mönchskutte mit iPads in der Hand. Ja, der Text ist noch nicht ganz richtig, der muss dann anders sein. Ich geb das mal. So, das ist ja hier alles mit Jesus und so weiter, ne? Das Interessante ist, ich hab dann nachgeschlagen, Apfel heißt auf Lateinisch, ich hoffe jetzt kommen nicht irgendwelche Leute mit großen Latino.
Die kommen natürlich, aber ist ja gut dann.
Also ich hab's im Internet nachgeschlagen, muss man jetzt gleich vorweg zu sagen, maybe I'm wrong here, aber das ist so das, was das Internet ausgespuckt hat. Und Apfel heißt auf Lateinisch Malum.
Malus. Der Apfel. Ich hatte Latein, ja, aber ich hab alles vergessen.
Aber den Apfel.
Es steht doch in der Wikipedia, Malus. Oder irre ich mich jetzt? Also Apfel und das Schlechte.
Hier irgendwie der Baum, die Frucht, der Erkenntnis, blablabla. Adam und Eva Apfel ist doch verschissen.
Das ist aber christlich, Vogel. Da hatten die Römer erst später was mit am Hut. Mit dem Christlichen und Adam und Eva.
Na ja, weil es das Wort ist, haben sie dann den Apfel so benannt wie übel.
Die alten Römer hatten ohnehin komische Assoziationen immer mit irgendwas. Zum Beispiel hat uns unser Lateinlehrer mal erzählt, die hatten tierisch Schiss vor Wald. Ja, der Wald war für den typischen Römer, vor allem für den typischen rövelischen Legionär, war der Horror schlechthin. Weil da die Germanen drin hausten, auf den Bäumen sitzen und dann auf die armen kleinen Legionäre runterfallen. Ernsthaft, die hatten echt Schiss vor Wald. Deswegen kann man auch durchaus sagen, vielleicht fanden sie auch Apfelscheiße. Und deswegen haben sich da so... weiß man nicht, da kann man jetzt spekulieren drüber.
Ja, aber ich meine, ich benutze jetzt hier Dikt. D-E-L-A Punkt Dikt Punkt C-C. Dikt.cc ist ja meine Lieblingsdiktionärie im Internet, falls jemand nochmal ein gutes Diktionärie sucht. Ich fand das schon immer am besten. Wie auch immer. Und hier steht Malum. Und die Übersetzung von Malum ist Apfel, übel, Fehler, Gebrechen, Laster, Pfiffigkeit, Quitte auch übrigens, Schaden, Übeltat, Unglück, Unheil. Und Zitrone auch. Also sie haben es irgendwie nicht so ernst, also mit dem, ich weiß nicht, mit dem Ost.
Hauptsache es ist sauer.
Was?
Ah, hier wird kommuniziert.
Ah, Malus ist böse und Malus ist Apfel.
Es gibt kurze und lange A's im Lateinischen. Was mit einem Akzent drauf oder was? Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das gibt es aber nicht im Lateinischen, also nicht in dem Latein, was ich gelernt habe.
Soll das jetzt...
Das soll ein A, ein langes A sein. Malus.
Was ist denn das da, so ein Cedir oder ein Enir oder was soll das da sein? Das kriegen die doch mit ihrem Meißel niemals in den Stein geklopft. Geklöppelt. Also wir halten einfach mal fest, in Dateien ist es dasselbe. Jetzt haben wir sozusagen hier... Texten wir das mal um und ersetzen einfach mal Jesus durch Apple. Dann heißt das Pie Malum Domine Dona Nobis Requiem. Und das heißt ja dann sie, also gib ihnen... Nee, was war das? Das heißt schon fast vergessen wir irgendwie.
Was ist denn jetzt hier mit den Lateinen?
Ist geil. Wenn Engländer von der Waldorfschule sich in einem deutschen Podcast an Latein versuchen.
Ja guck mal, also Dona Es Requiem heißt, in der englischen Wikipedia wird es übersetzt mit give them rest. Also gib ihnen Ruhe oder gib ihnen was auch immer sie damit meinen. Jetzt müsste man das mal umdrehen, also wenn jetzt hier jemand Latein kann...
Ja, Hauptsache, wenn dann der Engländer und Horns IP vor dem Kopf.
Gib uns Ruhe.
Was heißt gib uns Ruhe? Also nicht Dona Es, Dona, was ist denn da was? Dona Es, Dona Es geben, oder? Dann heißt Es Ihnen.
Einmal oben drücken.
Und was heißt uns? Was würde uns, gib uns Ruhe heißen? Weil dann könnten wir nämlich dahin gehen, die uns die iPads von Kopf hauen in der Mönzkutte und dazu singen, oh, großartiges Apple, genau, Apple unser Gott, lass uns in Frieden.
Oder? Da sollte man aber nochmal jemanden fragen, der Latein kann. Ich bin das nicht.
Diesen schönen kirchlichen Dona Nobis Patschem.
Heißt Nobis uns? Ja, ha, grant us peace. Gib uns, das heißt, ich würde das jetzt mal frei übersetzen mit Dona Nobis Requiem. Das ist doch auch sehr schön, das klingt sogar noch besser.
Nach einer freien Übersetzung von Tim Brüthler.
Frieden, Hallo, Frieden, Patschem?
Nein, nein, ich will ja nicht, ich will ja nur...
Nee, nee, die sollen uns keinen Frieden geben, die sollen uns in Ruhe lassen. Pie Malum Domine Dona Nobis Requiem.
Dann gehst du dahin, sagst das auf und haust dir das iPad von Kaufdebau.
Und das als Performance.
Ja, wenn wir jetzt noch Mobile-Max-T-Shirts anhanden...
Kutten bräuchten wir noch.
Mobile-Max-Kutten.
Warum haben wir keine Mobile-Max-T-Shirts?
Mobile-Max-Münz-Kutten. Mobile-Max-Bade-Mäntel wären auch gut, weil wir uns erstmal umbenennen müssen, uns ein ordentliches Logo verpassen müssen, das sieht ja nicht aus. Ja, das kommt. Das machen wir noch.
Also für die, die also nicht wissen, was wir übermorgen anstellen wollen, zu dieser großartigen Veranstaltung, der wir schon seit Jahren entgegenblicken. Also ehrlich gesagt, ja. Mich juckt dieser Apple Store überhaupt ja nicht.
Mir schon, ich will ein Neues.
Was? Neues Store.
Ich würde gerne die Öffnung sehen.
Was würdest du gerne sehen?
Die Öffnung.
Ja, ich muss mal sehen, ob ich da… Gut, haben wir abgesperrt.
Sich dann hinstellen und die Leute da total auslachen?
Ja, oder drüber lächeln, bis die da machen.
Falls es noch Hörer gibt, die irgendwie gut in Erinnerung haben, wir haben ja irgendwie in der allerersten Mobile-Max-Sendung gab es schon mal die Voraussage, dass wenn Apple Store, wenn Apple nach Berlin kommt, dass sie zum Kudamm gehen. Ich weiß aber leider nicht mehr, in welcher Sendung das gesagt wurde. Wer das rausfindet, kriegt...
Ja, wenn es die allererste war, wird es Mobile-Max 001 gewesen sein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es in der ersten war.
Sie haben uns auf jeden Fall mal unterhalten, dass ich auch meinte, na, hier Friedrichstraße und so, und du meintest, nee, alles Pippi Fax da am Osten, und Kudamm ist der Shit.
Genau, so ist es gekommen.
Sveni ist schon wieder Bitcoin-Preise durch die Gegend gewunken. Ist das jetzt was Gutes? Er grinst dabei.
Das ist nicht so gut.
Ach, das ist der Preis für eine, ja.
Ist nicht so gut, war schon mal besser.
Ja, war schon mal besser.
Warum grinst du denn so? Hast du Shortverkäufe gemacht damit? Guck, ich hab grad wieder 5000 Euro verloren, das ist geil.
Kommen wir zu Apple.
Wir sind heute wieder sehr despektierlich. Ich insbesondere.
Hier, Quarterly Results gab's. Nö, komm, das ist schon mal ganz interessant.
Findest du nicht?
Was muss ich hier drücken, dass jetzt hier Crickets und Thumbnails eingespielt werden? Hat es nicht so ein Soundboard oder so?
Also wir sind ein paar Sachen ein bisschen unklar. Quarterly Results, sie haben wieder ihre Quartalszahlen veröffentlicht. Und ein paar Zahlen sind ganz interessant, finde ich. Erst einmal haben sie 19,5 Millionen iPads verkauft in dem Quartal. Das waren vor einem Jahr noch 11,8. Also Prozente stehen hier gerade nicht da, bin zu faul, um das auszurechnen. Auf jeden Fall viel mehr. Ich schätze mal so 80.
So genau wollten wir das gar nicht wissen.
Also ich will sagen, iPads gehen weg wie warme Semmel und da rockt wirklich der Laden. Also diese iPads verkaufen sich wie Blöde. Bei den iPhones gab es eine Steigerung von nur 2,3 Millionen, also 37,4 zu 35,1.
Bayern hat ein Tor gemacht.
1-0? So, das heißt...
Nix Barcelona.
Ja, hat sich ausgelohnert.
Deutsches Finale. So, was wollte ich damit sagen? Ah ja, genau, also iPhone steigt, aber steigt nicht monumental. Und ich glaube, dass wir auch jetzt an einem Punkt angekommen sind, wo es ganz interessant wird, weil nachdem wir jetzt seit 2007 im Prinzip so die Geburt dieser ganzen Smartphone-Welle beobachtet haben und die Leute wie Blöde jetzt Telefone gekauft haben, also die Smartphones sind, weil sie ihre Alten verkauft haben, kommen wir jetzt langsam in den Sättigungsbereich. Also in zunehmenden Maßen haben die Leute schon ihr erstes Smartphone gehabt. Also jetzt außer natürlich den Power-Usern, die sich sowieso jedes Jahr immer das Neueste kaufen müssen. Aber so auch der normale Zyklus, also der Markt verändert sich jetzt. Und während halt Android extrem angestiegen ist und im Prinzip alle Verkäufer abgedeckt hat, die nicht Apple abgedeckt hat. Also Apple ist ja immer gewachsen, also sie hat immer mehr iPhones verkauft, bis jetzt. Und Android ist relativ schnell nachgezogen und hat ja streckenweise mehr Geräte verkauft. Insgesamt, weiß ich gar nicht, wo weltweit jetzt so der Marktanteil ist in den USA, verändert sich das auf jeden Fall jetzt gerade wieder.
Also jetzt nochmal die Kurzfassung von dem ganzen Satz.
Ob die Kurzfassung ist, der Smartphone-Markt ist jetzt nicht mehr der oh geil Smartphones, das wollte ich schon auch immer haben und alle sind First-Time-Buyer und man steigt überhaupt erst mal ein.
Verschiedene große Welle am Anfang sozusagen.
Und jetzt geht es darum, wie das so mit der Loyalität zur Marke aussieht, wie die Leute, wie ihre Erfahrungen waren und ob die Leute bei der Plattform bleiben oder ob sie sie wechseln wollen.
Ob sie wiederkommen oder ja. Da gibt es ja jetzt gerade diese Studie, dass die irgendwie beim iPhone wiederkommen und die bei Android eher nicht so toll.
Ja, das kann man...
Das ist jetzt deine Chance jetzt hier dich einzubringen.
Das ist die Quelle von dieser Studie, die nach nichts gehört.
Ja, ist ja klar. Die wird auf Android-Foren natürlich nicht verbreitet. Naja, gut, ich mag das. Ich kann das gerne raussuchen.
Ich denke, viele Leute wissen gar nicht, dass sie ein Android-Telefon haben. Also das interessiert die auch, glaube ich, gar nicht groß. Die kaufen halt so ein Ding auch nach Features. Und es gibt halt relativ wenig Firmen im Markt, die wirklich eine starke Marke haben. Ich würde sagen, eigentlich reduziert sich das derzeit nur noch auf Samsung und Sony. Sony, eine starke Marke im Telefonbereich. Also sie haben eine starke Marke, aber nicht unbedingt im Telefonbereich. Wieso gibt es überhaupt Telefone von Sony? Wann habt ihr das letzte Mal eins gesehen?
Auf Plakaten.
Nee, ich meine, in echt.
Tatsächlich letzte Woche. Hatte jemand ein kleines Sony Android-Telefon mit einer hohen Auflösung und hat damit gespielt und Ingress gespielt. Und er meinte, das hätte halt so eine hohe Auflösung, das wäre total praktisch. Und dann Xperia heißt die Reihe da. Also die gibt's.
Ja, aber dass die jetzt eine starke Marke in diesem Telefonmarkt ist, würde ich jetzt gerade nicht...
Ich kaufe eh nur Nexus-Geräte. Also ich kenne keine anderen Marken, ich kaufe die nicht.
Ich versuche ja auch hier nur so ein bisschen aus dem Kaffeesatz zu lesen. Was steht noch drin im Kaffeesatz? Ah ja, genau, die andere interessante Zahl ist, sie haben nicht ganz 4 Millionen Macs verkauft. Und vor allem, ja, haben sie 4 Millionen Macs verkauft.
Alles stabil, mobil und fest.
Das schließt alle Macs ein. iMac, Mac Pro, wenig.
Dass es nicht gestiegen ist, wundert mich ein bisschen, weil sonst ja alle immer mehr iOS-Geräte kaufen und das alles so ein bisschen kennen und Apple-User werden irgendwie, denkt man sich, naja, vielleicht kaufen sie sich ja auch einen Mac, wegen iTunes, Syncing und hast du nicht gesehen, ist aber anscheinend nicht so richtig der Fall. Also ich hätte gedacht, dass es mehr so einen Nachzieheffekt hat.
Hat es vielleicht auch, aber man muss bedenken, wie gesagt, sie haben 19,5 Millionen iPads verkauft, 4 Millionen Macs. Letztes Jahr 11,8 Millionen iPads, 4 Millionen Macs. Das heißt, sie haben unglaublich viel mehr iPads noch verkauft und es ist klar, dass es eine Zielgruppe gibt, die nicht klein ist, für die ein iPad auch eine Alternative darstellt. Würde es keine iPads geben, also vor ein paar Jahren, als es noch keine iPads gab, haben sich diese Leute für diesen ich brauche da was fürs Internet, wo ich einen Webbrowser drauf habe und wo ich irgendwie meinen Facebook machen kann und bla bla bla, haben die sich halt so einen Computer gekauft und die haben sich dann vielleicht auch ein Mac gekauft. Und diese Gruppe entfällt. Trotzdem haben sie es geschafft, stabil zu bleiben. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht irgendwie gutreden, sondern...
Und der restliche Markt ist auch gerade am Zusammenbrechen eigentlich, oder? Also PC-Markt geht ja zurück, oder?
Genau, und das ist nämlich der Punkt. Der PC-Markt schrumpft so und der Mac-Markt bleibt stabil. Zumindest jetzt, wenn man die Zahl nicht überinterpretiert. Ich glaube, die Unterschiede sind gering, also sind wesentlich 3,9 irgendwas. Also die Macs halten sich eigentlich ganz gut. Aber es steigt halt auch nicht mehr an, zumindest nicht in diesem Quartal. Bitte? Ah, da hat es jemand nachgeschlagen. Mobamex 3.
Ach krass.
Vor fünf Jahren.
Ich habe das jetzt nicht so schnell gefunden. 52 Minuten 50 Sekunden. Das ist nicht einmal... Vielen Dank, Max Schneider, du hast einen gut.
Gab es damals Show Notes?
Ja, es sind tatsächlich...
Aber Q-Dom schreibt man ohne H, oder?
Ich habe ein paar Leute für die alten Max Sendungen tatsächlich Show Notes gemacht. Ich hoffe, das können wir noch hin. Ja, Q-Dom schreibt sich immer noch ohne H. Weil es hat ja nichts mit Kühen, sondern mit Kurfürsten zu tun.
Also ich habe mir im letzten Quartal auch keinen neuen Mac gekauft.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich bin ja immer noch schwer enttäuscht von der aktuellen Produktpalette.
Wirklich?
Ja, kein Ethernet, glossy screen. Das kickt mich nicht.
Tippe hier auf Hardware von 2010. Ist geil, wie weit wir gekommen sind, dass wir jetzt schon stolz drauf sind, dass wir alle den Schmack hoch haben bei Apple. Aber das kann man sich ja mal überlegen, wo das herkommt.
Na ja, vielleicht sind ihre Produkte auch so gut gewesen, dass sie jetzt einfach mal extrem lange halten.
Das war ja schon immer so eigentlich.
Also alle meine Macs laufen noch, sogar mein allererster.
Ich tippe hier auf mit 2011 und mein Mac Pro ist ja 2009 sogar.
Oder 2008?
Wo ist überhaupt der neue Mac Pro? Kommt der zu WWDC?
Wann ist die WWDC denn?
Wann ist die WWDC?
Die ist jetzt auf jeden Fall ausverkauft. In wie vielen Minuten gewesen?
Angeblich 2 Minuten.
Das ist schon ein bisschen frech, oder? So, WWDC ist vom 10. bis 14.
Juni.
Das heißt, es könnte durchaus bedeuten, dass wir jetzt noch 6 Wochen warten müssen. Ich würde sagen, es spricht dafür. Ich wäre nicht überrascht, wenn sie, was auch immer ihr Nachfolger für den Mac Pro ist, da veröffentlichen. Weil es wahrscheinlich relativ wenig Sinn macht, für sie dafür einen eigenen Event zu machen, weil da ist die Zielgruppe einfach zu klein. So etwas machen sie noch nicht mal mehr für den iMac. Und da sind natürlich eine Menge Leute, die an diesem Produkt echt Interesse haben, weil Developer stehen auf dem Mac Pro. Also vielleicht stehen nicht alle Developer auf dem Mac Pro, aber ich kenne eine Menge Developer, die nicht genug Kurs und nicht genug Performance und nicht genug Plattenoptionen und nicht genug alles Mögliche haben. Und da geht es einfach nur darum, wie schnell das Xcode durch meinen Code durchgeht. So, und es geht dann einfach auf dem Mac Pro halt doppelt so schnell oder viermal so schnell oder achtmal so schnell. Und das sind die entscheidenden Zahlen.
Also alle Entwickler, die ich kenne, benutzen einen Macbook.
Ja, also ich kenne tatsächlich auch, also alle Leute, die ich kenne, also ich kenne einen einzigen, der einen Mac Pro benutzt. Und das auch nur, weil irgendwie war gerade da und nichts anderes und...
Okay, also mir ist es klar, dass ein Macbook Pro auch sehr populär ist bei Developern. Aber wenn jemand sozusagen was damit anfangen kann, mit einem Mac Pro, dann sind es halt Hardcore-Grafiker, Sound-Ingenieure und Developer. Ja, und Video, genau. Also halt alles, was irgendwie wirklich...
Leute, die ehrenkopfhörer aufhaben, die es nicht stört, dass du dir in ihren Füßen rauscht und ihnen die Beine wärmt.
Die Schuhe föhnt, danke. Ja, das ist jetzt nicht so schlecht. Ja, ich meine, man muss ja auch sagen, vielleicht ist auch dieses Unexcitement jetzt mit Apple einfach deswegen so, weil wirklich wir uns einfach zufrieden sind. Wir sind satt.
Ich bin nicht zufrieden. Ich bin nie zufrieden.
Aber...
Ja, es fehlt noch ein SIM-Karten-Slot. Definitiv.
Im Mac Pro?
Ja, im Mac Pro eigentlich auch.
Das beklagen wir ja auch schon seit Jahren.
Aber ich muss sagen, dieses Gerät habe ich jetzt, seit ich da bei VUGA angefangen habe. Das ist jetzt auch schon eine ganze Weile her. Und es reicht. Also ich habe überhaupt gar keinen... Ich bräuchte eine größere SSD, aber ansonsten reicht es eigentlich auch. Also, mich durstet es gar nicht. Ich bin gar nicht so, oh ja, was will ich denn jetzt eigentlich noch? Also, okay, Retina-Display würde ich jetzt nehmen, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so ein Must-Have-Feature.
Das ist schon interessant, die Kisten sind für die allermeisten Tasks an einem Performance-Punkt angekommen, wo man irgendwie gar nicht mehr nach mehr schreit.
Also jetzt, genau, also eigentlich, das Einzige, wenn ich merke, dass die Kiste zu langsam ist, wenn ich wirklich mal hier so ein Full-HD-Video von meinem iPhone irgendwie mit iMovie runterziehe und dann mal irgendwas damit machen will, dann merke ich, okay, HD-Video, okay, braucht so seine Zeit. Aber wenn jetzt, also ich meine, das Audio, was ich jetzt hier mache, gut, da könnte man auch noch ein bisschen was, aber das sind schon echt High-End. Also das so 99% der Leute brauchen das nicht. Und für 99% der Tastig mit dem Gerätmacher brauche ich es auch nicht. Deswegen, ich bin überhaupt so total, also mich, dieses neue MacBook Pro Retina-Display.
Wie auch immer, ich wage jetzt einfach mal so die Aussage, wir sehen neue Mac Pro Hardware oder was auch immer der Nachfolger des Mac Pro ist. Was auch immer das ist, was er meinte, was uns total glücklich macht, die wir Mac Pros toll finden.
Wann hat er gesagt, dass wir das mal...
Next Year, irgendwie, aber war nicht von First Half, ich weiß nicht, so richtig aus dem... Ja, so in 2013. Außerdem hat er auf dieser komischen Konferenz, wir nennen die das immer, wenn sie ihre Quartalszahlen bekannt geben. Da gibt es immer diese Fragestunde. Und da haben sie dann, meinte Tim Cook, sie hätten ja wieder tolle Produkte in der Pipeline, die sie dann im Herbst und im nächsten Jahr, throughout next year oder so ähnlich war die Formulierung, releasen würden. Mit anderen Worten. Sie widerspricht in gewisser Hinsicht meiner These an der Stelle, wobei ich mir durchaus vorstellen kann, dass sie davon dann auch abweichen. Das ist glaube ich auch der Versuch, so ein bisschen die Luft rauszunehmen. Aus diesem ganzen Erwartungs-Klimbim. Ich habe aber auch so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass der Laden gerade Luft holt. Und zwar ganz enorm. Und das ist ja auch diese, vielleicht kann ja unser neuer Finanzexperte uns das mal auch erklären, was sie da irgendwie machen. Sie verdienen ja immer noch awesomäßig viel Geld.
Sie haben so gefühlt, gefühlt.
Das war jetzt ein Fachausdruck.
145 Milliarden.
145 Milliarden Cash, wobei dieser Cash weltweit verteilt ist und vor allem deshalb auch als Cash vorliegt, weil wenn sie das nach in die USA reinholen würden.
Da müssten sie 35 Prozent Steuern zahlen.
Genau und Steuernzahlen ist ja bäh.
Also 100 Milliarden haben sie außer 45 Milliarden haben sie wohl zu Hause.
Trotzdem haben sie dann aber ihren Aktionären versprochen, dass sie jetzt über die nächsten Jahre 100 Milliarden US-Dollar ausschütten wollen.
In Form von Dividende oder Aktienrückkauf, was beides den Aktienkurs antreibt.
Ja und darum geht's. Ich versuch das wirklich zu verstehen.
Die Dividende ist 2 Dollar 95 oder irgendwie so pro Aktie. Es war 2,65 und sie hat jetzt um 15 Prozent.
Okay, ich hab keine, aber.
Und das ist immer pro Quartal.
Ja, das ist ja schön. Wenn man ganz viele Aktien hat, kriegt man sozusagen einfach so Geld überwiesen.
So sieht's aus.
Und sie sagen entweder Dividende, ist das so und oder oder oder wie? Und sie wollen auch noch Aktien zurückkaufen. So, aber warum? Warum?
Also der Grund ist, weil dadurch indirekt der Aktienkurs steigt. Natürlich, wenn eine Aktie die Dividende ausschüttet und 100 Dollar wert ist, also ein Kurs von 100 Dollar ist natürlich mehr wert als eine Aktie, die 100 Dollar wert ist, ohne dass sie Dividende ausschüttet, weil du halt die Dividende kriegst, ist ja klar. Deswegen wird die interessant und deswegen steigt der Preis jetzt der Apple-Aktie, weil sich die Dividende erhöht hat. Gleichzeitig, wenn Apple natürlich auf dem Markt irgendwie die eigenen Aktien wieder einkauft und damit den Anteil der Aktien senkt, sehen wir bei Bitcoins gerade was passiert, wenn alle irgendwie Aktien oder Bitcoins kaufen, dann steigt der Preis und so durch den Aktienrückkauf von Apple steigt der Preis der Apple-Aktien auch.
Ja, warum ist es für sie so wichtig, dass der Preis steigt?
Also genau weiß ich es nicht. Also entweder ist es nur so ein psychologisches Ding oder einfach weil sie wirklich wollen, dass der Preis, dass der Apple-Preis gut ist. Also Tim Cook muss es ja schon deswegen wollen, weil er kriegt selber eine ganze Menge, war ja so. Ganz viele andere Leute, die bei Apple arbeiten auch. Also ich meine, die machen das. Die Aktionäre wird nicht machen, das ist ja deren Job. Sonst haben sie auch Ärger auf so eine Aktionärsversammlung und dann sagen die Aktionäre hört mal zu, ey wir wählen dich ja ab, wenn wir nicht langsam mal ein bisschen Kohle reinkriegen, weil am Ende gehört Apple ja nicht sich selbst, sondern den Aktionären.
Ja gut, aber sie haben 15 Jahre lang keine Dividende ausgeschüttet und Steve Jobs hat immer gesagt, Scheiß auf euch, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ja, Steve Jobs hat auch regiert mit eiserner Faust und da hat sich keiner getraut. Meinst du, der Einhorn hätte das gemacht mit einem Steve Jobs an der Führung? Nee.
Einhorn?
Der David Einhorn, der hat doch mal rumgeklagt, dass er meinte, ihr müsst mal ein bisschen mehr Geld ausschütten, er hätte gerne Aktien mit, mit, mit irgendwie, mit irgendwelche Special-Aktien für die Hauptaktionäre, wollte da irgendwie so ein Deal haben, der wurde dann auch irgendwie abgeschmettert. Der hat doch vor Gericht durchgesetzt, dass da irgendein Voter irgendwie nicht gemacht werden kann oder irgendwie so. Da war doch so eine Geschichte vor sechs Wochen oder acht.
Hab ich bestenfalls am Rande mitbekommen.
Ja, da hat irgend so ein hoher Hedgemanager wieder rumgeklagt und hat auch Recht bekommen.
Da im Chat schon wieder diese alte Mehr von Apple gehört Microsoft durch die Weltgeschichte Tapas.
Die ist süß, ne?
Ja, das ist echt unglaublich.
Aber es war noch so.
Microsoft hat mal für 150.000 Dollar Vorzugsverfahren.
Nee, nicht 150.000 Dollar.
150.000 Dollar, dann würden wir jetzt Apple geharrt.
150.000.000 Vorzugsaktien gekauft. Vorzugsaktien sind nicht stimmberechtigt und ich glaube, die haben sie auch nicht mehr. So, aber jetzt hat Apple auch nochmal, um das letzte Argument nochmal aufzugreifen, also ihr Interesse daran, dass der Aktienkurs steigt. Jetzt fällt mir nämlich auch gerade ein Grund ein, ist, dass sie ja vielen Mitarbeitern auch Aktienoptionen, das sozusagen auch ihr Akquise- und Personalsystem ja darauf basiert, dass es da eine Wertsteigerung gibt und sie dadurch natürlich den Incentive für ihre Mitarbeiter auch bei Apple zu bleiben auch aufrechterhalten.
Wer weiß auch, um die ganzen AMD-Jungs gegangen sind.
Ja, aber das wäre zumindest jetzt mal eine Motivation, weil ich habe mich gefragt, was kann ihre Motivation sein? Insbesondere vor dem Fakt, dass sie jetzt auch noch 17 Milliarden US-Dollar als Anleihe haben.
Sie haben so einen Firmbond ausgegeben. Genau, das ist eine Anleihe. Das geht, glaube ich, zwischen 32 Jahren. Die haben da so verschiedene Chargen irgendwie, insgesamt jedenfalls 17 Milliarden Dollar. Und die kriegen da Zinsen von 1,8 bis 2,4 Prozent, also total wenig. Aber es ist deswegen, weil Apple irgendwie die Chance, dass sie die Kredite zurückzahlen ist, so zu 99,99 Prozent, da gibt es diese Moody-Ratings und Visa-Lifes, A plus und AAA und hast du nicht gesehen, Apple ist da ganz oben.
Es gibt sozusagen AAA und Apple.
Nee, nee, Apple ist ein bisschen unter dem ganz besten, weil sie halt im Techniksektor sind und da ist sozusagen, wenn so ein Produkt zusammenbricht, dann geht es denen scheiße auf. Microsoft hat wirklich den AAA, weil die machen halt Software, da kann nicht so viel, die haben halt keine Kosten und so. Und die brauchen nur den Copy-Batten nicht mehr drücken.
Aber warum holt sich jetzt eine Firma, die 145 Milliarden Cash hat?
Na, weil das Geld, das wir schon hatten, was da im Ausland liegt, offshore oder wie auch man das nennt, wenn sie das zurückholen würden nach Amiland zum Auszahlen, dann müssten sie halt erstmal Steuern draufzahlen und so zahlen sie nur 1,8 bis 2,4% Zinsen, ist halt viel billiger.
Ja, aber warum geben sie dann so viele Dividende raus, wenn sie die Kohle nicht haben irgendwie?
Na, damit sie die Aktionäre happy machen.
Ja, aber die würden doch jetzt, warum müssen sie so horrend? Ich meine, 100 Milliarden US-List, damit kannst du ja Griechenland irgendwie...
Ne, ein Drittel oder so haben sie geschrieben.
Na gut, ein kleineres europäisches Land kannst du damit schon shoppen. Falls du mal ein Land brauchst.
Ja, die haben sich wahrscheinlich auch überlegt, was soll man mit dem Scheiß?
Ja, das wird auch mal eine Idee, vielleicht so was wie iCountry. Einfach so, weißt du, Disney Park? So wird es mal in groß gedacht. Genau, so iCountry. Das weiß ich ja, irgendein Land, was sowieso schon vor die Hunde kommt und wo man irgendwie mal wirklich am Design auch was verbessern könnte. Holland zum Beispiel. Holland hat einen scheiß Visor.
Und schon wieder Hörer verloren.
Oder? Na mal ehrlich, die Städte sind auch langweilig. Bis auf Amsterdam vielleicht.
Ist nicht in allen großen Ländern so, bis eine Stadt ist der Rest langweilig?
Warst du mal in dem Land, habt ihr da einen Pass aufgestellt aus dem Land?
Jaja, es ist nicht alles so square. Das ist auch nicht so klein.
Das können sie glaube ich nicht kaufen.
Britannien kriegen sie nicht gekauft. Also Holland müsste da eigentlich drin sein.
Oder Belgien.
Luxemburg. Kaufen sie zwei davon.
Luxemburg kaufen wäre gut.
Aril und Danz.
Das ist ja auch iTunes sowieso schon zu Hause.
Gibt es Lichtenstein gratis dazu. Für zwei Luxemburgs gibt es Lichtenstein gratis dazu.
Ich glaube Lichtenstein ist ein bisschen teuer.
Aber man kann auf jeden Fall sehen, dass wenn man sich jetzt den aktuellen Apfelkurs anguckt, kann man schon sehen, dass schon die Ankündig davon und auch die Umsetzung, die dann heute in den News irgendwie so rumging, dass sie sich schon bemerkbar gemacht hat im Kurs. Weil der war ja schon bis unter 300 Euro runtergefallen und inzwischen ist er wieder aktuell hier zum Tagesschlusskurs hier 337,97, also 338 Euro. Also ist schon wieder reichlich, reichlich gestiegen und allein deshalb.
Gut, wegen deshalb.
Wobei man nie so genau sagen kann, weswegen der Kurs steigt, genauso wenig, wie man sagen kann, warum er fällt, weil dazu gab es ehrlich gesagt, ich meine, es gibt eh keinen Grund, warum die Aktie fällt. Also im Sinne von Vertrauen in die Marke und so weiter, ich meine, alles, was so gesagt wird, da fasse ich mir einen Kopf. Die große Neuigkeit bringen und so.
Die Vorstellung der Masse, was das halt wert ist oder wert werden sein wird. Und jeder hat auch noch eine andere Sichtweite an die Länge der Zukunft. Manche denken ein Jahr voraus, manche fünf. Also ich glaube, das ist ein Thema für sich.
Wie WDC, keiner von uns geht hin und alle anderen auch nicht, weil...
War so schnell auserkauft, dass man gar nicht gucken konnte.
Sie sind auch immer noch in Moskroni, mit 5000 Plätzen, genau wie Google auch. Die wollen da nicht raus und 5000 Plätze sind schnell weg.
Ja, aber haben die das gleiche Problem wie der Kongress? Finden nix mehr.
Nee, die könnten sogar innerhalb von Moskroni sich noch vergrößern. Das ist nicht so, dass da jetzt keine Flächen gibt.
Aber den gehen ja auch irgendwann die Developers aus, die das da ganze managen, oder?
Ja, sie haben da schon ihre Einschätzung, wie viele Leute sie handeln können und das ist die Zahl, die sie handeln wollen und mehr Tickets gibt es halt nicht.
Ja, ich denke mal, vielleicht werden sie doch mal irgendwie Livestreaming einschalten oder irgendwie ihre Videos. Haben wir gesagt, dass sie schon während der Veranstaltung die Videos publishen wollen. Das war bisher, glaube ich, auch nicht der Fall, oder? Die kamen mal kurz danach. Es wurde mal schneller, aber noch nicht.
Letztes Mal war es, glaube ich, die Woche danach oder so.
Ja, soll es jetzt währenddessen schon passieren. Also sie werden das Ding einfach zur digitalen Konferenz machen und dann ist alles schick. Dann muss man da nicht irgendwie durch einen Nacktscanner latschen und wer will denn das. Max war aber da.
Ich war auch noch auf keiner IEO und werde auch diesmal nicht hinkommen, weil ich auch wieder kein Ticket bekommen habe. Na ich war dreimal auf dem Bezahlscreen. Also es hat länger gedauert, weil es so lief, du bist dann auf dem Bezahlscreen, du wirst dann mit Kreditkarte bezahlen und dann wird es nicht akzeptiert oder es wird akzeptiert und wenn es nicht akzeptiert wird, geht dein Ticket wieder in den Pool. Hatten wir beim Kongress so ähnlich, nur ein bisschen verzögerte. Und deshalb war erst nach einer Stunde oder so klar, dass es wirklich kein Ticket mehr gibt, weil dann immer wieder die zurückgeflossenen Tickets tatsächlich auch irgendwann bezahlt werden konnten. Und ich hatte dreimal den Bezahlscreen und dreimal mit drei verschiedenen Kreditkarten hat dieser Server es nicht geschafft, meine Zahlung entgegenzunehmen. Aber ich hätte den Bezahlscreen wahrscheinlich auch nie gekriegt, wenn es bei den anderen nicht genauso gewesen wäre. Also die anderen hatten auch den Bezahlscreen, haben es auch nicht geschafft zu bezahlen, weil der Bezahlserver das irgendwie nicht haben wollte, das Geld. Und deshalb habe ich auch überhaupt nur einen, vermute ich, also ich hätte sonst auch kein Ticket bekommen, wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber Apple scheint das ja im Griff zu haben, nach zwei Minuten alle Tag Tickets zu verkaufen.
Ja, also das mit dem Bestellen und dem Bezahlen, das... Nö, das können sie ja irgendwie, das machen sie täglich Milliardenmal, also das ist... oder Millionenmal auf jeden Fall, ich weiß nicht, was verkaufen die jetzt so pro Tag irgendwie an iTunes-Ware?
Na ich meine, Google betreibt auch den Play Store, aber irgendwie, ich meine, naja, egal. Ich bin ein bisschen frustriert. Die ist ein Monat vorher, also jetzt in zwei Wochen und in Berlin wird es in der Seabase die IO. Extended geben und da können, ich sag jetzt mal, alle hinkommen, die die Streams in der Seabase mit anderen...
Das heißt, die wird live gestreamt?
Ja genau. Da werden fast, also fast alle Sessions, letztes Jahr war es so, die ersten zwei Tage komplett, der dritte Tag gar nicht. Und es gab aber auch eine Session, die hätte ich gerne gesehen, aber da gab es dann auch nicht mal eine Aufzeichnung von... Aber das war halt so ein Lab, oder wie das dann heißt. Aber das ist schon ganz gut, wobei, also vorletztes Jahr war es ein Problem mit dem Streaming, da hatten wir auch eine Seabase, da hieß es noch nicht IO. Extended, aber... Ja, da hat YouTube nicht senden wollen nach Berlin oder nach Deutschland und dann mussten wir uns Leola Portz Gequatsche anhören, weil dessen Stream konnten wir gucken, aber der hat halt darüber geredet die ganze Zeit. Und dann haben wir sozusagen letztes Jahr ordentlich Druck gemacht und Google war das wahrscheinlich auch bekannt, dass es nicht in Ordnung ist, dass sie nicht nach Deutschland senden und ich glaube dann gab es auch schon spezielle Adressen, von denen wir uns dann den Stream abholen konnten oder unsere Adresse war freigeschaltet oder was auch immer. Also es hat letztes Jahr funktioniert und ich hoffe es wird auch dieses Jahr funktionieren. Mitte Mai ist es.
Mitte Mai?
Ja, drei Tage, 15. bis 17.
So Mädels, mir gehen die Themen aus hier.
Ja, ich habe noch ein ganz großes Thema. Ich habe ja schon ein Notizen.
Bitcoins haben wir noch, müssen wir noch mal kurz. Warum eigentlich?
Was hast du denn für ein Thema, Dirk?
Na Ingress. Das hattet ihr ja vor zwei Sendungen und da habt ihr nicht so viel sagen können. Jetzt könnt ihr immer noch nicht so viel sagen, aber ihr könnt Fragen stellen und ich habe mir meine Liste gemacht.
Ich habe einen Kollegen, der daunt immer drauf starrt und ich habe versucht, ihn zu fragen, aber er konnte es mir nicht sagen, weil dann war er immer schon wieder weg. Also es scheint sehr irgendwie sehr...
Es ist sehr einnehmend. Ja, absolut. Also ich mache...
Kennst du dieses Spiel Shadow Cities, was das ist? Ja, das ist das gleiche.
Also fang mal von vorne an, tue mal so, als wären wir blöd. Was ist denn Dampfmaschinen?
Nein, ich wollte nicht so tun.
Unwissend. Also Ingress ist ein Spiel...
Eine Database, nein.
Ja, war mal eine Datenbank. Also es geht darum, also die Backstory, die kenne ich zwar, aber die ist irgendwie uninteressant, aber kurz mal zur Einführung. Okay, die Aliens sind auf der Erde gelandet und...
Wir werden alle sterben.
Und haben ein paar Menschen davon überzeugt, dass sie die guten Aliens sind und andere, das sind die Enlightened, also es ist die eine Fraktion, und die andere Fraktion ist die Resistance, das sind die, die davon überzeugt sind, dass die Aliens nicht die guten sind. Und es gibt auf der Welt überall so Punkte, Portale nennen sich die, die können kontrolliert werden von der einen oder der anderen Fraktion, nämlich von den Erleuchteten oder auch, wie sie genannt werden, von den Verblendeten, oder der Resistance. Und so, Portale haben wir.
Wir reden von einem Spiel, ja?
Ja, ja, es ist ein Spiel. Also, okay, also du hast ein Spiel auf deinem Android-Telefon und da siehst du dann die Portale in deiner Umgebung. Also es sind so Points of Interest. Zum Beispiel hat...
Was ist ein Portal?
Genau, zum Beispiel habe ich gelernt, das ist eine Martin-Luther-Statue, auf dem Alexander Platz gibt. Neben der Kirche, die da steht, ist eine Martin-Luther-Statue und diese Martin-Luther-Statue, das ist immer mein Paradebeispiel, weil ich die vorher nicht kannte, die ist ein Portal auf deinem Telefon und solange es uncaptured ist, ist es grau und wenn dann die Grünen kommen und da ein Resonator, jetzt sind wir schon beim nächsten Fachbegriff, einen Resonator reinstellen, davon können acht drinstehen, dann ist es ein grünes Portal, also gehört denen inleitend.
In diese Statue stellt man die Grünen.
Ja, man stellt es auf ein Telefon.
Aber was haben denn die Grünen mit dem?
Es gibt halt Grün und Blau. Grün und Blau. Also die Resonatoren, das ist alles nur, du hast dein Telefon oder hast du eine Scanner-Applikation, die heißt Scanner-App und in dieser App siehst du die Portale, in der Wirklichkeit siehst du sie nicht. Die sind nur in deinem Telefon vorhanden.
Google Glass sehe ich sie auch.
Vielleicht irgendwann mal, es gibt im Moment nur ein klein für Android. Soweit ich weiß, gibt es keinen für Google Glass. So, also so ein Portal wird kontrolliert von Resonatoren, davon kann man acht Stück reinstellen, die gehen in die Himmelsrichtung Norden, Süd, Nord, Ost.
In die Acht Himmelsrichtungen.
Ja, in die Acht Himmelsrichtungen, genau. Und es kann immer nur eine Sorte drin stehen und die kann man kaputt machen. Dafür gibt es Waffen, Börster. Mit den Börstern kann man die Resonatoren des Gegners kaputt machen. Wenn alle Resonatoren weg sind, alle acht, dann ist es wieder grau und dann kann man seine eigenen Resonatoren reinstellen.
Ich hab nochmal langsam. Also die Aliens sind gelandet und die sind jetzt die Guten oder die Bösen?
Das weiß keiner.
Die sind entweder gut oder böse.
Die sind gelandet.
Die Story da, damit es zwei Fraktionen gibt.
Genau, es gibt halt zwei Fraktionen.
Es gibt die Leute, die glauben, dass die Aliens die Guten sind. Und es gibt Leute, die sagen, welche Farbe ist jetzt welche.
Ist auch alles egal, es gibt Grüne und Blau.
Grün sind die Aliens.
Das kann ich egal.
Aliens oder Horde. Scheißegal.
Okay, die Blauen glauben, dass die Aliens doof sind.
Das ist Aliens.
Genau, das sind die Blauen, die glauben, dass sie gut sind.
Das passt ja alles zu den Grünen.
Ob das jetzt zu den Grünen passt, weiß ich nicht. Aber so ist es in dem Spiel.
Wer leuchtet uns?
Grün und Blau. Und jetzt gibt es noch ein paar, ich gebe mir das Gloss-H durch.
Er möchte nicht glauben, er hieß ein Non-Believer.
Dann bist du bei der Resistance richtig. Ich bin auch Resistance, weil, weiß ich nicht.
Wie will man denn das, ob man das eine oder das andere ist?
Am Anfang, wenn du die App installierst und deinen Activation-Code eingibst, danach wählst du die Fraktion.
Da weiß man noch überhaupt nicht, was Sache ist, aber man muss sich sofort für eine Glaubensrichtung entscheiden.
Das ist wie früher, wo es noch keine Pandamönche gab.
Naja, ich meine, dir gibt jemand ja den Activation-Code und der sagt dir schon, welche Fraktion du wählen sollst, weil du dann mit ihm spielen kannst. Oder er sagt dir, welche du nicht wählen sollst, wenn du nicht mit ihm spielen willst. Weil man spielt mit der gleichen Fraktion, spielt man auch zusammen. Und irgendwann, ab einem gewissen Level, muss man auch zusammen spielen.
Und spielen heißt, ich muss irgendwie rumlatschen, Portale suchen und da Resonatoren reinstellen?
Oder Resonatoren kaputt machen. Und die dritte Sache, die du mit einem Portal machen kannst, das heißt hacken, macht aber keinen Sinn. In der API heißt es auch Collect Items. Also man hackt das Portal und kriegt dann Items von dem Portal. Also entweder Waffen, also Börster, Resonatoren, oder Schlüssel, dazu kommen wir gleich noch, oder Power Cubes, oder... Achso, genau, eine Sache hab ich noch vergessen. Exotic Matter. Exotic Matter ist sozusagen die Energie in Ingress. Und das Exotic Matter liegt überall in der Welt rum. Auf der Scanner-App kann man es auch sehen. Da muss man dahin laufen und kann die Energie aufnehmen. Wenn man keine Energie mehr hat, dann kann man nicht mehr viel machen in dem Spiel. Also man kann nicht sterben, aber man muss dann erstmal eine Weile rumlaufen und wieder Exotic Matter aufnehmen. Genau, Portale kann man verlinken. Man kann also eine Strecke zwischen zwei Portalen, wenn sie die gleiche Farbe haben. So willst du nochmal den Sinn wissen, oder was?
Im Prinzip ist es Capture the City, Cogmented Reality.
Wenn ich bei Feldern bin. Du musst jetzt noch ein bisschen zuhören, dann kommt der Sinn. Also links zwischen zwei Portalen kann man links machen und wenn man drei Portale miteinander verbunden hat direkt, also sozusagen drei Links hat zwischen den drei Portalen, dann entsteht darin ein Dreieck, ein Feld, das heißt Control Field. Dieses Control Field überspannt eine gewisse Fläche. Die Fläche bedeutet...
Da werden das Jogsortorts gefangen.
Nicht ganz, Mind Units. Mind Units, das ist die Einheit...
Ist doch klar, Tim.
Das ist die Einheit, in der sozusagen der Global Score gemessen wird. Also die Fraktion... Also nehmen wir mal an, du kriegst... Also für ganz Berlin zum Beispiel, es gab mal ein Feld, das war ein grünes Feld über ganz Berlin, das waren 880.000 Mind Units. Das korreliert so ein bisschen mit der Anzahl der Einwohner. Nein, nicht wirklich, aber je größer das Feld, desto mehr Mind Units und Mind Units sind die... Also diese Felder sorgen dafür, dass die Leute, die darunter leben, kontrolliert werden. Das ist jetzt wieder die Backstory. Also das ist das, worum es eigentlich geht. Aber der Global Score ist eh immer falsch. Also der war schon auf 0 und auf 100 und auf X Prozent. Also den Global Score, da achtet eh keiner drauf. Aber du hast halt in deiner Nachbarschaft Portale. Und die willst du natürlich, dass die in deiner Lieblingsfarbe sind. Nämlich in der Farbe deiner Fraktion. Und deshalb gehst du nachts um zwei aus dem Haus. Nein, das ist halt ein Spiel. Deshalb gehst du nachts um zwei aus dem Haus, um die Portale wieder blau zu machen.
Und danach kommt wieder jemand und macht sie einfach wieder grün?
Wenn der vorbeikommt und deine Resonatoren kaputt machen kann, ja.
Kann man so hüpfen wie bei Shadow Cities?
Nein, das ist nicht drin. Du musst wirklich hingehen oder mit dem Fahrrad. Also ich spiele mit Fahrrad.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Aber kann man das Teil bestimmt auch bescheißen?
Man kann bestimmt auch bescheißen, aber das ist ja Schummeln und das macht keiner. Jetzt nochmal kurz, was Schummeln ist. Das ist nämlich klar definiert von Google. Schummeln ist, das GPS zu faken, also sozusagen eine andere Position vorzugeben, an der man wirklich ist.
Ja, und der andere total schwierig ist, muss man dazu sagen.
Und doppelte Accounts zu verwenden, also du darfst nicht zwei Accounts verwenden. Und drittens keine In-App-Items handeln gegen echtes Geld. Also du darfst natürlich tauschen, die Resonatoren und die Börster, aber... Was ich noch vergessen habe waren die Level. Also es gibt die Level 1 bis 8. Und je höher dein Börster ist, desto mehr Schaden macht er. Und desto weiter macht er auch den Schaden. Und je höher dein Level vom Resonator ist, desto schwerer ist es, kaputt zu kriegen. Also wenn du sozusagen viele High-Level-Spiele in deiner Umgebung hast, dann machen die alles blau. Nein, dann machen die alles in der Farbe, in der sie sind. Und dann ist es schwieriger für die andere Fraktion, das irgendwie wieder kaputt zu machen. So, das war jetzt mal der ganz grobe, ganz schnelle Umriss.
Das heißt, man rennt die ganze Zeit um, um irgendwas blau oder grün zu machen, damit jemand dann kurz danach kommt und es auch wieder blau oder grün macht. Das ist sozusagen das ganze Spiel.
Nee, nee, nicht damit der kommt, sondern leider kommt der.
Ja, aber faktisch ist das das, was passiert.
Ja, aber der Effekt ist, dass man erstens gut rumkommt in der Stadt.
Mehr Fahrrad fährt.
Genau, mehr Fahrrad fährt. Und, dass man auch Schleichwege kennenlernt. Weil man will dann zwischen den Portalen, es gibt auch noch so einen Begriff, der nennt sich Farming, das ist nicht offiziell, aber man macht die Portale so hoch, wie es geht in der Gruppe. So ein Achter-Portal kann man halt nur mit 8 Leuten vom Level 8 machen, weil der Durchschnitt der Resonatoren ergibt den Level des Portals. Und nur aus dem Achter-Portal kriegst du auch Achter-Items so für richtig raus. Also du kriegst auch einen Siemer-Portal, manchmal Achter-Items, aber eben eher aus einem Achter-Portal. Also läufst du mit 8 Leuten durch die Gegend, wie so eine Schildkrötenformation. Das sieht sehr lustig aus, wenn man das nicht kennt. Also wir haben schon oft mit Touristen Encounters gehabt, weil wir gucken halt alle auf unser Telefon die ganze Zeit, weil du nur auf dem Telefon siehst, was wirklich gerade abgeht.
Also auf einmal tauchen irgendwelche Leute um dich herum auf, die offen sich, die auch Ingress spielen, weil sie die ganze Zeit auf ihren Nexus starten.
Ja, man lernt Leute kennen, genau.
Wenn dich lernt, man mal Leute kennt, die auch Android benutzen.
Tatsächlich gibt es wohl einen Entwickler, der einen iOS-Klient schreibt, um unerkannt zu bleiben. Der will irgendwie mit seinem... Also es gibt keinen iOS-Klient bisher.
Ist das offen?
Das ist auch mal alles total offen. Das ist eine gute Frage. Also erstmal ist das die Firma nicht Google, die das entwickelt hat, sondern Niantic. Und Niantic gehört zwar Google, aber sie haben zum Beispiel keinerlei Zugriff auf die Google-Daten, sondern machen ihr eigenes Ding.
Innerhalb des Google-Universums hat nie irgendjemand Datenzugriff auf irgendwas.
Wie auch immer.
Sehr glaubwürdig.
Sie haben eine API. Sie behaupten, sie hätten keine API, aber sie haben natürlich eine API, weil der Client benutzt diese API. Sie haben also keine offiziell nutzbare API. Sie reden zwar die ganze Zeit davon, dass sie das haben wollen. Ich habe sie einfach mal vorausschauend betrachtet und mir die API mal genauer angeschaut und entwickle auch an einem eigenen Client. Und dann gibt es, also es gibt diesen Client und dann gibt es noch eine Übersicht im Web, die Intel-Map. Und für die Intel-Map gibt es halt so Modifikationen. Das nenne ich IITC, also Intel Ingress Total Conversion oder so ähnlich. Und da gab es einen Fall, dass der Entwickler oder einer der Entwickler bei Injantik nachgefragt hat, ja, guckt mal, was ich hier tolles gemacht habe mit euren Daten und mit eurer API, wie findet ihr denn das? Und dann haben sie ihm geschrieben, ja, finden wir Scheiße, macht das weg. Und das hat er dann auch gemacht.
Total gemein.
Und letztens gab es ein Gespräch mit einem Mitarbeiter von Injantik und da habe ich dann halt auch mal gefragt, also er hat gesagt, wir haben keine API, da habe ich ihm gesagt, doch ihr habt eine API, die dürfen wir bloß nicht benutzen, wie ist denn das? Und dann hat er gesagt, naja, wir gucken nicht danach, ob jemand die API benutzt. Aber wenn jemand zu uns kommt und fragt, ob er sie benutzen darf, dann sagen wir ihm, dass es eine Nutzungsbedingungsverletzung ist.
Es gibt keine API, aber die API ist unsere API.
Genau, und so ist der Stand der Dinge. Also es wird wahrscheinlich irgendwann eine API geben, eine offizielle, und bis dahin darf man halt nicht fragen bei Injantik, ob man die benutzen darf, die API, die da ist. So, das ist jetzt der, ist es offen? Nein, offiziell ist es nicht offen, aber das ist so leicht zu reversieren.
Und was macht daran jetzt so Spaß?
Ja, ist schwierig zu erklären.
Also ich hab bei diesem Shadow Cities eine Weile gespielt, und wenn ich dann auch nach Hause gefahren bin, noch mal schnell zum Nordbahnhof, hab da irgendwie einen platt gemacht, bin ich morgens aufgestanden, also was heißt morgens, die Sonne ging schon wieder unter, aber dann hab ich gesehen, hat der mich wieder platt gemacht und so, also es war so immer so ein dauerndes hin und her. Ich hatte auch eine Weile lang das Brandenburger Tor und was weiß ich nicht alles, potz da mal Platz und so, alles in meiner Ecke, aber es war halt auch schon ganz schön anstrengend. Dann fängt man auch an so Friedenspläde zu machen mit seinen Gegnern, damit, okay, du kriegst die drei, ich lass dich in Ruhe, dafür lässt du mir meine drei hier schön in Ruhe, aber irgendwann war es auch ein bisschen langweilig dann.
Also mir macht es noch Spaß. Ich glaube so zwei, drei Monate.
Okay, das ist ja doch schon ganz schön lange. Ich hab's glaube ich nur so zwei, drei Wochen ausgehalten oder vier, fünf.
Und man freut sich, also gerade gestern waren wir wieder farm in einem Engelbecken und da, also diese Resonatoren verlieren pro Tag 15 Prozent ihrer Energie, das heißt...
Man muss sie auffrischen.
Man muss sie auffrischen, genau. Und das war schon ein cooles Gefühl, dass meine Resonatoren da noch drin stecken, weil normalerweise ist das Engelbecken...
Was resonieren die eigentlich?
Die halten das Portal sozusagen zusammen.
Ja, aber wenn es Resonatoren sind, dann müssen sie ja irgendwas...
Ja, die heißen so. Wirklich die Backstory, da darfst du mich nichts sagen.
Das ist alles unwichtig, Mann.
Aber das kann man bestimmt irgendwo nachlesen.
Aber das ist sozusagen das Spiel, was die Berliner Hunde schon seit Generatoren spielen.
Berliner Hunde, achso ja, markieren.
An der Ecke gehen, mal eine Marke setzen.
Das ist das digitale Pissen, oder wie?
Digitales an die Wand pinkeln.
Wie immer, schön zusammengefasst.
Ich geh noch mal raus.
Ich muss noch mal meine...
Meine Revier markieren.
Mein Revier resonieren.
Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Ja, ich glaube, das...
Leider lädt dieses Nexus 7 hier immer noch. Wer kriegt eigentlich Inwalt? Also ich habe einen bekommen.
Achso, apropos Inwalt, ja.
Man braucht immer noch welche, ja?
Na ja, es gibt da mehrere Aspekte. Was ich gehört habe ist, wenn man selber sich anmeldet, muss man drei Wochen warten. Das scheint sich auch zu bestätigen. Also nach drei Wochen kriegt man dann seinen Inwalt. Andererseits haben gerade gestern, alle Level-2-Agenten heißen die, also alle Level-2-Agents haben einen Inwalt bekommen. Das heißt, es sind jetzt tatsächlich Inwalt vorhanden in der App. Und für Leute, die einen Inwalt wollen, habe ich auch welche mitgebracht. Mal gucken, wie viel Android-Hörer ihr habt.
Also ich hab 10.
Wir werden es gleich sehen. Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
Gleich haben wir noch mehr.
Ich würde sagen, ich hab mir überlegt... Die hab ich von Niantic.
So, so.
Ich soll sagen, dass ich sie von Niantic hab.
Du hast richtig viel.
Nee, das sind nur zehn, aber die zehn würde ich sozusagen so rausgeben, ohne dass ich sage, welche Fraktion die Leute nehmen sollen, weil ich die halt dafür gekriegt habe, dass ich die hier verteile.
Hättest du denn einen Vorteil davon, wenn Leute deiner Fraktion...
Natürlich.
Du musst nicht so viel raus.
Du musst nicht nach Bamberg fahren, um da irgendwie das Hoch voll rauszuverteilen.
Nee, natürlich hat man was davon. Insbesondere wenn man halt... Also ich hätte gerne Hörer, die auch wirklich spielen wollen.
Sind denn alle Nerds blau?
Nee, das ist interessanterweise so, dass der CCC in Berlin eher grün ist. Also eher entleitend. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt einen Namen nennen soll. Eher nicht. Und die C-Base ist eher blau. Tatsächlich.
Also sozusagen...
Nee, das ist wirklich interessant gerade. Also die Leute, die ich so von früher kenne...
Wie ist denn die Verteilung? Gibt es denn mehr Grüne als blau?
Na, es gibt... Ich weiß nicht, die letzten Statistiken kenne ich nicht, aber die, die vor ein paar Wochen aktuell waren, waren, dass es mehr entleitend Agenten gibt, aber die weniger aktiv sind, sodass es eine Resistance-Dominanz gab. Deshalb sind auch einige Leute, die ich kenne, dann zu entleitend gegangen, weil sie gesagt haben, Resistance ist mir zu einfach. Aber jetzt ist es wirklich schwer für beide Seiten. Also es ist meiner Meinung nach sehr gut ausgeglichen. Ich weiß nicht, die aktuellen Portal-Statistiken habe ich mir jetzt nicht angeguckt. Also wir hatten zum Beispiel in den Event am letzten Sonntag einen Link aus drei Segmenten von Berlin nach Genf zu legen. Und so ein Link kann maximal 655 Kilometer lang sein. Dazu braucht man aber auf der ausgehenden Seite einen Level-8-Portal. Das muss man erstmal halten. Ist klar.
Lass mich raten, weil eins und links ist 10 Meter und 65.536 mal 10 Meter sind 655 Kilometer.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, woher kommt denn sonst 655?
Du bist doch ein Nerd.
Gute Idee, aber das kommt von einer Ami-Firma.
Das ist einfach so.
Füße, Meilen, Sonne.
Okay, manche Amis haben auch das Licht gesehen.
Einen Fakt habe ich noch nicht erklärt. Links dürfen sich nicht kreuzen. Das heißt, um von hier nach Genf zu kommen, wollten wir erst über Ahlen gehen und dann über Stuttgart. Aber man muss halt erst mal aus der Stadt raus. Die Frösche haben natürlich versucht, immer Querlinks zu setzen. Das heißt, wir haben dann mit Teamspeak und allen möglichen Operators, da waren drei Leute, die haben... Ja, das ist eine richtige militärische Operation, kann man sagen, ohne echte Waffen natürlich. Also wir hatten drei Operators, die haben die Intel-Map beobachtet, haben gesehen, wo welche Links weg müssen, haben so ein Draw-Tool, mit dem sie eine Linie ziehen konnten. Von hier nach Ahlen. Ahlen haben wir nicht geschafft und Stuttgart haben wir dann letztlich auch nicht geschafft, weil dann in Leipzig noch Links aufgetaucht sind und die Leipziger waren dann nicht mehr bereit, noch mal dahin zu fahren und die wegzumachen. Also haben wir es nicht geschafft, aber es gab noch andere Städte, also Stuttgart, Milano, glaube ich. Es waren sieben Städte und in sechs der anderen Städte haben die Resistance es geschafft, diese Links zu legen. Und dann hatten die Antik gesagt, okay, dann geben wir mal ein paar Invite-Codes an die Entleitenden draus, damit die ein paar Agenten rekrutieren können. Aber diese Invite-Codes sind wohl nicht rausgegangen. Und als Belohnung gab es dann Power Cubes. Also Power Cubes sind sozusagen XM-Speicher, die man gut brauchen kann, weil XM war das Exotic Matter. Das ist die Energieeinheit. Also für euch ist eigentlich das einzige Problem, wenn ihr ein Telefon kriegt.
Und dass ich gar nicht die Zeit für sowas habe.
Okay, also die 10 Invites habe ich mir überlegt, die sollen mich einfach auf Twitter Menschen nennen und dann die ersten 10, die ankommen, kriegen einfach so eins. Und alle, die Resistence werden wollen...
Auf Twitter. Bist du eigentlich auch auf Abdeutnet?
Ich bin auch auf Abdeutnet, aber da weiß ich gar nicht, wie ich heiße. Da heiße ich auch Dirk Jäckel. Einfach zusammengeschrieben mit AE. Und die, die danach kommen, nach den 10 sozusagen, wenn sie Resistence werden wollen, dann finden wir eine Lösung. Also und wer entleitend werden will, kann ich auch gleich noch dazu sagen, der kriegt von mir dann zwar über die 10 hinaus keinen, aber es wird am 3. Mai, also am Freitag ein Event von Entleitend geben zur Rekrutierung und da kann man sich ja dann einfinden, wenn man entleitend werden will. Also in Berlin, Entschuldigung, das wird jetzt bundesweit gehört, ich bin so Berlin-bezogen. Das wird weltweit gehört. Ja gut, Ingress ist ja auch ein weltweites Spiel. Okay, also die Berliner, die sich der... Ich sag's jetzt nicht nochmal, ich hab's oft genug gesagt.
Ne, ne, die Leute sind von mir gewöhnt, dass hier Sachen immer mehrfach erwähnt werden. Sagt ihr schon, dass die Leute daran gewöhnt sind, dass die Sachen mehrfach erwähnt werden?
Ja, und wer Redundanz verstanden hat, hat auch Redundanz verstanden.
Ja, ach so, genau, und es gibt so diese Level, die man erreichen kann. Also man kann die Sachen eines bestimmten Levels erst benutzen, wenn man diesen Level erreicht hat. Und dafür braucht man Punkte, und das sind Action Points, und wenn man Sachen kaputt macht oder aufbaut, kriegt man Action Points. Und die Level gehen halt von 10.000 Punkten für Level 2 bis 1,2 Millionen Punkte für Level 8. Wobei es aber auch leichter wird, mit jedem Level mehr Punkte zu machen, weil man ja bessere Buster verwenden kann und bessere Resonatoren, obwohl die helfen nicht beim Punkte machen.
Dennis, hast du eigentlich schon ein App.net-Account?
Hab ich mir noch in der vorletzten Sendung hier gemacht. Und hab festgestellt, dass hier mein Kumpel mit seiner Triumph, der twittert, hätte ich jetzt beinahe gesagt. Aber ist egal, der twittert an dir auch. Die zwitschern halt da rum auf dem ADN. Meine Fresse, der macht ja nichts anderes den ganzen Tag. Mit dem gelben Symbol, mit dem Pesthörnchen drin.
Eine Sache wollte ich noch erwähnen. Also, die ernsthaften Spieler erkennt man daran, dass sie einen Akku-Pack dabei haben. Weil nämlich sonst das Telefon nach einer Stunde aufgibt. Und da wollte ich noch ganz kurz, weil ich einen Fehlkauf gemacht habe, noch sagen...
Wir würden es jetzt gerne hier anbieten.
Nicht diesen. Nein, nein, also es geht um nicht um ein bestimmtes Modell, sondern nur, wenn ihr einen Akku-Pack kauft, achtet darauf, dass er einen USB-Lade-Input hat. Wenn euch nämlich sonst das Ladegerät kaputt geht oder verschüttet geht oder sonst wie, aus dem könnt ihr dann nur zuhause laden und nicht auf Arbeit. Also ich empfehle darauf zu achten, dass erstens das Ding sehr schnell lädt, also mit einer hohen...
Aber mal ehrlich, Dirk, du hast ja gesagt, du fährst mit dem Fahrrad und so, ne? Leute, die mit dem Auto fahren, werden ja wohl was im Auto haben. Würdest du dann nicht eher was mit dem Fahrrad irgendwie lädt, die ganze Zeit?
Nein, nein, nein, man muss ja auch nochmal zu Fuß unterwegs sein, um dann, also diese Waffen, diese Radialwaffen, die, wenn man die an einem bestimmten Punkt zündet, da haben sie den höchsten Impact.
Ja, und da kommen die Wände mit dem Fahrrad nicht hin, meinst du?
Genau, da geht man dann zu Fuß die letzten Meter durch die Botanik.
Na gut, aber die meiste Zeit wirst du ja wohl auf dem Fahrrad sitzen und da hast du dein Dynamo und...
Ja, den Dynamo, den muss man doch mit dem Akku puffern, weil du willst nicht, dass dein 400 Euro Telefon kaputt gemacht wird von dem Narbendynamo.
Wo wir bei Android und durch die Gegend fahren, habe ich noch eine andere Anmerkung bzw. Frage. Und zwar habe ich Kenntnisse erhalten von einer Software, die ich glaube ich auch ganz gerne hätte. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, weil ich nicht 100% verstanden habe, was sie jetzt genau macht. Und zwar heißt die Open Signal.
Ah, ich wollte das noch recherchieren. Also das letzte Mal, als ich sie benutzt habe, hat sie aufgezeichnet, wo welche WLAN-IDs zu sehen sind und welche GSM-Zellen, richtig?
Genau, es ist so eine Karte, die... Also ich bin mir halt nicht so sicher, ob das irgendwie eine offene Karte ist, die angezeigt wird und die man dann selber noch aktualisiert oder wo man sich anzeigen lassen kann, wo man ist, oder ob das sozusagen nur der eigene View ist. Also letztlich, woran ich Interesse hätte generell, das gilt im Übrigen auch für iOS, vielleicht hat da irgendjemand einen Tipp, nur Software, die einem die GSM, OMTS, meinetwegen auch gerne WLAN-Infrastruktur in der Umgebung irgendwie anzeigt und Signalstärken notiert und anzeigt, weil ich bin gerade so ein bisschen auf der Suche.
Was willst du damit?
Rauskriegen, wo in einem bestimmten Gebiet was eigentlich zu empfangen sein müsste oder wo man vielleicht noch um die Ecke geht.
Oder gibts doch die tollen Netzabdeckungskarten der Anbieter und die lügen nie.
Ich suche mal nach Open-Cell-ID, da gibt es das für GSM. Für WLAN gibt es immer eine AP. Also ich wollte auch so eine Datenbank haben, um nämlich offline mich zu lokalisieren, weil die WLAN-IDs sehe ich ja und die GSM-IDs sehe ich auch. Und da bin ich auf die Open-Cell-ID. Da, genau, Open-Cell-ID. Da gibt es das für GSM und UMTS. Zum runterladen. Die haben, glaube ich, auch eine AP. Genau, da gibt es auch die Rohdaten. Genau, opencellid.org. Für WLAN gab es von den, da gibt es so eine amerikanische Gruppe von Leuten, deren Namen ich wieder vergessen habe, weil die nämlich nur eine AP hatten und immer gesammelt haben von mir, aber nie was zurückgeben wollten. Wie hießen die dann noch? Ach, da haben wir jetzt schon einen KML-Fall.
Da gibt es einen KML-Fall, das muss ich ja gleich mal.
Genau, und wie hießen die anderen? Vielleicht hat sich das auch geändert. Das ist jetzt auch schon zwei Jahre her, dass ich das recherchiert habe. Kann sein, dass es inzwischen das auch für WLAN gibt, als Datenbank zum Runterladen. Aber eine API gibt es da auf jeden Fall auch schon länger. Ach so, und unter iOS wird es das für WLAN nicht geben, weil du unter iOS leider nicht sehen kannst. Also da kannst du nur das Ding sehen, wo du eingebucht bist. Mit iOS 4 gab es noch eine versteckte API, mit der man auch die anderen Zellen sehen konnte. Aber das gibt es seit iOS 5 leider gar nicht mehr. Aber diese Open-Signal-Web, die wir jungs irgendwann, glaube ich, okay. Also denen kann man ruhig seine Daten geben, wenn ich das richtig erinnere.
Mein Telefon macht Gerach. Was ist hier los? Ah, wieso geht das nicht aus? Ah, sorry. Was ist das?
Ab in die Schemenecke.
Warum spielt das? Ja, es ging nicht.
Ein User.
Das Instacast hat einfach losgespielt.
Von sich aus.
Nee, ich hab's so angeklickt, weil ich wollte es gerade mal ausprobieren, das Instacast auf dem iPhone.
Und wenn man draufklickt?
Ja, dann habe ich alle Buttons gleichzeitig gerückt, hier sogar diesen da. Und es hat trotzdem noch über den Speaker gespielt.
Ein User. Ich hatte doch neulich Martin sogar schon mal gefragt, ob man irgendwie als Abentwickler mit diesem Schieber da anstellt, und da hat er irgendwie nur abgewunken. Mit diesem Laut-Leise- oder auch mit diesem Nacht-Ding.
Profis. Also dieses KML-Fall überzeugt mich noch nicht so ganz.
Da ist wirklich nur ein sehr kleiner Streifen abgedeckt anscheinend.
Ja, es sieht so aus, als ob es hier nur 500 Zellen gibt.
Ach warte mal, naja, das ist glaube ich eine Größenbegrenzung. Willst du es vielleicht lieber mal in Google Maps versuchen?
Das hilft mir nicht, ich will halt an dein Ort fliegen und wissen welches Netz da ist. Und bei diesem Open Signal habe ich gesehen, dass es dann eben auch schön den Range abprozentiert.
Wieso, da steht doch vielleicht das Netz. Klick doch mal dahin, da steht MNC, MCC und LAC. Da weißt du genau. Also MCC ist Deutschland, MNC ist der Netzanbieter. Ich weiß gar nicht welcher, aber...
MCC, MNC, was heißt das?
MCC ist der Mobile Country Code.
Genau, das ist erstmal egal.
Gute alte ECCITT oder ITU Recommendation E123. Kannste nachschlagen, 262 ist der Mobile Country Code für Deutschland. Die Leute, die uns noch Datix P kennen und damals noch mit Pets rumgehackt haben, kennen das auch, das waren nämlich auch die Länder.
Und MNC ist der Netzanbieter.
Der Mobile Network Code. Was ist 7?
Das kannst du rausfinden. Ich weiß es nicht. Lack ist die ID, das ist die Seller-ID.
Das Netz ist ja noch mal unterteilt in sogenannte Location Areas. Da können wir demnächst mal drüber sprechen. Gab es nicht schon 20 Millionen CIEs über GSM-Netz oder so?
Nur über deren Sicherheit, nicht so sehr über die Struktur.
Soll ich dir jetzt 30 Sekunden lang den Erklärbar geben oder wollte das nicht so?
Mir geht es jetzt primär erst mal darum.
Ist aber wichtig, den Lack, damit du das verstehst. Die ID ist nur pro... Aber wenn du jetzt was wissen willst, wenn du schon sagst, da steht ein Türmchen, dann willst du wissen, welcher Operator das ist, guckst du dir an, möchtest gerne 1262H mit einem MNC von 7, solange du noch O2-Kunde bist und dann ist alles toffig.
Und dass da nur dieser Streifen zu sehen ist, liegt an der Limitierung von dem KML-Format in Google Earth. Ich würde das mal in Google Maps reintun, das KML.
KML ist ausgerechnet in Google Earth, wofür es gemacht ist, irgendwie eingeschränkt? Ist ja auch lustig.
Einmal mit Profi.
Vielleicht ist auch das File kaputt.
Der Verlust, gerade ein Network-Request zu machen, der nicht so richtig bedient wird, glaube ich. Na ja, okay, gut, lassen wir das. Aber so eine App gibt es irgendwie nicht außer OVZ.
Was war nochmal die Frage, du wolltest wissen, welcher Operator da Coverage hat?
Ich bin irgendwo in der Pampa. Und jetzt möchte ich gerne wissen, welcher Provider bietet hier UMTS? Da, jetzt, wo ich gerade stehe. Oder wie viele Meter muss ich mich vielleicht noch nach links oder nach rechts bewegen?
Also wo ist das Türmchen, das sich theoretisch versorgen soll?
Achso, da finden wir eine Android-App, wo man gucken kann, welchen Turm man gerade benutzt, zumindest. Da kann man so eine Luft liegen. Nee, da gibt es noch was anderes. Ich habe es schon so lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Wie schaltet man dieses Gerät eigentlich ein?
Das Ding sagt dir, in welcher Richtung der Turm ist, wie weit er weg ist und wo steht er auf.
Ich versage, bei diesem Nexus 7 würde ich schon beim Einschalten. Wie lange will der denn noch laden?
Zeig mal.
Der ist am Strom, so eine halbe Stunde.
Zeig mal ein bisschen länger. Da ist noch nicht viel Strom drin.
Na, der ist immer wieder voll und leer.
Na, wenn dieser Ladedingster immer wieder leer ist, dann ist es auch noch leer. Die Animation heißt nur, dass er lädt. Was ist denn da für ein Netzteil angeschlossen? Was für ein Netzteil? Wie viel Output?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Das dürfte sich dabei um einen Apple-Netzteil handeln.
Und das Kabel ist ein Datenkabel. Manchmal hilft es, wenn man einfach einen Strom-USB-Kabel nimmt. Na, es gibt Kabel, die haben mehr Pins und welche, die haben weniger Pins.
Wenn da mehr Pins sind, dann schadet es.
Dann ist es manchmal langsam mit dem Laden.
Der schummert doch da schon seine Batterie die ganze Zeit auf dem Display hin und her.
Aber es lädt wahrscheinlich nur mit 500 mA.
Und du meinst, es wird besser, wenn man mehr Adern im USB-Kabel gibt?
Weniger Adern. Die Daten kurz schließen. Manche Netzteile liefern mehr Strom, wenn man ein anderes Kabel verwenden muss.
Aber nicht so ein Apple-Netzteil.
Na gut, dann musst du halt warten.
Ein Apple-Netzteil ist toll.
Ich könnte dir auch noch ein Netzteil geben.
Ja, dieses beigelegte Netzteil, das hat irgendwie schon seinen Geist aufgegeben. Das ist erstaunlich.
Willst du ein volles Nexus-Tablet haben?
Nein, ich will meins haben, weil ich habe da dieses blöde Ingress drauf. Und das wollte ich jetzt irgendwie mal starten und irgendwas eingeben.
Ich kann ja mal gucken, wie hier...
Keine Ahnung, ob hier irgendwas blau oder grün ist gerade nicht, dass ich hier irgendwie den falschen Believer oder Non-Believer bin. Ich dachte, es gibt jetzt sozusagen so die angesagte App irgendwie auf Android, mit der man das so macht und mit der man das vielleicht rauskriegen kann. Weil das wäre ja durchaus mal eine Anwendung für dieses Gerät, weil es eben da eine Limitierung nicht hat, die der iOS eben sehr verbreitet ist.
Es gibt diese App, aber ich weiß den aktuellen Namen nicht davon. Aber das wird im Chat doch sicher gesagt worden sein, oder?
Im Chat.
Ja, nicht.
Ich guck gerade. Hier wird gestritten, ob ein Apple-Netzteil toll ist oder nicht.
Ich werde das nachliefern mit dieser App, okay?
Panasonic empfiehlt, seine Geräte mit Apple-Netzteilen zu laden.
Ja, das ist aber ein Acer, was du da hast.
Ich lade meinen Kindl mit einem Apple-Netzteil.
Genau, aus Prinzip.
So.
Ich hab jetzt noch was in eigenem Interesse zu verkünden. Es ist ja bald Republika. Nämlich nächste Woche. Und ja, da wird es auch Podcasting geben. Und zwar live. Denn ich habe mich mit Ralf und Claudia von den Wikigigs zusammengetan. Und wir sind das Sendezentrum auf der Republika. Und das Sendezentrum macht eine Sondersendung. Und wir haben einen eigenen Raum auf der Republika. Und der Raum ist, sagen wir mal, nicht nur jetzt so unsere Redaktion und auch nicht nur der Ort, wo wir die Live-Sendung täglich machen, um 17 Uhr bis 19 Uhr, sondern auch. Und vor allem soll es so ein bisschen auch ein Anlaufpunkt sein für Podcast-Interessierte. Wenn ihr also auf der Republika seid und so ein bisschen die Duftwolke des Podcastings aufstöbern wollt und genug Vorträge gesehen habt über die Monetarisierung von Blogs, dann könnt ihr in Halle 5, das ist, wenn man reinkommt links, der Trakt im ersten Stock. Da gibt es dann so an dem einen Ende, an dem Nordende gibt es so ein kleines Räumchen. Und da sind wir das jetzt nicht besonders riesig. Und wenn da die Live-Sendung ist, wissen wir auch gerade nicht so richtig, wie viele Leute wir da gegebenenfalls noch so als Zuschauer reingepackt bekommen. Aber wir sind da auf jeden Fall nicht, um uns da irgendwie zu einzuschließen und zu verschließen, sondern es soll eben ein Anlaufpunkt sein, wie schon gesagt.
Einfach reinplatzen, über die Groupies rübersteigen.
Wer nicht auf der Republika ist, kann dann aber immerhin zuhören. Nämlich von 17 bis 19 Uhr, wie schon erwähnt, am 6., 7. und 8. Mai. Wir teilen uns die Moderation. Das heißt, es werden immer zwei von uns zum Einsatz kommen. Sprich, an jedem Tag gibt es eine andere Moderatorenkonstellation. Wenn ich mich recht entsinne, geht es mit Ralf und Claudia los und dann mit Ralf, aber das kann sich gegebenenfalls auch noch ändern. Wie auch immer Informationen zu diesem ganzen Climbim gibt es auf diesondersendung.de. Und das wird ja auch mal gesagt sein. So, da gibt es auch noch einen schönen Link mit einer Ankündigung. Da haben wir ein bisschen überlegt, wie wir das alles so nennen. Und das finden wir ganz gut. Die Sondersendung aus dem Sendezentrum. Mal sehen, du sie alle erkennen kannst. Hast du nicht gesagt, Google hat gesagt, man darf nicht mit zwei kleinen Spielen. Guck mal hier auf den Namen, da steht beides mal der selbe Name. Das ist der selbe Account.
Gibt es hier ein Portal in der Meta-Ebene? Ja, es gibt, nein nicht in der Meta-Ebene, aber das wäre mal was. Nein, nein. Nein, Geo-Tagging hier.
Geo-Tagging verboten.
Happy Friends Mural scheint der Spielplatz zu sein gegenüber. Also auf der anderen Straßenseite.
Da geht jetzt Tim mit seinen Kindern nicht mehr hin, seitdem er da weiß, dass da Resonatoren stehen, die seine Kinder verstrahlen.
Ja und die Control-Fields, da ist nämlich gerade ein blaues Control-Field über der Schule. Na ich farm da gleich nach der Sendung. Das ist ja Resistance. Vielleicht kriegt ihr ihn auch auf Level 7.
So Oke, dann hast du doch jetzt bestimmt noch funny Bitcoin-Sachen zu erzählen, habe ich gehört vorhin.
Ja, nicht so funny. Außer, dass Bitcoin Central sich jetzt mal entschieden hat, nach der ganzen Hackerei Social Hacking wie Technical Hacking mal ein bisschen zur Ruhe zu setzen. Hat alle Kunden aufgerufen, mal die Bitcoins abzuziehen, um sich mal eine kleine Austalt zu gönnen, um alles mal ordentlich zu inginieren. Hat man das eigentlich letztes Mal erwähnt, dass mit diesem Wiese das letzte Mal gehackt worden?
Da habe ich ja nicht so komplett zugehört. Ich glaube nicht, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Die zurückzuziehen, die haben gesagt, geht mal alle zur Konkurrenz, wir machen das alles sicher und dann kommt ihr alle wieder.
Naja, die wurden halt zuletzt so gehackt, dass die Leute durch Social Engineering die Rootpasswörter für die Kisten beim Provider sich erigniert haben.
Wait, wait, wait, der Provider hatte die Rootpasswörter?
Ja, oder was auch immer, irgendwas, um die Kisten zu resetten halt. Weißt du, reicht ja, wenn man so was... Admin-Konsole, irgendwie Passwort. Genau. Und wenn es halt an der Stelle dann irgendwann fällt, dann musst du dir glaube ich schon erstmal nochmal ganz deutlich Gedanken darüber machen, wie du da deinen Bitcoin- und Echtgeld-Exchange fährst. Das war eigentlich so die größte Nachricht, das hat aber erstmal eigentlich gar keinen interessiert weiter, der Kurs bleibt da erstmal stabil und ansonsten Mount Gox kämpft ja auch weiterhin noch mit DDoS-Attacken, da gab es doch irgendwie so die Meldung, dass sie jetzt irgendwie eine weitere Währung hinzufügen wollen, oder?
Leitkönen wollen sie hinzufügen, haben sie aber erstmal auf die lange Bank geschoben, weil sie meinen durch die aktuellen Geschehnisse da haben sie jetzt erstmal genug andere Sorgen und sie wollen irgendwie Ende Mai oder irgendwie so noch viel, viel mehr Server dazu packen und irgendwann im Juni wollen sie dann auch irgendwie ihr System auf irgendwas anderes umstellen, was dann irgendwie reichlich, besser, schneller, neuer, toller ist und so weiter und so fort. Was noch interessant war, dieser andere Bitcoin-Laden, der über Polen abgewickelt wurde, wie hieß denn der? Nicht Bitcoin Central, sondern... Ja, könnte sein. Also was ich so richtig gesehen habe, ist, wo irgendwie unter 30-jähriger Typ irgendwie aus Bremen oder sowas, also relativ jung, hat dann schon Konten irgendwie der Millionen Euro irgendwie raufließen. Ich hoffe, die Fakten stimmen jetzt einigermaßen, weil ganz genau habe ich es jetzt nicht gelesen. Aber es ist halt schon auch, dass eine Menge Leute jetzt in den Bitcoin-Markt einsteigen, da viel Geld händeln und aber noch nicht so die Erfahrung oder das halt vorher noch nicht so gemacht haben. Also es ist schon noch ganz schönes Wildwest da draußen. Und dem hat seine Bank dann auch Ärger bekommen, weil einfach zu viel Geld auf seinem Konto da eingeflossen ist. Und die halt auch meinten ja hier, das sieht ja auch nach Geldwäsche aus und so weiter und so fort. Und das wollten sie nicht machen und dann dachte sie, das ist ja ganz easy, dann nehme ich einfach eine Bank in Polen. Es hat dann mit der Bank weitergemacht. Und dann hat wohl aber irgendeine deutsche Staatsanwaltschaft dann auch in Polen irgendwie Amtshilfe ersucht und tralala. Jedenfalls haben sie ihm erstmal alles gesperrt. Weil es war wohl so, dass einige Scammer, die Konten, die sie sich escammed haben, dann direkt zu ihm überwiesen haben, haben sich in Bitcoin auszahlen lassen und waren weg. Also du brauchst ja einen Punkt, wo du deine Kohle herkriegst, und das haben die halt über Bitcoins gemacht. Der hat jetzt auch erstmal die Arschkarte und muss erstmal erklären, dass nicht er selber das war und so weiter. Vielleicht kriegt er das ja auch erklärt, aber toll finden die das trotzdem nicht. Und ich glaube, der kommt nicht mehr so schnell wieder ins Business. Und dann gibt es auch ganz, ganz viele Leute, die da ihre Bitcoins und ihre Euros hatten, die jetzt erstmal gesperrt sind. Vielleicht sind sie noch nicht weg, aber auf jeden Fall erstmal gesperrt. Und die müssen ewig warten, bis sie dann ihre Kohle wieder rankommen. Das ist alles nicht so schön. Also Jungs, wenn ihr da ein Bitcoin irgendwie handeln wollt, oder ihren Euros, dann sucht euch was, wo ihr euch drauf verlassen könnt. Und was auch funktioniert und nicht irgendwie ein, der irgendwie vom DJ zum Exchange-Macher irgendwie wurde.
Ja, das ist aber bei ganz vielen so. Und das sieht man ja von außen manchmal nicht.
Ich finde es auch gar nicht schlimm an sich, wenn einer ist, der meint alles klar, es macht mir Spaß, ich versuche es mal. Der muss sich ja vorher gar nicht auskennen. Kann man alles machen, aber es kann halt immer auch schief gehen. So ist das. Also, ich meine, müssen die Leute halt selber wissen, ob die dann in so einer Sache Vertrauen unter ihre Kohle rumliegen lassen. So, die andere Sache mit den Bitcoins ist, dass, was ich noch mal erwähnen wollte, weil beim letzten Mal habe ich es vergessen, in Berlin-Kreuzberg bildet sich ja so ein kleiner Bitcoin-Kiez, und zwar in der Grefe-Straße, da wo der berühmte Room 77-Laden ist, wo man seine Bürger in Bitcoin zahlen kann. Und wie der Zufall so will, ist morgen der erste Donnerstag im Monat, und da ist wieder Bitcoin-Treffen. Die Burger sind auch sehr super, mir schmecken die sehr lecker. Und was aber noch ganz witzig ist, dass der Besitzer, der Jörg Platzer aus dem Room 77, auch schon bekannter, war auch schon bei uns auf dem Kongress, habe ich glaube ich auch alles schon erzählt, dass er auch die anderen Läden, die da bei ihm in der Straße sind, irgendwie ansteckt, dass sie Bitcoins nehmen, also der Plattenladen daneben, und noch irgendwie zwei, drei weitere Cafés da, oder ich glaube auch so eine Art Jugendherberge, oder irgendwie so, die nehmen auch alle so Bitcoins so einigermaßen. Die haben irgendwie so ein Tablet da, wo sie klicken könnten zur Not, also sie machen jetzt nicht so profimäßig glaube ich, aber haben sie am Start. Ich kann mal kurz hier auch einen Link dazu noch, die haben irgendwie ein Video auch da gedreht vom Guardian, wo ist unser Chat jetzt hin?
Wann ist das Treffen immer?
Erste Donnerstag im Monat. Ja, um 19, 20 Uhr gehst du hin und dann sitzen da so ein paar Jungs. Ich weiß nicht, ob du den kennst, aber der Programmierer der Android-App ist auch immer da.
Ja, Andreas Schildbach.
Genau der, der ist auch immer da, der ist auch ganz nett. Und dann sind auch, wer zum Beispiel, ja jetzt mein Tipp an alle, weil ich werde andauernd gefragt und ich habe immer keinen Bock, dass die Leute ihren Shit mit den Bitcoins aus meiner Quelle machen. Wenn ihr Bitcoins kaufen wollt, dann geht in Room 77 zum Analogdealer. Da kriegt man seine Bitcoins auch analog. Das muss man nicht über mich machen. Also geht dahin und kauft die euch da. Und ja, jedenfalls.
Was kann ich Bitcoins kaufen?
Wovor hast du jetzt konkret Angst? Das habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden.
Na, es kommen Leute zu mir und wollen bei mir Bitcoins haben. Kaufen von dir? Ja, warum geht der denn nicht da und da? Ja, dann kann man ja meine Adresse tracken und so weiter. Aber danke, meine kann man dann tracken. Ja, schön, super.
Ach so, die wollen Spezialdienste in Anspruch nehmen, genau.
Und ja, also das heißt, wer das machen will, der soll seine Bitcoins da in analog sich besorgen. Das geht, da gibt es den sogenannten Bitcoin-Dealer. Und müsst ihr selber rausfinden, wer das ist, ob er da ist, wie er aussieht. Keine Ahnung. Es gibt bestimmt auch mehrere.
Gibt es da noch einen Laden? Ich habe gehört, Davids Kitchen. Ja, genau da, das ist auch ein Laden.
Der hat auch Bitcoins, genau. Wie gesagt, ich habe hier gerade so ein Video gepostet. Kannst du denn die Links damit aufnehmen?
Ich möchte einen B kaufen.
Hier unten drunter? Das haben die bei dem gedreht irgendwie vor einer Weile. Der hatte ja irgendwie so ein... Das war genau da, wo der Crash ist, wo bei dem die Bude voll war. Aber ich glaube, das ist das Ergebnis dieses Videos dann.
Was für ein Video ist das jetzt konkret?
Über die Bitcoin-Szene in Kreuzberg da speziell. Ja, Gräfe-Straße, Elke-Bürgstraße.
Aber was nix kostet, ist auch nix.
Müssen wir uns jetzt nicht komplett geben hier. Aber der Link haben wir irgendwie in den Show Notes.
Genau, ich glaube es gibt auch eine Adresse bitcoinkeats.de oder so. Und muss ich mal kurz gucken, stimmt das auch?
Dort WordPress.
Ja, das ist noch nicht allzu viel, aber ich glaube, da sieht man auf jeden Fall die Greifestraße und schon die ersten vier Läden, da hinten noch zwei. Ja, es geht ab. Ja, jedenfalls morgen wieder. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich selber auch da sein werde, wenn sie so nur ein Kognitor...
Ach, da Urbahnstraße, alles klar, schön, wenn die Straße die Ecke ist.
Direkt bei mir am Ecke, wo ich arbeite. Also im Devil's Kitchen war ich, aber die haben eine Stunde fürs Essen gebraucht, weil der Koch irgendwie was verbaselt hat.
Da muss er erst die Bitcoins wechseln, das dauert eine Weile, bis das bestätigt ist.
Was ist da noch drunter?
Das ist... Der Plattenladen neben ihm.
Ah, man kriegt Platten, man kriegt Burger. Was noch?
Und dann gibt es noch... Da kannst du gleich die Software kopieren und dann die Farbe... Und noch ein Kaffee, also Essen ist gesorgt. Kaffee, Bier, Burger, Kopien.
Und der Witz Kitchen ist ein normales Restaurant, oder?
Ja, und bei Room 77 gibt es ja auch noch hier Rollberger oder Rollberg, also Berliner...
Bier.
Berliner Bier.
Noch ein Bier. Okay, und man muss nicht weit laufen, also wenn man da in der Mitte wohnt, muss man nicht mehr über die Straße gehen.
Ja, kann aber nur sagen, ab 19, 20 Uhr, da ist da die Bude voll, also wenn man wirklich in Ruhe Burger essen wollt, dann vielleicht ein bisschen früher hingehen.
Oder reservieren.
Machen die nicht.
Hab ich schon gesehen.
Ja, aber nicht abends nach 9 Uhr oder so, weil da ist so voll, da lohnt es sich einfach nicht mehr. Hab ich letztens auch probiert, meinten sie, nee, zu spät.
Der Berliner Bitcoin-Kiez, was nicht alles gibt.
Clemens, unsere Spendenadressen stehen auf unserer Webseite, ne?
Clemens, ich hab den Switch eingebaut und der Stream ist bisher noch nicht abgerissen. Vielleicht ein gutes Zeichen.
Liegt nicht an dem Switch. Aber es ist schön, dass du den Switch eingebaut hast.
Wieso liegt es nicht an dem Switch? Jetzt sag mir nicht, dass es nicht an dem Switch liegt. Ich hab diesen scheiß Switch gekauft, weil es am Switch liegt.
Nee, weil du gesagt hast, du wolltest einen Switch haben, der okay ist, den du dir noch leisten kannst.
Ja, und der nicht der Alte ist, weil der Alte hat hier beide Leitungen gekappt. Na was denn sonst? Wenn die Verbindung zwischen diesem Mischpult und diesem Computer, die nur über diesen Switch hergestellt wird, abreißt, während auch diverse andere Verbindungen abreißen, auch der Stream nach draußen.
Das war ja eine Fehldiagnose von dir, dass das abgerissen ist. Also die Verbindung zwischen deinem Pult und deinem Rechner.
Die ist abgerissen.
Egal, du hast jetzt diesen Switch da drin und jetzt ist alles toll?
Bisher ja schon. Warum sagst du mir jetzt, dass das eine Fehldiagnose ist?
Ich wollte dich in dem glauben lassen, dass du das Problem gefunden hast.
Aha, was denkst du, was das Problem ist?
Das wissen wir ja nicht.
Na, ich glaube, es war der Switch.
Antilpherso-Notes. Den hast du jetzt nur angemacht und dann hast du irgendwie zweimal versucht, dich einzuloggen und jetzt läuft das alles noch wie LAN 1 und so oder wie oder?
Ja, ich habe versucht, das Ding zu konfigurieren, aber es klickt nicht gescheitert.
Ich habe da irgendwie versucht... Wir sprechen nach der Sendung nochmal dazu, wie wir dieses Problems generell her werden.
Was?
Das Problem, dass diese...
Wie konfigure ich meinen Switch?
Ja, das ist wirklich nicht einfach. Also man muss diese ganze Foul-Andenke und so weiter. Das UI hat es mir jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht sehr einfach gemacht.
Und du hast schon noch die GUI benutzt. Soll ich dir mal das Kommando-Zeichen-Konfig-File von dem Ding zeigen?
Das Problem ist nicht so sehr das UI gewesen, sondern mein Verständnis von Foul-Laden-Optimierung und Settings und dass dieses Gerät out of the box, obwohl es von Cisco ist, nicht in der Lage ist, sich eine V6-Adresse zu ziehen.
Steht Cisco drauf, aber das hat mit dem richtigen Cisco-Switch nichts zu tun. Aber es ist trotzdem erstaunlich, was der Ding kann. Also ich hab dir den nicht aus Spaß empfohlen. Der einzig komische Teil, den ich wirklich nicht verstehe, ist, es schreit überall rum, es macht vor sechs und hin und her und lalala, aber du musst explizit noch mal einen Haken anmachen, damit er das auch wirklich macht, er konfiguriert sich das alles und dann muss ich aber sagen, nee, ich meine das ernst, hier gibt es wirklich vor sechs und dann zack, das ist gut, dann geht das auch alles.
Den Haken habe ich nicht gefunden. Also ich habe Haken, ich habe verschiedene Haken gefunden, aber danach war...
Du hast noch mehr Haken gefunden.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall auch schon den System Factory Reset gefunden und der hat auch funktioniert.
Den in der GUI oder musstest du den mit einer Büroklammer?
Nein, Büroklammer. Das ist mal als Macintosh User, als man das ja gewohnt.
Verstehe. Ja, aber ernsthaft, das Ding ist für das Geld, weil das kostet, kann das echt eine ganze Menge. Und was ich eben sehr schön finde, ist, es macht keinen Radau. Also der nächstgrößere macht dann ein bisschen Rabatz oder so, aber das Ding hat 20 Gigabit Ports plus noch SFP-Slots und so weiter und macht keinen Rabatz. Wir machen ja hier immer Produktwerke, und die Leute, die sich jetzt fragen, worüber wir reden, wir reden über einen Cisco Small Business Switch SG300, die 20-PoE, Power-OV ist das ja nicht gegeben, also die 2 SG300-20. Ich glaube, der mit PoE, der würde auch bei 20 Ports schon rumlüften, weil dann haut ja 15 Watt aus jedem Port raus.
Ich wollte jetzt ja auch nicht irgendwie Stromschläge verteilen.
Er fragt doch erstmal, das 802.3 AF, der Standard dafür, der guckt erstmal, ob da wirklich, also sagen wir so, das Device, er guckt nicht, sondern das Device, das den Strom haben will, muss ihn auf besonders krude Art und Weise beantragen. Da sind, ich weiß das gar nicht genau, also da sind irgendwelche Widerstandskapazitäten oder sonstige Netzwerke auf bestimmten Adern drauf oder so was, dass sozusagen der Switch gucken kann, habe ich da hinten ein Device, was sowas haben will. Also dass sozusagen, dass ein Gerät ohne Strom selbst zu haben, sagen kann, ich hätte gerne welche. Das ist ja schon mal ingenieursmäßig nicht ganz so einfach. Also ich weiß jetzt echt nicht genau, aber es sind so, wie gesagt, es gibt verschiedene proprietäre Lösungen davon von verschiedenen Herstellern. Der Standard dafür, den du hier benutzt, 802.3af, oder den du ja nicht benutzt, aber den man so allgemein benutzt. Und da kann man mal nach googeln. Aber wie gesagt, da müssen irgendwelche widerstellende Kapazitäten, Dioden, was weiß ich, irgendwas auf den Adern drauf sein, damit der Switch gucken kann, ob du Strom brauchst oder nicht. Das hat sich inzwischen recht gut durchgesetzt. Es gibt eine ganze Menge Geräte. Telefone, Access Points, auch jetzt hatte ich dieser Tage mal ein sehr nettes Gerät in der Hand. Zwar gibt es von der Firma Ubiquiti, gibt es sehr schöne Netzwerkkameras. Outdoor, also schön draußen auch in den Regen zu hängen und so. Auch mit PoE-Betrieben, allerdings haben diese ein Proprietärsystem, da muss man erst so einen Konverter dazwischen hängen, um von 802.3.f diese Ding da powern zu können. Das heißt Ubiquiti Aircam. Kostet, Retail, ungefähr um die 90 Euro, gibt es auch mal ein bisschen billiger, gibt es auch als Dreierpack für 200 Quitsch oder so und macht für dieses Geld, AirVision, einen sehr ordentlichen Bild. Hatte ich jetzt dieser Tage mal viel und wo raus aus einer Kiste bei jemanden dachte, was ist denn das, guckst du mal an und...
Kannst du noch mal die Preislage sagen?
Ein so ein Ding für um die 90 Euro unten oder sowas. Und das macht, wie gesagt, ja da kommt so eine Software auch mit, wo du dann mehrere dieser Kameras verwalten kannst und sagen kannst, wenn da in dem linken unteren Quadrant des Bildes irgendwie was zuckt und dann machst du das und das und so.
Dann sofort schießen.
Dann schießen, dann das Gas einleiten und so. Und das ist aber wie gesagt für den Preis und die macht ein recht schönes Bild. Kann mal gucken, ob ich demnächst noch mal ein Bild, ein Bild ziehe davon, das könnte man mal irgendwo hin tun.
Aircam ist die normale Cam.
Die gibt es noch mal als Indoor, als Dom-Kamera. Die kannst du ja an die Decke hängen, die hat ein weiteres Sichtfeld. Und dann gibt es noch mal so eine Aircam Mini, die finde ich immer im Album.
Wie ist denn die Kamera, die du früher auch schon mal gehabt hattest? Da hattest du auch schon mal so eine Firma vor zehn Jahren.
Ubiquiti ist eigentlich durchaus anders bekannt. Ubiquiti ist ein Hersteller von so Access Points, gerade auch Outdoor und so, die extrem preiswert sind. Das ist eine ziemlich gute Hardware, die die da machen. Selbst die Software ist ganz okay. Die meisten Leute, die sie kennen, flaschen sich aber eh in Open VRT drüber. Das ist wirklich eine sehr ordentliche Hardware für einen sehr günstigen Preis.
Die machen aber nur Power-over Ethernet sozusagen.
Das heißt, du brauchst da so ein spezielles... Nee, die bringen auch so einen Injector mit. Der Witz ist, dass du nur ein Kabel zu deiner Kamera führst. Du führst nämlich nur dein Ethernet-Kabel zur Kamera. Am anderen Ende des Ethernet-Kabels musst du den Strom rein kriegen. Entweder du machst das dadurch, indem du die Kamera an einen Switch dranhängst, der eben auch schon PoE kann. Oder neben dem sozusagen einen Mini-Injector, den liefert Ubiquiti, steckst du sozusagen das Ethernet-Kabel von der Kamera rein in so ein Kästchen. Und da kommt ein Ethernet-Kabel wieder hinten raus. Da ist dann nur noch Ethernet drauf, also nur noch Netz. Das da geht in die Steckdose an. Da gibts dann noch einen Wurfanker, für den du da wieder reinsteckst. Also so ein Stecker-Netzteil. Wie gesagt, Ubiquiti verwendet einen proprietären Hausstandard für die Speisen ihrer Geräte. Allerdings bieten sie auch dann selber wieder Adapter an, was die jetzt kosten, weiß ich nicht, um das auf den Standard 802.3 AF zu bringen. Was ich, wie gesagt, an dem Ding jetzt ganz lustig finde, ist einfach das Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis. Das ist wirklich sehr ordentlich. Und das Ubiquiti-Kram, das gibt es so häufig auch, das ist jetzt kein Exot, den man sich selber importieren muss, aus Taiwan oder aus USA oder sonst wo. Es gibt irgendwie drei Dutzend Händler in Deutschland, die dir den verkaufen. Du kannst einfach bei Amazon gucken, klicken. Und die Kramhaus gibt es auch im 3er Pack.
Indoor ist für Mädchen.
Das kriegt wieder Ärger.
Ja, zu Recht. Na ich brauch ja was Indoor erstmal.
Wen willst du denn Kamera überwachen?
Das sag ich nicht. Aber das hätte mal Beobachtungsbedarf hier. Und wenn die anderen schon 90 Euro kosten, dann kostet diese Mini bestimmt noch weniger oder was?
Die Mini sind immer teuer. Die kosten alle mal so. Klickt einfach mal bei Amazon, wenn ihr das wissen wollt. Oder bei billiger.de oder was weiß ich so.
Hardware-Schotte. Bei ganz vielen Läden kriegst du nur den guten Preis, wenn du über Hardware-Schotte den Link benutzt und zurückkommst. Ich hab das schon ausgetestet. Bei Hardware-Schotte hast du einfach mal 10% mehr bezahlt.
Das einzige Problem bei dem Ubiquiti-Zeug ist, du kriegst das einfach nicht einfach an die Tastatur einnehmen. Dieses Wort ist einfach so krass. Der Dom, den du an der Decke hängst, will der Schotte hier 117 Euro dafür haben. Die wollen 106 Euro haben für die Aircam. Das haben wir aber schon billiger gesehen. Ist egal. Aber wie gesagt, gibt da auch einen Dreierpack von 300 Euro.
Der Hardware-Shot listet nur Läden auf. Der macht ja nicht selber.
Ich weiß, aber das habe ich doch schon billiger gesehen.
Billig, billig, billig.
Die erzeugen übrigens auch einen schönen Stream, diese Kameras. Die machen HD 720p allerdings nur. Und je nachdem, wie viel Bandbreite du ihnen gibst, kriegst du auch schön deine 25-30 Frames pro Sekunde hin.
Das fliegt auch. Und die können auch V6?
Die können auch V6. Ich gucke gleich mal.
Das ist ja ganz interessant.
Night Vision ist jetzt gerade nicht so gut bei den Dingern. Aber die können. Das müssen wir jetzt tagsüber mal machen.
Was nimmt man denn, wenn man Night Vision haben will?
Die Kameras werden dramatisch teurer. Es gibt diesen schönen deutschen Hersteller, Mobotix. Da fängt keine Kamera neu unter 1000 Euro an. Die haben sehr lustige Sachen. Wie gesagt, keine Kamera unter 1000 Euro. Die haben dann auch teilweise zwei Objektive in einem Ding drin, mit unterschiedlichen Winkeln oder mit unterschiedlicher Lichtempfindlichkeit. Eine für Tag und eine für Nacht. Oder eben einen Weitwinkel und einen Zoom. Das ist der Kram, den man an der Tankstelle hängen kann. Diese Mobotix-Dinge haben ein ganz auffälliges Design. Die sind immer so aus, wie Nummer 5 lebt. Die hängen sehr gerne irgendwo rum, wo es nicht aufs Geld ankommt. Also zum Beispiel da, wo Vater Staat oder eine Gemeinde mal so was hinhängt. Also in Potsdam hängen die überall an irgendwelchen Ampelmasten oder sonst irgendwas. Weil, wie gesagt, die sind auch outdoor und die haben sogar noch... Hier ist der In-Hanschluss drin. Früher war das so, dann konntest du die Dinge anrufen. Die haben nämlich auch ein Mikrofon drin und einen Lautsprecher. Dann konntest du den bösen Einbrecher, der gerade deine Wohnung räumt, den du natürlich live beobachtet hast, über ISTN, kannst du dann anrufen, über die Kamera und ihn schelten. Das geht jetzt aus. Sie haben jetzt inzwischen erkannt, dass das mit ISTN nicht mehr ganz so hip ist. Deswegen haben die auch irgendwie so einen ZIP-Client da drin. Das heißt, du kannst den jetzt auch in dein Voice-Over-IP-Netz einbinden und dann anrufen. Aber diese Kamera ist dann relativ spitz gekannt. Wo ich definitiv raten würde, die Hände vonzulassen, sind diese ganz besonders billigen Webcams von Konrad oder ELV oder sonst wo, diese Taiwan-Ware. Da ärgert man sich wirklich nur. Ich habe auch mal gedacht, oh geil, eine Kamera mit 50 Euro, die war so richtig fies. Ich weiß schon, was du meinst, diese Schweden, diese schwedische Ding? Ich glaube, die sind von Logitech übernommen worden. Wie hieß denn denn der Chat? Wo ist der Chat, wenn man ihn braucht? Na Perl nicht.
Verdammt, da bin ich erst drauf rumgeklickt.
Canon, Panasonic.
Wenn du das jetzt recherchierst, habe ich noch mal kurz eine Abdeutnet-Noob-Frage. Mich hat einer angesprochen und wenn ich dem jetzt antworte, geht das dann nur an den? Oder sieht das denn jeder?
Als Post?
Message. Ich glaube, ich bin hier in Messages. Da, da ist eine Message gekommen und wenn ich dem jetzt antworte, kriegt nur der das?
Wo ist die denn gekommen?
Bei meinem Webinterface hier. Welches Webinterface ist das? Omega.
Ja, Privat.
Ah, was ist nicht Privat? So, jetzt haben wir die Show noch total durcheinander gebracht. Gut, also zwei Codes sind weg, wenn man es jetzt eh schon nicht, ich dich jetzt eh schon unterbrochen hab.
Mano Access, genau da ist es.
Access, meine ich, genau, das war das schwedische Bude, glaube ich. Und die sind dann irgendwie gekauft worden von Logitech oder irgendwelchen anderen Sprechen?
Das weiß ich nicht, auf jeden Fall treten sie noch von alleine auf. Die haben natürlich da, also ich weiß, die sind ja sehr lange dabei schon, deswegen habe ich jetzt gerade mal Marktführerschaft unterstellt, keine Ahnung, ob das immer noch gilt. Aber die haben natürlich auch eine enorme Auswahl an Kameras und auch vor allem eine Menge Features.
Die haben auch eine enorme Auswahl an Platin-fahrenden Kreditkarten, die sie akzeptieren, die man nämlich braucht, um ihre Geräte zu kaufen. Also die stehen Mobotics in Sachen Preis-Indix nah. Kann man sich natürlich geben. Also es ist ordentliche Hardware. Ich hatte auch mal eine Axis-Kamera vor vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren. Aber das Zeug ist richtig. Deswegen kam ich überhaupt nicht.
Können die eigentlich WLAN da, diese Detail-Isthito da?
Die Ubiquities?
Nein, die sind Power over Ethernet. Power over WLAN haben wir noch nicht.
Das macht ja auch irgendwie keinen Sinn, wenn man eh schon Ethernet-Kabel hat.
Es gibt diese, wenn du bei Konrad oder EFV klickst, es gibt massenhaft, oder bei Pearl, es gibt massenhaft WLAN-Kameras oder so. Die sind optisch so finster. Und auch das User-Interface ist grottenschlecht. Und keine von denen kann V6. Das war jetzt das letzte Argument, was ich jetzt überzeugen soll.
Aber die anderen, die du empfohlen hast, die können V6.
Das ganze Zeug von Ubiquiti kann das. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher. Irgendwann, vor ein paar Wochen oder Monaten, habe ich mal so ein Video gesehen über diese Firma. Das ist irgendwie ein Spin-Off, glaube ich. Ich weiß nicht, von Motorola oder sonst und was. Wieder so eine Großbude, so eine amerikanische Ingenieurs-Großbude, die sich mal wieder reorganisiert hat. Und da waren irgendwie mal so eine Handvoll von Engineers, die einfach mal gesagt haben, ey, da haben wir jetzt keinen Bock drauf. Wir sind irgendwie eine coole Truppe, wir wollen das mal irgendwie ordentlich machen. Die haben eben angefangen, Access Points zu machen, also Radiotechnik, was sie wirklich aus dem FF konnten. Und wenn du dir diese Videos anguckst, sind die ganzen Typen, die da arbeiten, oder der Großteil der Typen, sind alle schon über 50. Also die haben ihre Radiowellen schon ordentlich eingeatmet die letzten 30 Jahre oder so. Die wissen wirklich, was sie da tun. Und die haben sich gedacht, wir machen jetzt mal eine kleine Bude auf, die einfach mal affordable Hardware herstellt. Und machen das aber mal mit ordentlichem Engineering. Und nicht so, wir hauen mal schnell in China ein paar Bauteile zusammen und wichsen eine Software drauf. Sondern das macht für den Preis einen sehr ordentlichen Eindruck, muss ich wirklich sagen.
Kann man mal erwägen, ist vor allem dann auch nicht gleich so ein totaler Fehlkauf.
Eben, deswegen kam ich überhaupt drauf. Weil, ja.
Und den Hardware, also man connectet sich dann wirklich von außen direkt auf die Kamera. Und dann kriegt man das in welchen Protokollen vor die Nase geworfen.
Kannst dich mit dem Webbrowser draufklicken, der heute was um die Ohren hat. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, was da drin als Transportsystem hat. Ich hab mal drauf geguckt, da die Dinge auch RTSP sprechen. Also auch schon moderne Protokolle sozusagen für solche Geschichten haben. Mit VLC zum Beispiel draufgeklickt auf das Ding.
Ja, genau, das hätte ich nämlich jetzt...
Ja, und dann gibst du sozusagen im RTSP, kannst du auch dein Username, Passwort und so vergeben. Oder das offen lassen. Dann gibst du so als Parameter in dem All, gibst du dann an, was für ein Format du haben willst und Framerates und so weiter.
Und das dann halt auch über V6 und dann hat man sozusagen auch das Problem gelöst.
Ja, das kannst du auch machen.
Und RTSP macht dann auch mit Kinvort und so?
Kannste ja optional anmachen, annipsen.
Das kann auch durch VLC?
Ich denke mal, müssen wir mal gucken. Stream? Ich denke, der wird fragen. Kannst ja mal anmachen. Ja, das ist echt immer wieder toll. Arab. Das ist echt super, dass diese Hersteller... Das nennt man als Feature, ne? Der Marketing-Fuhr sagt, wir brauchen hier was für einen Flyer. Was kann das so für Protokolle? Ja, das macht so HTTP.
Ja, das ist nicht genug, das ist nicht genug.
Wir brauchen da was. Ja, dann schreibst du halt noch irgendwie UPNP noch mit hin.
UPNP ist ja zumindest ne Aussage. Das ist TCP und UDP kann irgendwie, finde ich ja jetzt schon mal krass. Und AAP ist auch geil. ICMP ist auch super. Und RTCP, weiß ich gar nicht, was das ist, um ehrlich zu sein. Wen? RTCP, was bitte ist RTCP?
Ist das nicht so?
Ist das Time Control? Das ist der Stream und das ist der Control dafür.
So, jetzt guck ich einfach mal, weil ich schon gefragt hab, das mach ich jetzt mal vorsichtig. Ich wollte schon sagen, da fehlt DNS, aber nein, DNS kann's auch.
Also bei Access gibt's einen schönen Produktselektor, da kann man dann irgendwie wirklich auch so die Features da anklicken, die man gerne haben will. So mit Day- und Night-Support und so, mit Audio-Support. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob sie bei Audio nur in oder out meinen. Also dieses Kamerathema finde ich interessant, da müssen wir uns irgendwie mal ein bisschen mehr beschäftigen. Nur nach Preisen kann man das hier nicht sortieren. Das wäre mal was. Ich wollte mich nochmal bedanken. Und zwar bei den zwei Leuten, die mir irgendwie USB-Verlängerung von Apple zugeschickt haben, als großes Kino. Die sind ja auch schon teilweise erfolgreich zum Einsatz gekommen.
Das waren die mit dem Steg.
Ja, genau, der ist richtig gut festhalten und so weiter. Ich hab eben gerade noch eine andere Stelle gefunden, wo ich die zum Einsatz gegeben hab.
Ich kiffel mir da auch immer einen ab, da Stecker reinzukriegen.
Ja, aber wenn er drin ist, ist er drin.
Der hält.
Das ist der Vorteil. Ah ja, und dann hab ich noch was.
Sekunde mal, wo du gerade sagst, Leute, die dir Sachen zuschicken. Zu der letzten Sendung hat dir jemand was zugeschickt für das Mobile-Max-Team. Das hast du letztes Mal schon unterschlagen und jetzt wollen wir das haben. Du hättest das halt nicht öffentlich in der Not Safe For Work Sendung machen sollen. Das haben jetzt Tausende von Leuten gehört, dass du was gekriegt hast für Mobile-Max, was du uns nicht abgeliefert hast. Das finde ich nicht okay. Zumal wir auch schon keine Mobile-Max-T-Shirts haben, die wir Freitags anziehen können.
Ich mach mich fertig. Ich gucke noch mal die Kiste, aber ich weiß gerade, ich habe keinen Überblick. Das ist alles ein bisschen schwierig.
Ich habe noch ein Ablenkungsthema. Kennt ihr Fluid? F-L-U-I-D? Das ist eine App, mit der man Browser machen kann. Und ich wollte noch ein Feature sagen, wofür es sich lohnt, das Ding zu kaufen. Das ist nämlich der separate Cookie Store. Ich habe damit Facebook eingeknastet auf meinem Rechner. Also Facebook benutze ich nur in der Fluid App, die einen separaten Cookie Store hat. Und darin mache ich Facebook auf. Das heißt, mein normaler Browser kennt den Cookie von Facebook nicht und benutzt den auch nicht. Wenn ich Facebook machen will, gehe ich in die Fluid App mit Facebook.
Der Aluhut unter den Browsern.
Genau, ich habe nämlich gerade ein Updote-Net-Fluid gemacht.
Ist nicht so, dass wenn du auf irgendeine Seite gehst, so wie früher bei Heise, die haben ja nun inzwischen was dagegen getan, als wenn da der Like-Button kommt, dass sie das sowieso auch schon checken?
Das machen halt nicht alle.
Ja eben. Also bei Heise muss man erst klicken, damit das gecheckt wird, aber bei anderen natürlich leider nicht.
Aber guck mal, wie viele Fluids ich habe.
Das heißt, du brauchst fast gar nicht mehr irgendwie...
8 x 5... 40. Na ja, nicht ganz. 42. Und dann kann man sich halt auch so Stalker-Accounts machen.
Na ja, Stalker-Accounts. Und dann bist du ja doch bei Facebook. Erzählt mir doch.
Ja, mit meinem Stalker-Account. Nein, bei Facebook. Ja genau, das ist nämlich das Problem. Bei Facebook...
Der Stalker-Account von Dirk Jäckel heißt nämlich MMMM, lass mich los, MMMM.
Also Fluid kann ich sehr empfehlen. Und mit dem separaten Cookie Store nochmal extra. Also du kostest halt 5 Euro. Oder 5 Dollar. So, da sind die Kekse.
Also ich hab einen Umschlag gefunden, da ist nichts mehr drin.
Ich erinnere mich nicht mehr.
Die 500 Euro Scheine sind alle weg.
Also Uwe, du weißt wahrscheinlich, wer gemeint ist. Vielleicht schickst du mir noch mal eine Mail und sagst mir, was da drin war. Weil ich bin mir sicher, dass ich das schon irgendwie zum Einsatz gebracht habe. Aber ich erinnere mich jetzt einfach nicht. Es ist so viel Post hier. Ich komm echt nicht mehr hinterher.
Und die Altersdemenz.
Und die Altersdemenz und überhaupt. Das macht die Sache schwierig. Ich hab dann auch noch einen Tipp bzw. einen Wunsch. Und zwar den Nils, der hier letztes Mal zu Gast war, der hat ja sehr erfolgreich dieses Ding abgefeiert, alle Clients für up.net in so einer Google Spreadsheet Matrix unterzubringen. Und dann quasi rein zu erfassen, welcher Client welches Feature macht. Und ich dachte mir so, das wäre doch mal eine tolle Sache, das Ganze für Podcast-Clients zu machen. Ich hab auch schon ein paar Mal versucht, mir halbwegs einen Überblick zu besorgen, wer kann was. Das Schwierige daran ist, dass man erst mal sich natürlich so ein bisschen auf Features einigen muss. Beziehungsweise vielleicht klappt das ja auch einfach so automatisch. Ich hab da mal was vorbereitet. tinyuol.com/podcastclientsbringt euch zu diesem Spreadsheet. Und da könnt ihr einfach mal drin rumschreiben. Das Ganze ist jetzt einfach mal ein Experiment. Da steht derzeit noch nicht viel drin, was man verlieren könnte. Von daher kann man es einfach mal so probieren. Und wäre schon mal ganz wertvoll, überhaupt Podcast Clients in ihrer Gänze zu erfassen. So ein paar, die mir so aus dem Kopf eingefallen sind, die habe ich schon mal reingeschrieben. Und die Spalten sollen dann eben Features beschreiben. Da ist jetzt noch quasi nichts drin. Also ihr könnt euch mal Sachen, die euch wichtig erscheinen oder die ihr vielleicht sogar auf mehrere Clients zurückführen könnt, wo es die gibt oder wo nicht, da reinschreiben. Also Sachen wie, wenn du Kapitelmarken unterstützt, gibt es Kapitelnavigation. Ich weiß nicht, was würde euch so aus dem Stand einfallen? So ein Sleep-Timer könnte was drin sein. Eine Todmann-Taste hätte ich ehrlich gesagt gerne, aber ich glaube, das kann doch keiner. Also ich habe mir mal überlegt, wie man das machen könnte. Das ist eigentlich ein sehr einfaches Feature. Wenn du sagst, ich möchte jetzt den Podcast beim Einschlafen hören, dann kannst du den Klein so einstellen, dass er alle fünf Minuten automatisch stoppt oder alle zehn Minuten. Also irgendeine Zeit stellst du ein und der stoppt automatisch nach fünf Minuten, sodass du dann immer wieder knipsen musst und weiterhörst.
Hätte ich eine bessere Idee. Der wird einfach nur ein bisschen leiser.
Und dann?
Das merkst du und dann drückst du eine Taste und dann geht er wieder langsam auf normal-Lautstärke zurück. Wenn du nicht die Taste drückst, wird er immer leiser.
Aber du hast auch keine Taste. Du hast ja nur die Start-Stop-Taste.
Ist doch egal, welche Taste du drückst, irgendwas.
Ja, aber kann man das abfangen als iOS-App-Developer? Kann man sagen, hier dieser Play-Pause? Ja, doch kann man eigentlich, ne?
Irgendeine Taste.
Aber leiser, weiß ich nicht, du könntest so einen Ton einspielen.
Musst du ja nicht, du machst einfach leiser. Du willst ihn ja auch nicht wecken.
Ja, aber vielleicht tut der Podcast ja leiser. Na ja, weiß ich nicht, müsste man ausprobieren.
Egal, wenn der Podcast leiser ist und der drückt, dann weißt du ja auch, dass der User noch wach ist.
Ja, oder so ein Ton, als wenn die Batterie leer geht.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das da mittendrin immer wieder haben will. Ich würde leiser okay finden.
Oder so.
Ich würde langsam leiser machen, der User merkt es.
Dennis Vorschlag auch sehr gut. Was geben wir denn so vor Töne von sich, wenn die Sendung so langsam hier zu Ende geht? Ja, sowas. Sag mal nochmal Podcast-Features, die ihr benutzt bei Clients. Podcast-Client-Features.
Ich benutze keine Podcast-Features.
Sachen, die du vermisst, wenn du deinen Client wechselst, Sachen, die du toll findest, dass du die in deinem mobilen Ding irgendwie vorfindest, weil iTunes die nicht hat, so Dinge.
Ich find's praktisch, wenn so ein Client anfängt, das runterzuladen und ich schon gleich rein hören kann und gleich während des Downloads.
Abspielen während des Runterladens bzw. das, was gestreamt ist, zu nutzen als... Genau.
Das hat mein Client auch.
Suchen finde ich zum Beispiel auch ganz toll. Das hat keiner, den ich bisher getestet habe.
In Show Notes suchen oder...
Nee, ich hab ja alle möglichen Episoden drin und Feeds und manchmal suche ich eine Sendung, die ich gehört habe oder die ich noch hören wollte. Oder so eine Playlist, so eine Liste mit, was ich mir demnächst anhören will. Manchmal entdecke ich so die Sachen, während sie runterladen, aber ich kann mir nichts vormerken zum Anhören.
Ja, man will so eine Queue haben, wo man Sachen hören kann.
Genau, wo man sagen will, das ist das nächste, was ich hören will, das ist das nächste, sowas. Ja, und Show Notes im Player wäre zum Beispiel noch so ein Feed. Aber das sind mehr so Sachen, die ich gerne sehen würde. Ich spreche jetzt erst mal von Sachen, die es schon gibt.
Ach so, diese Geschwindigkeit zum Beispiel, im Mobile Max kann man auf 1,2-fache Geschwindigkeit hören. Bei 1,5 wird es schon kritisch. Vielleicht finde ich zumindest.
Ja. Also tinyurl.com/podcastkleines, das ist schon im Chat. Und vielleicht fallen euch ja gute Sachen ein. Und dann können wir das alles mal erfassen und mal gucken.
Das ist jetzt auf der Plattform unabhängig?
Ja, Android ist drin, iOS, Windows, Linux, Unix, you name it, andere kann man da auch noch mit hinzufügen. Was gibt es noch? Windows Phone, gab es noch andere OS auf den Podcast kleines vielleicht zu haben sind? Was gab es denn da noch? Da gab es auch was, war da nicht mal was mit Nokia? Wie heißt das jetzt? Ach nee, Nokia ist ja auch Windows Phone. Huckel, sag mal ein mobiles Betriebssystem.
Symbian.
Vielleicht will ich mich nicht traut zu sagen. Es gibt Podcast-Klans auf Symbian. Kann man ja reinschreiben, wenn jemand einen kleinen kennt, soll er es einfach reinschreiben. So, was haben wir noch?
Lustige Ups.
Oder sonstige nützliche Sachen. Die Republika hat eine eigene App und schickt einem tatsächlich Notifications, wenn sich sowas wie eine Speaker-Beschreibung geändert hat. Das fand ich schon mal ganz cool. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Wie ist denn die Homepage von ADN oder wie haben die eine Seite und einen Namen?
Die wollen, dass ich meine E-Mail-Adresse konfirme, aber ich kann nirgendwo die E-Mail nochmal schicken.
Ah, warte mal. Ich glaube, ich habe dieses Teil noch nicht richtig frei gegeben. Warte mal, ich glaube, ich muss das mal richtig frei geben. Ich habe mir, Entschuldigung, ich dachte, das wäre schon Public. Oh Gott, jetzt muss ich Google. Vertraulich, öffentlich, im Web. Jeder, der über den Link verfügt, was will man haben? Ich mache mal hier öffentlich im Web. Scheiß drauf. Jeder im Internet ist zur Anzeige berechtigt. Die zur Anzeige. Ihr sollt mich nicht anzeigen, ihr sollt arbeiten. Hier, darf bearbeiten. So, jetzt haben wir das hier.
Ihr sollt nicht anzeigen, ihr sollt arbeiten.
Jeder im Internet ist zur Bearbeitung berechtigt. Entschuldigung, ich dachte, das hätte ich schon getan. Jetzt dürft ihr es nochmal probieren.
Ich sehe den gar nicht. Ach, schon.
tinyyule.com/podcast-clients. Soll ich es nochmal posten für dich?
Nein, ich schalte einfach hoch. triggertrepp.com.
Jetzt geht es los.
Das ist auch schon sieben Minuten her.
Genau, jetzt gibt es nämlich hier, ich habe auf einmal alles voll mit irgendwie Request to Share, tralala. Das könnte, das lösche ich gleich mal, jetzt dürft ihr alle sozusagen. Na ja, wenn ich mich mal mit Google so gut auskennen würde wie Dirk.
Ich bin als dieses spreadsheet auch nicht.
Das wiederum benutze ich schon häufiger, muss ich zugeben, weil das eigentlich die einzige Methode ist, die ich kenne, mit der man mal eben so ein Formular für das Web machen kann und Daten einsammeln kann. Das ist ganz praktisch.
Ja, also ich benutze schon Google Docs für meine Präsentationen, damit ich die gleich als Link mit reinschreiben kann, aber nicht Spreadsheets, keine Anwendung für.
So, aus der Abteilung Lustiges im Internet wollte ich noch hier was präsentieren. Habt ihr das mit diesem Game-Dev-Tycoon-Spiel mitbekommen?
Ja, geil, das war echt schön.
Das ist echt cool. Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Das ist wirklich lustig. Und zwar haben sich da ein paar Spieleprogrammierer zusammengetan und haben irgendwie ein Game geschrieben, was simuliert, dass man ein Spieleentwickler-Bude sei.
Ach doch, das habe ich doch gesehen.
Ja, also man gibt ja so Spiele mit sei, dein eigenes, bau dein Business auf, lalala. Railroad Tycoon ist da die Vorlage.
Und jetzt gibt es auch Software Developer Tycoon.
Genau, jetzt kannst du sozusagen auch Software Developer sein und haben das so wie die üblichen Upstores bereitgestellt. Ich weiß gar nicht, was da die Plattform war. Was war denn da die Plattform überhaupt?
Habe ich auch nicht drauf geachtet.
Für Mac, genau, also es ist eigentlich für Mac. Und dann haben sie selber von dieser Version eine Pirate Version sozusagen hochgeladen und haben dann aber da eine Änderung vorgenommen, dass nämlich dort die Software Developer eben mit Software Piraterie zu kämpfen haben, was in der normalen Version halt nicht so der Fall ist. Und dann schlugen halt diese Leute, dann schlugen die Leute im Forum auf und fragten halt, wie sie irgendwie gegen diese Software Piraten irgendwie angehen konnten.
Das ist doch nicht so cool.
Allein für den Joke, irgendwie hat sich die Arbeit wahrscheinlich schon gelohnt, das ist echt super.
Ja, sie haben aber auch gesagt, dass sie 97% piratet von ihrer Version haben, also nur 3% haben es gekauft.
Aber die Leute, die es gekauft haben, haben halt dieses Problem nicht.
Wer weiß, vielleicht finden die ja jetzt eine Lösung.
Die Lösung ist, kauft ihn.
Wenn die keine finden so, dann... So, ich sehe schon hier, das spreadsheet wird angenommen. Das sieht ganz cool aus, muss ich sagen. Das hat was.
Ja, echt viele Hörer, alter Schwede. Aktive Hörer.
Apropos, wir wollen unser Hörer-Meter wieder haben.
Hörer-Meter? Ja, müsste man mal.
Ja, echt mal, mach doch mal was.
Ach, Pocketcast gibt es auch für iOS.
Ja, Pocketcast kommt im Wesentlichen, glaube ich, für iOS.
Aber dann muss ich es ja nochmal kaufen.
Ja, aber diese Podcast-Client übersicht, da bin ich sehr scharf drauf, hat natürlich verschiedene Hintergründe. Erstens interessiert mich das grundsätzlich, zweitens wäre das mal eine schöne Quelle, um überhaupt mal so Feature-Vergleich zu machen und mal zu schauen, was gibt es überhaupt für Clients. Flatter können wir natürlich da auch noch mit reinschreiben. Und, ähm, alle ist schon flatter.
Jetzt störe die Hörer nicht vom Arbeiten.
Nichts. Nicht Finger weg von dem Schiettimp.
Ja, ja, das regelt sich alles von alleine. Man muss auf das Internet vertrauen. Ja, mich interessiert es natürlich auch gerade im Hinblick auf PodLav, welche Clients man vielleicht als nächstes auch mal angehen sollte, die es vielleicht wert sind, angesprochen zu werden, etc. Jetzt soll man noch ein Feld einführen für Responsivität bei Feature-Requests. Genau.
Es ist echt irre, wie die da drin rumhacken. Ich würde das auch haben. Ich habe häufiger mal irgendwelche dämlichen Sheets auszufüllen. Kann man das nicht auch mal so crowdsourcen? Das finde ich sehr... Ja, hat was. Ich nutze das auch täglich, aber wir sind halt nur zu dritt, wie wir da drin rumstochen oder zu viert. Wie viele Leute hast du jetzt? 20, die dir gleichzeitig in dem Sheet rumhacken?
Keine Ahnung, wie viele das sind.
Da oben rechts oben.
Ah, 43 weitere Betrachter.
Betrachter, okay, da sind natürlich wieder die Leecher dabei. Ja, da sind auch wir dabei. Ob man mit deinem Aluhut-Browser wieder da ist.
Das muss an mir liegen, die anderen schaffen es ja offensichtlich.
Hast du wieder einen flüssigen Browser genommen?
Nee, in dem Fall habe ich Firefox. Ich bin ja ein großer Firefox-Besitzer.
So, alle stöhnen.
Ja, jetzt ist ja auch bald das Ende Schluss. Die Solidarität hat jetzt bald ein Ende.
Einen habe ich noch. Einen hast du noch. Ja, dabei habe ich es von der Liste. Gibt es hier irgendwie eine, ich weiß jetzt auch gar nicht, die Ärzte, ich weiß gar nicht, aber kennt ihr dieses Problem, dass ihr irgendwie einen Termin bei einem Arzt haben wollt, aber euch fällt das irgendwie immer nachts ein?
Ja, dann geht dann mal nur der Anrufbeantworter ran.
Ja, dann kannst du halt keinen machen und zu so normalen Tageszeiten irgendwie so, diese Problematik.
Was mich viel eher schockiert in diesem Zusammenhang ist, die Ärzte drücken ja dauernd immer komische Pappkarten in die Hand. Ich hab jetzt jeden Arzt, den ich in den letzten Jahren, dem man begegnet ist, mir Freude strahlt oder solche Sprechstundenhilfe, immer diese Pappkarte aufdrücken wollte, die man umklappt, hinten steht dann dein Termin drauf oder so. Und vorne stehen immer die Fax-Nummern drauf, Telefon und Fax. Und ich denke so, schön, dass sie ihre alten Visitenkarten noch aufbrauchen. Aber sagen sie mir doch bitte noch mal ihre E-Mailer, dass sie schreiben, wir haben hier dazu. Sowas haben wir nicht.
Also, ein QR-Code wäre cool mit dem Termin, dass du dir einfach kurz was hinhalten, wo du den QR-Code abscansst, und dann hast du den Termin in deinem Terminkalender.
Die Dinge ändern sich.
50 Bitcoins weniger auf der Wallet.
Vielleicht hier in Prinzselberg, die schwäbischen Ärzte.
Ja, also, weiß nicht, ich hab einen Zahnarzt, der schreibt dann sogar irgendwie regelmäßig, dass man mal wieder rumkommen sollte und so. Und auch ansonsten geht das so.
Das ist ganz gut per E-Mail.
Aber trotzdem, Termine sind ja immer so eine Sache, weil du musst ja da auch Interaktionen betreiben. Und es gibt hier eine apparzttermine.de, die tatsächlich, die planken sich irgendwie in diese Arztsoftware rein.
Machen für dich den Arzt voll drauf.
Und du kannst halt wie bei MyTaxi, quasi dir da einen Termin irgendwie mit dir abholen.
Okay.
Wie du dir halt auch mit MyTaxi irgendwie einen Taxi holen kannst.
Und das wird von allen Ärzten unterstützt?
Der Mal, wie gesagt, gerade Ärzte vor drauf stehen, dass sich ihr Bein einplackt. Ich hab's getestet. Du wählst irgendwie deinen Ort aus. Die rufen bestimmt an. Dann kannst du halt irgendwie sagen, was hättest du denn gern hier? Blablabla. Der Zahnarzt, der ich gerade erwähnte, war halt dabei.
Die Pizza, die die Faxe schickt.
Du musst allerdings auch noch deine Versicherungsart dazu angeben.
Du musst privat auswählen, sonst geht er gar nicht.
Da ist ein Patient, Error.
Naja, funktioniert auf jeden Fall, ist relativ easy. Wie du kannst jetzt einen Termin festlegen, du kannst jetzt eine Bestätigung, dass du den Termin hast. Ich seh, wie weit der Zahnarzt entfernt ist. Und hier gibt's sogar Fotos von dem Zahnarzt.
Da stehen sowohl die Ärzte total drauf, und die Sprechstundenhilfen finden es super geil, wenn man an ihrem Arsch vorbei da Termine macht.
Die haben da Optin gemacht.
Die tauchen da nicht auf, wenn die nicht ja dazu gesagt hätten.
Ist mir schon klar.
Die müssen wahrscheinlich auch eine Leitung haben.
Sonst wäre das ein lustiger Feature, wenn du ein App hättest, wo du sagen kannst, hack doch mal bitte meinen Hausarzt. Und schummel mich da mal, mach mir meinen Termin. Ich glaube, da würden echt viele Leute eine Menge Geld verzeihen. Vor allen Dingen bei so Fahrerärzten.
Einfach die Plätze versteigern.
So Röntgenärzte und so was, die ja auch immer gerne Termine für 2016 vergeben und so. Da gibt es bestimmt Bedarf dafür. Geil. Du wohnst ja auch in einer Stadt. Sorry, dass ich jetzt dein Spielzeug kaputt gemacht habe, aber ich finde es echt... Cool, wie heißen die Arzttermine? Arzttermine. Meine Erfahrung mit Ärzten im Zusammenhang mit elektronischen Medien, mit Neuren ist doch eher negativ geprägt. Aber ich lasse mich gerne eines Besseren belehren. Ich probiere das sofort aus. Gleiches. Jetzt muss ich mir nur noch irgendeine Krankheit suchen, die ich haben könnte.
Genau.
Muss man aber nehmen, so für Ärzte, wo man normalerweise keinen Termin kriegt. Also irgendein Augenärzt oder sowas sind da auch ganz berühmt dafür.
Oh man, ich habe ja noch was Schönes zum Ausklagen. Das ist geil.
Jetzt wird ausgeklungen.
Haben wir es? Ich glaube, wir sind durch, oder? Ich bin auf jeden Fall durch. Also relativ kurze Sendung.
Doch nur dreieinhalb Stunden, sehr gut.
Wir müssen die Bits sparen, die Drossel kommt, und Tim kann nicht mehr so viele Bits durch die Gegend schieben.
Okay, dann sagen wir Tschüss, wa?
Das wird ja nie.
Tschüssi. Wink, wink.
Please demonstrate for our technicality challenge friend.